Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Hast du Elon Musk gesehen?
Ja.
Hat er den Hitlergruß gemacht?
Vielleicht sagte er dreimal von Herze Köln à l'Art. Hättest du gedacht, dass wir in einer Zeit leben, jetzt, in der man darüber diskutiert, ob Elon Musk einen Hitlergruß gemacht hat, wo alles so offensichtlich ist und zugleich die Ambivalenz natürlich von ihm noch da ist, dass er gewisse Großformeln dabei weggelassen hat, dass man darüber noch diskutiert und in der Welt Rechtfertigungen erscheinen?
Ja, ich hab gleich Clips dazu, aber wir haben aus eigener Kraft Argumentation in diesem Podcast, denn wir haben ja...
Rutger Brechmann.
Der ja die Frage stellte, was ist mit diesen Politikern, die sich auf großer Bühne immer unerhörtes trauen, von dem wir wissen im sozialen Nahfeld geht das irgendwie nicht.
Ja.
Also irgendwie mit einem Kanzler zusammensitzen und sagen, ja ja Herr Kanzler, Ihre Agenda ist genau richtig, ich bin gerne Ihr Finanzminister, Sie sind der beste Typ der Welt. Dieser Kanzler hat gezeigt, dass was möglich ist und dann verlässt du den Raum, Ronsheimer ruft an und er fragt, haben Sie eine Meinung zum Kanzler? Und du sagst, das ist das größte Arschloch der Welt, der verrät uns alle und Deutschland geht den Bach runter. Muss man sich ja trauen. Und manche Menschen trauen sich etwas auf großer Bühne, was sie sich in Angesichts des Kanzlers nicht trauen. So und Ihnen mask hat sich da etwas getraut, dass nun interessanterweise, du hast es gesagt, von der Welt verteidigt wird. Ja. Jetzt fragen wir uns natürlich, wenn die in der Welt angestellt werden, ihren komischen Springerkodex unterschreiben, Israel, Amerika, Transatlantik und so weiter und so fort, begrüßen sie sich dann mit Hitlergrüßen?
Ich glaube nein. Und das ist ja ganz lustig, auch dann zu sehen, dass Elon Musk ja nochmal zugeschaltet war beim AfD-Parteitag und dort gesagt hat, um das jetzt ganz kurz zu halten, lass das mal mit diesem Schuldkult sein, warum immer Holocaust, denk nicht immer über die Geschichte nach. Und da hat jetzt Döpfner einen Meinungsbeitrag geschrieben, so ginge es ja nun nicht. Und das war ja dann ganz lustig, dass da also Döpfner plötzlich eine Kritik an Elon Musk formuliert. Natürlich ist dieser Text auch sehr amüsant zu lesen, denn eigentlich müsste der natürlich so lauten, lieber Elon Musk, alles gut und schön, dass du dich für den Rechtsdruck einsetzt. Das tun wir ja auch. Aber wir wollen schon auch noch, wenn es uns passt, den Holocaust instrumentalisieren für unsere Zwecke. Deswegen können wir das jetzt natürlich nicht ganz so machen, wie du das vorschlägst. Da müssen wir dich mal ins Gebet nehmen und dir zeigen, wie wir hier schon seit vielen Jahrzehnten Politik machen. Also es ist wirklich ein Zusammentreffen der Multimilliardäre, die sich noch nicht ganz fein abgestimmt haben.
Genau und das ist doch toll, weil wir in diesen aufgeregten Zeiten jetzt eine Problemlage haben, die offensives und etwas ehrlicheres, authentisches Sprechen verlangt, ermöglicht. Also während sich Döpfner im Hintergrund hält und glaubt, er zieht hier Stricken, indem er Elon Musk einen Gastbeitrag genehmigt und dann im Spiegel gerätselt wird, ob das jetzt Döpfner eingefädelt hat oder nicht. Und wir uns alle denken, ja genau, das sind die wichtigen Fragen. Haben wir doch jetzt so einen Moment, wo alle so ein bisschen ehrlicher damit umgehen und Döpfner sich denkt, nee, ich rufe heute doch mal in der Redaktion an, statt direkt auf den Golfplatz oder ins Museum zu gehen, um kurz der Öffentlichkeit zu vermitteln, Hitlergrüße gehen doch zu weit. Ist nicht ganz vereinbart.
Ja, beziehungsweise das, was er da sagte mit der deutschen Schuld bei dem Parteitag. Bei den Hitlergrüßen war ja interessant, interessant war ja, dass zugleich davor in der Welt ja Rechtfertigungen schrieben, dass jetzt irgendwie die linke Woche Bubble da Hitlergrüße oder was er kennen will. Also das war ja auch Tenor dann auf Twitter von vielen, nennen wir sie mal rechten Journalisten, dass sie die ganze Zeit so getan haben, als sei das einfach nur ein Winken, irgendetwas.
My heart goes out to you. Ich brauch mich nicht mal hier am Tisch.
Ja, bitte nicht, dass wir hier noch gewandt werden.
Geht das auch im Sitzen?
Ja, das wäre auch eine interessante Frage.
Ich dachte die Deutschen stehen anständig, wir kommen nachher drauf zurück. Also zu diesem Moment des ehrlichen Sprechens. Wir haben gestern am 30. im Deutschlandfunk, der macht ja immer eine Tageszusammenfassung ein Interview. Wir haben ja in dieser Tageszeit immer ein Interview-Gast.
Ja.
Und es hat sich ein aktiver CDUler aus dem Bundestag, aus der März-Fraktion, der nicht mitstimmte oder sich enthielt, also er hat teilgenommen, der eigentlich, ich weiß nicht ob er sich enthalten oder dagegen gestimmt hat, im Radio sagt, mein Chef hat den Zauberlehrling gemacht. Er ist die Geister nicht wieder losgewonnen. Und das fand ich cool.
Ganz seltener Moment, man könnte ja jetzt mal da bleiben, denn das Erfolgsrezept von Donald Trump war, den Leuten erfolgreich zu vermitteln, dass er selbst glaubt, was er sagt.
Ja.
Was nicht schwierig ist, denn Donald Trump ist, das kann man ja jetzt auch mal ganz ehrlich sagen, doof. Also der ist einfach dumm. Das Erfolgsrezept von ihm ist ja auch, ich bin so doof, dass alle glauben, sie könnten mich in ihre Richtung ziehen. Also hat er jetzt Stephen Miller mit einer harten Einwanderungspolitik und Elon Musk auf der anderen Seite. Und dann hat er Steve Bannon auf der einen und die anderen auf der anderen. Und alle kämpfen so miteinander, weil sie glauben, nee, was Herr Trump da sagt, der geht eigentlich in meine Richtung. Und dann sagen die anderen, nee, das war in meine Richtung ausgelegt. Bist du bescheuert? Und beide wissen, es macht gar keinen Sinn jetzt mit Trump darüber zu diskutieren, weil bei Trump zwei Kilometer vor seinem Schlafzimmer stürzt ein Flugzeug ab mit 16 Amerikanern drin. Und seine Botschaft dazu ist not good. Ja, da gibt es nichts zu diskutieren.
Und die woke Ideologie sei auch mit dran schuld am Ende.
Das auch natürlich. Ja, ja, das ist, da werden wir noch einige zu knuspern haben. Also es passieren dramatisch Ereignisse und alle wissen, ja, also das müssen wir jetzt mit Trump nicht diskutieren. Das muss jetzt eine Ebene tiefer. Also das hat ihn aber, weil alle glaubten, so und jetzt müssen die das auskämpfen. Also es ist.
Ja, diese Liberalitäten sind ja schon offensichtlich. Trump hat ja jetzt dieses Stargate-Programm geschrieben, von dem man auch jetzt überlegen kann, wie sinnvoll ist das eigentlich so, wahnsinnig viel Geld draufzuwerfen, wo man sieht, die Chinesen können das mit Diebsieg billiger. Jedenfalls hat er ja also damit Sam Altman sehr protegiert. Das ist nun der Erzfeind von Elon Musk, der dann gleichzeitig schon wieder twitterte, wie furchtbar dieser Sam Altman ist und dass der ja eigentlich ein Demokrat sei, dass er ja damals Trumps Wahl kritisiert habe etc. Das heißt also, wir erleben jetzt die Rivalität der Multi-Milliardäre, die unter Trump sich um Plätze sorgen, kämpfen. Wir haben bei der Inauguration gesehen, dass dort die Milliardärsklasse schon direkt präsent war. Und zwar muss man hier auch sagen, die Milliardäre der Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie.
Absolut.
Also es ist ja nicht so, dass man jetzt einfach irgendwelche alten Ölbarone dahingesetzt hat. Die haben natürlich immer lobbyiert. Die haben immer einen Einfluss gehabt. Und die haben natürlich dafür gesorgt, dass der Klimawandel lange Zeit nicht als Problem erkannt wurde. Das gab es ja zu allen Zeiten. Ich glaube nur, dass jetzt also diese mediale Präsenz von Trump und diejenigen, die die Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie in ihren Händen haben, zusammenkommen. Und dort natürlich jetzt die eigentlichen Kämpfe stattfinden. Denn es geht diesen Leuten ja nicht mehr dann ums Geld, sondern nur noch um die Frage, wer steht wie da? Und deswegen gibt es auch diese gerade zu kindischen Tweets dann von Elon Musk gegen Sam Altman beispielsweise.
Ja, aber viele Clips, die ich jetzt im Hinterkopf habe, ich werde sie spontan nicht rauskramen. Donald Trump hat ja bei der Amtszeitführung gesagt, und diese komische E-Auto-Förderung, die werden wir streichen. Ab jetzt darf wieder jeder Amerikaner selbst aussuchen, welches Auto erfährt. Was natürlich dann kommentiert wurde mit, oh krass, das geht ja voll gegen Tesla, weil die immer davon profitiert, dass die Teslas billiger sind. Wozu dann Alex Jones in seinem Info Wars Podcast sagt, da sieht man es, ein Mann aufrechtstehend nimmt den Hit gegen seine eigenen Unternehmen für die Republik. So, gleichzeitig wissen wir aber, Elon Musks Memes-Doc Börsenwert seiner selbst ist um 60 Milliarden gestiegen, allein in den zwei Wochen seit der Amtszeitführung. Was mehr als ein Jahresumsatz Tesla verkaufend ist. Also es juckt ihn so im Grunde nicht. Es ist alles absurd. Wir gehen aber gleich, also wir machen das sehr ausführlich heute. Wir gehen ins politische Vorfeld und wir blicken ein bisschen in die Zukunft. Österreich.
Ja.
Mal wieder. Ja, wir machen es immer wie Österreich. Da wir es bisher immer wie Österreich gemacht haben, nutzen wir die Gelegenheit und gucken uns heute schon mal den März 2025 mit Friedrich Merz in Deutschland an.
Ja, du hast gesehen, er war beim World Economic Forum. Friedrich Merz.
Zu Gast Friedrich Merz.
Und er hat Strümpfe mit seinen Initialen drauf gehabt.
Mittelschicht.
Da fragt man sich jetzt, wozu braucht man das?
Gar nicht.
Vergisst er morgens seinen Namen.
Das werden wir heute, wozu braucht man das?
Lebt er im Heim, dass man dann die wieder zuordnen kann, sind sie in der Wäsche warm? Also das sind die Fragen, die ich mir gestellt habe. Jedenfalls war er dort.
Wenn du deine Sachen nur im Hotel wäschen lässt. Ist das sinnvoll? Dann ist das sinnvoll, die Namen da drin zu haben. Das ist wie bei den Erstklässlern, wenn die Lehrerin schreibt, anders als im Kindergarten können wir die Sachen hier nicht einfach so auseinanderhalten, denn hier sind ein paar mehr Kinder, bitte schreiben sie mit einem Adding den Namen in die Jacke. So ist das bei mir auch.
Ja. Es ist entsetzlich, wir lachen jetzt hier gerade, aber was jetzt doch in den vergangenen Tagen passiert ist, hätte ich so nicht gedacht. Also meine These war eine Weile die Folgende. Friedrich Merz ist derjenige mit sauerländischem Katholizismus im Hintergrund, der derjenige sein wird, der noch einmal sagt, die CDU ist die konservativ rechte Partei, da darf es daneben eigentlich nichts geben. Und da schotten wir uns auch nach rechts ab. Er wäre also der Letzte seiner Art. Danach, das habe ich hier im Podcast auch schon mal betont, habe ich nicht mehr das irgendwo als Hoffnung gesehen, sondern ich würde sagen, die Unterschiede zwischen Alice Weidel und vielen Jüngeren aus der CDU, Jens Spahn und anderen sind so marginal, dass wir uns jetzt sehr vertiefen müssten in Einzelaussagen, um das noch festzustellen, wo die Unterschiede sind. Das heißt, dass da Koalitionen möglich sind, war mir sofort klar. Habe ich gedacht, das ist dann das für 2029. Ich habe nicht damit gerechnet, dass Friedrich Merz so, ich weiß gar nicht, wenig darüber nachdenkt strategisch, weil er ja immer als der große Strategie beschrieben wird, was das eigentlich bedeutet, was er hier macht und ein retorisches Talent natürlich. Mit Wirtschaftskompetenz. Natürlich, dass er das macht. Ich hätte ihm nicht zugetraut oder um es anders zu formulieren, ich hätte ihn für ein wenig klüger gehalten und zu allem, was wir jetzt gleich sagen werden, will ich in Erinnerung rufen, ein Kanzler hat ja viel kompliziertere Dinge zu lösen als das, was Friedrich Merz sich da jetzt selbst eingebrockt hat. Also fragt man sich wirklich, wenn er das schon jetzt so gegen die Wand fährt, und da sind wir jetzt noch gar nicht beim menschenrechtlichen Fragen und so was, sondern einfach nur mal strategisch draufgeblickt. Wie sieht das jetzt so weltpolitisch aus? Also ist die Option jetzt, dass entweder Friedrich Merz uns an Trump und Putin gleichzeitig veräußern wird, oder löst er einfach den dritten Weltkrieg aus? Also ich glaube, diese beiden Optionen sind da. Die Wehrpflicht ist ja dann auch eingeführt, kämpfen für Friedrich heißt das dann. Ich würde sagen, man muss Panik schon deshalb bekommen, weil hier ja jemand strategisch offenbar nichts auf dem Kasten hat.
Ja, ist auch sehr gut, dass du das einführst mit wir lachen jetzt hier, jetzt werden wir kurz ernst und fragen uns, ob Friedrich Merz der redliche Konservative ist, den wir in Deutschland brauchen.
Ja.
Und wir stellen fest nein. Du hast einen Clip von Friedrich Merz mitgebracht, den wir zur Einstimmung eines Rundowns hören können. Ich kenne ihn nicht, ich sehe ihn aber schon.
In den sozialen Medien gepostet, eine Ansprache direkt an uns jetzt, an uns Wähler und vor allem auch an die, die Kinder haben.
Ich habe Kinder. Okay, dann höre ich mal zu.
Liebe Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger, ich habe selbst Kinder und ich kann mir trotzdem kaum vorstellen, wie es sich für eine Mutter oder ein Vater anfühlen muss, ihr Kind morgens in die Kita oder in die Schule zu bringen und es mittags oder abends nicht mehr in die Arme schließen zu können. Meine Damen und Herren, ich weigere mich anzuerkennen, dass die Taten von Mannheim, Solingen, Magdeburg und jetzt Aschaffenburg die neue Normalität in unserem Land sein sollen. Das Maß ist endgültig voll. Wir stehen vor dem Scherbenhaufen einer seit zehn Jahren fehlgeleiteten Asyl- und Einwanderungspolitik. Deutschland, unser Land muss endlich wieder sicher werden. Ich habe daher gestern einige Vorschläge gemacht und sicher ist und das möchte ich Ihnen versichern. Sollte ich zum Bundeskanzler der Bundesrepublik Deutschland gewählt werden, dann werde ich am ersten Tag meiner Amtszeit das Bundesinnenministerium anweisen, die deutschen Staatsgrenzen zu allen unseren Nachbarstaaten dauerhaft zu kontrollieren und ausnahmslos alle Versuche der illegalen Einreise zurückzuweisen. In diesen Minuten, in denen ich hier spreche, laufen Täter weiter frei in unserem Land herum. Das ist ein Zustand, den wir beenden müssen und den wir beenden werden. Die Menschen in Deutschland müssen sich wieder sicher fühlen. Und dafür werde ich kämpfen mit aller Entschlossenheit und aller Entschiedenheit. Und ich möchte Ihnen sagen, darauf können Sie sich wirklich verlassen.
Könnten wir uns darauf verlassen? Nein, könnten wir natürlich nicht. Interessant ist ja schon, dass er hier am Magdeburg mit hinzunimmt, wo wir es ja mit einem Fall zu tun haben, dass ein Mann, der viele viele Jahre hier lebte, als Arzt hier arbeitete, dann zu solch einer schrecklichen Tat übergeht, wo man aber nicht sagen kann, da ist die Integration an sich misslungen, sondern da würde man erst mal sagen, ja das ist ja ein Beispiel für eine gute Integration gewesen, dass jemand eine solche gute Position in einer Klinik inne hat. Da ist dann eine private Radikalisierung und vielleicht auch eine Psychose, wir kennen ja den Täter nicht genau, wir waren nicht bei Gutachten oder so dabei, entstanden, die dazu geführt hat, dass er so etwas machte. Es gab vor einigen Jahren in Trier einen Fall von jemand, der keinen Migrationshintergrund hatte, in dem sein Auto genommen hat und auch dort in die Einkaufsstraße rein ist und viele Menschen auch Kinder totgefahren hat. Einfach so möchte man sagen. Dann spricht er darüber, dass Täter jetzt frei herumlaufen. Also das klingt ja eher so, als würden wir, als seien Täter schon da, die jetzt noch nicht gefasst wurden. Täter vor der Tat. Ja, Täter vor der Tat kann man nicht sein. Also sagt er, hier laufen also Leute rum und damit meint er dann, also alle, die irgendwie migrantisch aussehen könnten, könnten ihre Kinder rauben oder töten oder sonst was. Also das heißt, hier wird also ein Generalverdacht ausgesprochen. Und dann drittens ist interessant, dass er seit sobald er kann, als am ersten Tag wird er Grenzkontrollen einführen. Die sind ja da. Ich war jetzt in den vergangenen Wochen in der Schweiz. Da ist es noch mit dem Zug dann anders, ja. Aber ich war dann in Luxemburg und in Belgien. Und dann jedes Mal, wenn man aus diesen Ländern wieder zurück nach Deutschland will, wird man runtergebremst auf 20 kmh. Dann stehen dort im Nieselregen ein paar Polizisten rum. Die gucken, wenn man dann so aussieht wie ich, dann kann man durchfahren. Und ich sage mal, die haben fast alle durchgewunken. Die können ja gar nicht jetzt jedes einzelne Auto anhalten. Und da sind ja Hunderte im Minutentakt, die da durchfahren. Die stehen also da, gucken kurz. Na ja, und wenn man jetzt nicht irgendwie besonders auffällig ist, wird man sowieso durchgewunken. Wie will er eine solche Grenzkontrolle durchführen, wo er genau weiß, also allein Trier-Luxemburg, halb Trier pendelt morgens um acht nach Luxemburg und kommt wieder dann zurück zum Feierabend. Wie sollen diese Leute kontrolliert werden? Zudem, wenn man sich diese Strecken ansieht, das ist Luxemburg-Trier ist sehr interessant. Man fährt ja über eine Brücke dann, also über die Grenze dann über die Brücke und ist dann in Deutschland, dann fährt man an Wäldern vorbei und irgendwann kommt dann diese Grenzkontrolle. Wenn man jetzt irgendjemanden da rauswerfen wollte, dann müsste man also mitten auf der Straße schon vorher alles blockieren, damit man nicht vorher anhalten kann und jemand in den Wald flüchtet. Weil natürlich die erste Grenzkontrolle dann erst kommt oder die einzige Grenzkontrolle dann erst kommt, wenn die erste Ausfahrt kommt. Also das ist so irrsinnig, das durchzusetzen und zu glauben auch, dass das jetzt irgendetwas ändert. Also das ist ja eine interessante Idee, dass er eine Sicherheit verspricht, wo man sich fragen kann, ist überhaupt eine Sicherheit möglich. Wir sind noch gar nicht hier bei diesen Anträgen und Koalitionen, die sich dadurch ergeben.
Da kommen wir heute auch nicht hin.
Da kommen wir quasi gar nicht.
Wir sind ja keine Nachrichten.
Wir kommen da nicht hin, dass wir das jetzt nicht nochmal alles wiederholen. Aber wir können ja mal.
Das ist prüfungsrelevantes Vorwissen, das der Hörer selber mitbringt.
Aschaffenburg war der Fall. So, da ist also ein Afghaner, der unter anderem ein zweijähriges Kind tötet.
Ja, ein Marokkaner. Also wenn man Afghaner sagt, muss man auch Marokkaner sagen.
Das Kind, ja. So, also dann wäre ja schon da interessant diese Generalisierung, die da stattfindet. Die ist ja schon mal eine grundsätzlich falsche.
Ja, also wenn Merkels rangegangen wär mit, in Deutschland werden wieder Ausländer getötet. Das dulden wir hier nicht. Was hätten wir dann gesagt?
Ich hab mir über diesen Fall so nachgedacht, weil zugleich eine Meldung kam, das ist jetzt hier, glaub ich sogar aus der Bildzeitung. Und zwar gab es dann eine Meldung wenige Tage nach Aschaffenburg. In Paraguay, ein 34 Jahre alter Deutscher, soll nahe der Hauptstadt einen Mann im Rollstuhl erschlagen haben, nackt und mit einem Ziegelstein. Der Sohn deutscher Auswanderer lebte im selben Wohnviertel wie sein späteres Opfer. Laut Bild soll er zur Zeit der Tat unter Drogeneinfluss gestanden haben. Das würde auch erklären, weshalb die Verdächtigen danach blutverschmiert ihn durch die Straße laufen sahen. Freunde und Wegbegleiter attestierten dem 34-Jährigen ein ruhiges Wesen. So Fälle gibt es offenbar. Ich will noch einen weiteren Fall bringen, ein Fall aus England. Da ist jemand, der heißt Dylan. Der hat seinen besten Freund mit 37 Stichen ermordet, hat seine Großmutter, seine Tante gebeten, nochmal ihnen zur Wohnung zu fahren. Er müsste mit dem Hundgassi gehen und hat dann diesen besten Freund aus eigentlich unerfindlichen Gründen, also er hat gesagt, weil der umziehen wollte, mit 37 Messerstichen erstochen. Und hier auch interessant, weil wir jetzt die ganze Zeit diese Debatte haben, warum hat man nicht schon vorher reagiert. Auch hier ist was interessant, es gab Anzeichen. Vor Gericht wurde bekannt, dass er wenige Monate vor der Tat über einen 14 Meter hohen Zaun des Buckingham Palastes geklettert war und einen Einbruch versuchte. Außerdem soll er seinem späteren Opfer schon gesagt haben, dass er überlebt habe, um ihn zu töten.
Die Zäune da sind 14 Meter hoch?
Ja, wohl an manchen Stellen, und da kann man auch drüber klettern offenbar. Was ich jetzt hier mit diesen Fällen, und wir könnten jetzt hunderte solcher Fälle natürlich anführen, was wir also sehen ist, diese absolute Sicherheit, die da versprochen wird, ist ja erstmal eine völlige Illusion. Und zweitens ist ja die Frage, wie geht man damit um, wenn Leute sehr devianzig verhalten, kann man sie dauerhaft so festnehmen, dass sie nichts mehr anstellen. Ich weiß zum Beispiel von einem Fall aus Rheinland-Pfalz, von jemand, der hat Morddrohungen bekommen, von einer Person. Auch die Familie wurde bedroht, inklusive Frau und Kinder. Dieser Mensch, der diese Morddrohungen geschrieben hat, wurde irgendwann von der Polizei festgenommen, auch an Widerstand geleistet, war nach wenigen Wochen aber dann aus der Untersuchungshaft wieder draußen, weil man nichts weiteres feststellen kann. Wenn da jetzt irgendwann einmal etwas passieren wollte, Gott bewahre, dann würde man sagen, na seht ihr, warum hat man da nichts getan? Und wir können jetzt ganz viele solcher Fälle sehen, da sind wir überhaupt gar nicht bei einem Migrationsthema, sondern wir sind plötzlich bei einem ganz anderen Thema angelangt. Warum das aber so charmant ist jetzt für Konservative und Rechte, dass mit Migration zu verbinden ist, dass man wirklich noch Politik simulieren kann. Denn wenn ich mir die Wahlprogramme ansehe, ich hab jetzt alle durchgelesen, dann fällt mir auf, bis auf wenige Ausnahmen, dass ja doch der Politik ziemlich die Hände gebunden sind. Ja, man ist in diesem Gefüge der Wirtschaftsstandort, der Wirtschaftsstandort bedeutet aber auch, na ja, höhere Löhne können auch ein Problem werden und so. Also das ist ja die Denkweise. Und dann sind die Maßnahmen, die man zu Verbesserungen des Lebens aller machen kann, doch relativ beschränkt häufig. Ja, es sei denn, man wagt sich jetzt eine sehr linke, progressive Politik, was aber die meisten nicht vorhaben. Und eigentlich müsste in vielen Programmen stehen, also wir können ihnen eigentlich nicht was maßgebliches anbieten. Politikwechsel oder so, vergessen sie das. Das können die aber nicht da reinschreiben. Und zugleich wissen die meisten Leute, die sich so empören über die in Berlin und sonst was, dass eigentlich doch die Möglichkeiten relativ gering sind. Und das Migrationsthema aber, bzw. Migration und Sicherheitsthema wie Friedrich Merz, das hier jetzt vorstellt und wie das dann von Alice Weidel dankbar aufgegriffen wird, ist eines, dass man wunderbar mit vollem Engagement vorstellen kann, ohne dass etwas passiert. Also ohne dass sich in dem Sinne die Sicherheitslage deutlich verbessert. Und es ist für die Leute, die jetzt Merz toll finden, Alice Weidel toll finden und so weiter, wunderbar, weil man politisch engagiert sein kann, ohne sich engagieren zu müssen. Man kann sich emotional voll reinlegen. Und so werden wir nochmal hier abgeholt. Sie als Vater, Sie als Mutter können Sie sich das vorstellen. Ich kann es mir kaum vorstellen. Man kann sich richtig nochmal empören, wie kann das alles sein? Behördenversagen etc. Und es gab ja auch Behördenversagen, das wollen wir ja gar nicht hier leugnen. Aber man kann sich selbst emotional engagieren, ohne sich wirklich in irgendeiner Weise politisch engagieren zu müssen. Denn politisches Engagement würde jetzt zum Beispiel bedeuten, warum gibt es denn so wenig Sprachkurse? Warum gibt es denn so wenig Unterstützung für Menschen, die nach Deutschland kommen? Warum unterstützt man nicht auch ganz andere Sachen noch, die politisch wert wären, dass sich da Leute engagieren? Das heißt, man kann eigentlich sagen, ich bin total politisch, bin jetzt die ganze Zeit voll dabei. Und so ist ja auch diese Aufregung bei Twitter. Alle sind auf 180. Aber man muss gar nichts selbst tun. Also ich muss nicht einen Schwimmverein leiten, ich muss nicht irgendeinen Kuchen für die Schule backen, ich muss eigentlich nichts machen. Ich kann mich die ganze Zeit moralisch empören, so tun, als sei ich wahnsinnig engagiert in der Sache. Weiß aber, naja, also wenn irgendetwas dort maßgeblich geändert werden muss, dann ist das irgendwie eine Grenzpolizei, irgendwas in Behörden. Ich hab damit gar nichts zu tun.
Ja, jetzt sehen wir hier ein großes Durcheinander, dass wir jetzt aufklären. Denn viele Leute fragen sich ja, was ist denn da los? Und vielleicht kann man bei Merz einfach sagen, naja, Merz dachte halt, er spielt den Ball, aber er wird halt gespielt. Also Merz hat ja gar nicht den Ball. Er ist irgendwie Fußballspieler, wo er immer hinterher rennt. So, die Zweikämpfe funktionieren einfach nicht. Er hat keinen Ball, er kriegt keinen Ball und er kommt damit zu Sprüchen, die er sich von Trump anschaut, an Tag eins und so weiter und so fort. Gleichzeitig hat er aber vom Gefühl so eine Vorstandsfunktion. Also er identifiziert so eine Art deutsches Volk, für das man handeln kann. Wer sollte der Bundeskanzler, das macht ja schon der Name. Ich werde ja vielleicht gleich Bundeskanzler. Also ich erzähl euch mal, ich kann handeln. Ja. Zieht aber so einen deutschen Rahmen. Das ist jetzt nicht nur aufs Volk bezogen, sondern auch auf deutschen Strom. Ja, also wir hören ja immer Jens Spahn, der sich dann fragt, warum wird in Konstanz Schweizer Strom verbraucht, weil wir in Deutschland nicht genug produzieren? Nee, weil das nächste deutsche Stromkraftwerk ist halt einfach ein paar Kilometer weiter weg und es macht voll Sinn, das nächstgelegte Stromding anzuzapfen und wie auch immer. Ja, so laut, dass ich sag, du hast es mit den Grenzen überschritten. Ja, wir haben in Deutschland Gebiete, die sind, obwohl auf deutschem Boden, viel mehr französisch und viel mehr niederländisch als sächsisch. Ja. So, also diese deutsche Einheit, so gibt es gar nicht. Und jetzt ist ja die Frage nicht so sehr, was ist jetzt konkret passiert, sondern warum sind alle so aufgeregt? Und zwar auch im Publikum. Also ich meine jetzt auch Hörer der Nachrichten, die dann völlig zurecht auf Instagram noch mal schildern, der 29. Januar wird in die Geschichtsbücher eingehen und so weiter und so fort. Und das spielt natürlich alles vor so einer Kulisse, Holocaust-Gedenken, deutsche Geschichte und so weiter statt, kann da problematisiert werden, wir werden die großen Demos sehen. Heute im Bundestag geht es ja auch wieder zur Sache. Das ist quasi der nächste Aufhänger, Anlass, sich solche Fragen zu stellen. Nur bei Friedrich Merz ist ja hier so ein implizites Denken dabei, das er nicht ausformulieren. Ausformulieren kann man ja erstmal vieles, so wie ich eben schon ansprach, ja, das Opfer war ein Marokkaner. Da könnte man jetzt die ganzen sich neu rechts fühlenden Menschen, die sich so sehr um die deutsche Seele kümmern, fragen, wie viele deutsche Ressourcen soll denn der deutsche Staat aufbringen, um Marokkaner in Deutschland zu schützen? Also diese Argumentation führt ja nirgendwo hin aus deren Sicht. Während ich mir denke, ja klar schützen wir ja auch Zweijährige, Marokkaner, ist doch egal, was das für Leute sind. Wir brauchen sie später in unserem Erwerbspersonenpotenzial. Klingt jetzt auch auf der einen Seite sehr radikal, aber das ist halt Win-Win. Das ist für den Zirkling gut und für die Gesellschaft, in der er lebt. So, also in der Ansicht, da gibt es ganz viele offene Fragen, die man sich klären kann und wir machen das, indem wir jetzt ins politische Vorfeld gehen. Also wir gucken jetzt gleich ganz viel Hoss und Hopf, hören Hoss und Hopf und schauen uns nochmal an, wie auch im deutschen Nachrichten Mainstream, also die FAZ-Redakteure und Leute vom Ludwig Erhard Forum so über Millet denken, was wir jetzt so in die Richtung machen und was in Österreich passiert. Also wir umzirkeln jetzt sozusagen, weil wir ja alle die O-Tone kennen. Ich will nur zum Einstieg, weil du jetzt hier den März so gespielt hast, es gibt noch einen O-Ton von Söder, den kann man ja nochmal spielen. Söder ist in der Stimmlage kaum wiederzuerkennen. Also ich dachte so beim Hören, das soll Söder sein. Ich springe nochmal zurück. Ahja, der Nachrichtmann sagt, jetzt hören wir Markus Söder. Also es gibt eine Andacht, Aschaffenburg liegt in Bayern, Markus Söder muss sich darum kümmern, Ländergerangel, Bund, wer ist jetzt dafür zuständig, dass hier keine zweijährigen Marokkaner getötet werden. Innerlich, sobald die Diskussion den Horizont übersteigt, kann man sie nicht aufklären. Also wie soll denn eine adäquate Politik aussehen, die sagt, wir wollen nur die richtigen Ausländer. Das heißt, wir schieben alle ab, außer die Ärzte, die brauchen wir. Dann fährt aber genauso ein Arzt ausgerechnet auf den Weihnachtsmarkt und tötet dort Leute. Ja. Es macht ja keinen Sinn. Also so kann man, daraus kann man keine programmatische Politik ableiten, die irgendeinem Gefühl entspricht, das heute vermutet wird in einem Publikum, das man gar nicht kennt. Das Merz glaubt hier ansprechen zu können.
Er sagt ja sogar, dass sie sich sicher fühlen, nicht, dass sie sicher sind, sondern sie sollen sich sicher fühlen. Und da denke ich mir, ja, viel.
So, jetzt hören wir mal kurz Söder, der auch weiß, hinter dem Horizont politische Programme, irgendwas Großes, Abstraktes, was irgendwann mal im Bundestag vielleicht, wenn der Referentenentwurf hinhaut, in einem Jahr mal Gesetz wird und in drei Jahren stellen wir fest, das Gesetz war gut, Umsetzung schlecht oder wie auch immer. Also alles Minenfeld versucht Söder eben auch diesen Appell an die Gefühle und ganz nah dran. Und ich finde das einfach absurd.
Ministerpräsident Markus Söder sprach in seiner Rede den Angehörigen sein Beileid aus.
Das Gute und das Böse sind keine Frage von Herkunft, Nationalität, Ethnie oder Glauben. Alle Kinder in Bayern sind unsere Kinder und alle Kinder dieser Welt haben Schutz verdient. Alle Kinder der Welt haben Liebe verdient. Und deswegen darf diese Tat nicht dazu führen, dass Hass von einigen unsere Gesandte Gesellschaft erfasst.
Ja, dann erkennt ihr nicht Wiener. Was ist denn da los?
Politiker, also Merz hat es noch deutlicher gemacht, also expliziter. Liebe Menschen, ein Kind ist gestorben. Ich sage Ihnen jetzt, wie Sie das fühlen müssen. Offenbar sind Sie zu gar nichts in der Lage. Wir müssen Ihnen schon die Politik und den Strom liefern. Jetzt muss ich Ihnen auch noch sagen, wie Sie fühlen sollen. Wir denken so, nee Herr Merz, wir können selber fühlen. Und wissen Sie was Herr Merz, ich hab gar keine Kinder und ich kann es trotzdem fühlen. So, ich bin die Tante, die kinderlos geblieben ist, aber ich habe auch Kinder in meinem Leben irgendwie so. Also es ist völlig absurd. So, wir steigen jetzt jetzt hier also mal ein und wollen das mal.
Lass mich ein Wort noch dazu sagen, es ist ja ganz interessant, dass Söder hier verspricht, dass es nicht Hass und Hetze geben soll. Und genau das aber dann zur CDU-Programmatik wird. Denn man kann ja jetzt deutlich sagen, dass wer jetzt die CDU wählt, schon mal eine Stimme mit abgibt für die AfD.
Ja genau, das ist die einzige Koalitionsoption, die er hat.
Ja, ich glaube noch nicht unbedingt daran, dass er eine Koalition mit der AfD macht, denn Franziska Brandner von den Grünen war sich ja nicht so schade, gestern noch mal zu betonen, dass sie so offen ist für eine Koalition mit Friedrich Merz. Aber wir sehen hier ganz klar, jede Stimme, die da hingeht zur CDU zählt schon ein auf eine mögliche Koalition, dann auch wenn sie erst 2029 meinetwegen stattfindet, aber zumindest wird man häufiger insofern koalieren, dass man sich bei Anträgen derart verhält, wie man das jetzt getan hat und sagt, naja wir haben jetzt folgende Idee, wenn die AfD da mitmacht. Und um das noch mal ganz deutlich zu sagen, weil das auch mal so gesagt wird, ja aber irgendwo haben die da mal mitgestimmt, es ist ja ein Antrag, den Friedrich Merz inhaltlich eingebracht hat, der auch AfD-Inhalt ist. Es ging ja nicht über einen Antrag um Hochwasseraufhangbecken, wo man sagte, naja gut Hochwasser ist Hochwasser oder sowas, sondern es war ein Antrag, der inhaltlich deckungsgleich ist.
Das zentrale Thema der AfD.
Das Thema, ja. Und deswegen ist es so absurd, das zu sehen. Und auch noch mal diese interessante Sache ist ja, warum hyperventilieren bei Aschaffenburg die Leute mehr als bei anderen Taten. Also ich hab hier, ist ja auch aus dem selben Monat noch eine Geschichte. Am gestrigen Abend gegen 19.30 Uhr kam es in einer Wohnung in Eisenach zu einem Tötungsdelikt. Hier wurde eine 35-jährige Frau durch massive Gewalt so schwer verletzt, dass sie in der Nacht starb. Eine 20-jährige Frau wurde ebenfalls schwer verletzt und in die Klinik eingewiesen. Die Ermittlungen richten sich gegen einen 37-jährigen Deutschen. Warum funktioniert das eine, also Femizide oder so etwas, das ist so, das geschieht halt in Deutschland, kommt in den Westen oder Haushalten vor, nach dem Motto, ja. Und hier aber Aschaffenburg interessiert so viel mehr. Warum ist das so? Nun, man sagt natürlich sich, also die Unterscheidung, die man dann bereit ist zu machen, wir und sie, also die Morde, die hier stattfinden von unseren Leuten, das ist halt das Normale. Das ist so wie, na ja, es kommt halt vor. Das erklären wir unter uns. Es kommt halt vor. Aber das andere hätte, wäre nicht vorgekommen, wenn die nicht hier hingekommen wären. Was dann aber nur im Umkehrschuss bedeuten kann, da muss man die Grenzen grundsätzlich für alle dicht machen, nie mehr irgendjemanden reinlassen, dann hat man nur noch die eigenen Morde zu ermitteln und keine anderen mehr. Und dieser Wahnsinn, der da drin steckt, zeigt sich ja dann eben besonders darin, dass natürlich von diesen terroristischen Anschlägen oder Amokläufen, oder wie man es auch immer nennen will, natürlich auch die hier längst zugewanderten und hier Lebenden gleichermaßen betroffen sind und gleichermaßen dann mit dem Messer verletzt oder getötet werden. Und wenn man aber es schafft, wie das Friedrich Merz und Jens Spahn tun, diese Wir-und-Sie-Unterscheidung wieder so stark zu machen, sagt man sich plötzlich, naja, das ist also etwas, was nur eine Frage von Import ist. Hätten wir das nicht, dann hätten wir es nicht. Und da wäre ja interessant, nach einem anderen Ansatz zu fragen, nämlich wie könnte man tatsächlich etwas verhindern? Und das ist ja schon doch interessant, dass wir es hier bei diesem Fall in Aschaffenburg mit einem Afghanen zu tun haben, der ja noch gar nicht so lange in Deutschland war. Jetzt wissen wir, was in Afghanistan war. Der Westen hat dieses Land in Schutt und Asche gebombt, hat dann gesagt nach vielen, vielen Jahren, nachdem schon vor zehn Jahren Margot Käßmann sagte, hier läuft alles schief in Afghanistan, wurde dafür ausgeschimpft und so, hat man dann doch gesagt, wir machen jetzt den Rückzug, und zwar nicht den geordneten, sondern wir flüchten, ja, und hat also Leute mehrmals traumatisiert. Nimmt dann Leute auch von Afghanistan auf und kümmert sich nicht entsprechend um sie. Also wir sehen ja hier, dass in relativ normalen Verhältnissen solch abscheuliche Taten möglich sind, dass Leute solche Psychosen oder was auch immer entwickeln, dass sie zu bestiärlichen Mördern werden. Und dann haben wir Leute, die stark traumatisiert und so, die überhaupt keine Unterstützung haben. Und dann wundert man sich, dass da jetzt so etwas passiert ist.
Wobei zu diesem ultranationalen Ethnoploralismus schon gehört, wir wären ja nie nach Afghanistan gegangen, was haben wir uns da eingemischt und so.
Genau das ist dann das, was so aus dem Kubicek-Kreis oder so kommen würde. Aber Friedrich Merz ist ja jemand, der wäre wahrscheinlich noch mit in Irak aufmarschiert.
Ja, das ist eben das Interessante, dass Friedrich Merz ein Globalist ist, der gerne mit Blackrock und deutschen Personalausweis überall auf der Welt machen möchte, was er will. Aber wehe in Aschaffenburg und so weiter. Also das ist alles verlogen und wir dröseln das jetzt mal auf, denn es gibt ja ganz viele Ungereimtheiten. Es gibt einen Hitlergruß, der nur so, war es wirklich ein Hitlergruß. Also klares Bekenntnis sozusagen von Maast, dann gibt es aber von Weidel dieses Hitler war ja gar keiner von uns, das war ja ein Linker und so. Dem gehen wir mal nach. Und zwar im O-Ton, wie es gesagt wurde. Zum einen Joshua Topolsky, also in dem Fall jetzt ein Amerikaner, kein Deutscher. Also er kommt jetzt nicht, er ist jüdischer Atheist, also seine Familie hat schon jüdische Geschichte, aber es ist jetzt sozusagen amerikanisches, ich will hier irgendwelche Nachrichten, ich spiele gerne im Internet rum, wie auch immer. Und er sieht Elon Musk auf der Bühne.
Wenn ich es sehe, wenn ich es sehe, fühlt es sich an, als wäre es das am meisten offensivste Ding, Hände runter. Und es war viel, insbesondere in den letzten vier oder fünf Jahren.
So, also Elon Musk ist nicht erst seit gestern bekannt, aber das, was er in Hitlergruß zeigt, Das ist von allem, was man bisher von ihm gesehen hat, das abscheulichste. Und zwar in dem Moment, in dem er der reichste Mann der Welt ist und den mächtigsten Mann der Welt zur Gratulationsparty geht, um zu sagen, hier mein Hartkurs aus, to you, weil ihr habt ihn gewählt. So und das muss man auch genau so, also man kann jetzt nicht mit einer Analyse beginnen, bei der man dahinter zurückgeht. Wir können jetzt nicht auf Weltspielereien einlassen, dann war es nur ein Hitlergruß oder wie auch immer. Lenzen Jakobsen hat in der Zeit geschrieben, ein Hitlergruß ist ein Hitlergruß, ist ein Hitlergruß. Das nehmen wir jetzt als gegeben. Elon Musk, wir kennen ja alle diese Videos, wie er so mit Herzchengeste und so über die Bühnen rennt und die Leute dann drunne schreiben, er kennt doch den Unterschied. Also er weiß genau, was ein Hitlergruß ist. Und wenn sich einer mit Hitler befasst hat, dann ja wohl. Elon Musk wird jetzt auch interessant, so langsam kommen ja da die Interessen, also wenn diese Leute jetzt meinen, sie müssten nicht mehr im Hintergrund leben und die Strüppen ziehen, indem sie irgendwelche Millionäre in den Kongress schicken, sondern selber Staatsangestellte werden. Interessiert man sich natürlich auch für die Biografie. Und wenn jemand in Südafrika aufwächst als Sohn eines Apartheit-Profitörs, dann vererbt sich halt ein Menschenbild, das dann irgendwann aktualisiert wird, wenn nur noch Speichellecker und Bittsteller um einen rumgaukeln die ganze Zeit. Na gut, das Zentrum für politische Schönheit hat ja eine Aktion gemacht in Brandenburg an dem Tesla-Werk, das hier im Podcast Haken dran noch mal pointiert aufgegriffen wird, denn es muss ja gar nicht unsere Primatmeinung sein, dass das nun ein eindeutiger Hitlergruß war. Es könnte ja auch sein, dass der deutsche Staatsschutz das sagt.
Wir haben über die Aktion des Zentrums für politische Schönheit gesprochen, die nach eigener Angabe eine Projektion des mastischen Hitlergrußes auf die Gigafactory in Brandenburg geworfen haben. Daraufhin hat die Polizei zunächst, das war der Stand bei der Aufzeichnung, gemeldet, es gibt keine Hinweise darauf, dass es echt war, sondern wohl Hinweise darauf eher, dass es eine Fotomantage ist. Und kurz nach der Aufzeichnung hat dann der Staatsschutz angefangen zu ermitteln, weil eben diese Projektion wohl doch echt gewesen sei. Es gibt auch Fotos, der Projektoren gibt auf dieses Werk in Grünheide. Und das Interessante ist aber, dass erst durch diese Ermittlungen des Staatsschutzes, jetzt eigentlich, finde ich, die Aktion überhaupt einen Sinn bekommt. Weil der Sinn nun ist, also abgesehen davon, dass du Aufmerksamkeit für dieses Thema generierst, wo Thorsten auch meinte, ja, aber belehrt das Menschen, wir wissen es nicht. Der Sinn der Aktion ist aber jetzt, wenn der Staatsschutz feststellt, dass die Projektion dieses Bildes das Darstellen eines verfassungswidrigen Symbols war, dann haben wir schwarz auf weiß, dass nach deutscher Rechtsprechung diese Geste von Elon Musk tatsächlich ein Hitlergruß war. Und das halte ich für einen fantastischen Move.
Ja, das ist doch witzig, oder?
Ja.
Also das wirkt sehr gut. Wir haben ja also eine Ausgangslage, die sagt, nein, alle Fragen, die wir uns jetzt stellen, sind genauso ernst zu nehmen, wie Elon Musk Hitlergruß.
Wir können jetzt nicht einfach nur Rischivasche, ja, okay, hat er uns getrollt oder sowas, sondern nein, es war ein klares Bekenntnis zu einer Ideologie und wir fragen uns, aber welche denn? So, jeder der, klar, einen Holocaust muss man schon leugnen, um ihn sozusagen abzuschwächen. Jeder, der das anerkennt, sechs Millionen Tote, wie stelle ich sicher, dass ich es nicht bin, sondern dass sechs Millionen der anderen getötet werden? Also da tritt man ja auch eine Ideologie los, die am Ende vielleicht einen selber so ein bisschen in den Arsch tritt. Was besonders interessant ist, weil wir mit Hoss und Hopf Leute haben, die diese Ideologie, wie wir gleich hören werden, propagieren, aber gar nichts mit Deutschland zu tun haben. Der eine lebt in der Schweiz und der andere in Dubai. Und die ganze Zeit kümmern sie sich um ihr geliebtes Deutschland, das aber total zu verhassen ist. Und wir haben eben Alice Weidel, die als lesbische Frau in der Schweiz lebt und in Deutschland einen Bundestagswahlkampf anführt mit diesem Ultranationalismus oder diesen neuen Formen von Rechtsradikalität. Nichts davon passt zusammen, insbesondere nicht, dass Alice Weidel im Gespräch mit Elon Musk plötzlich über Hitler redet. Wir hören jetzt wie Ronzheimer und sein Kollege in einem Ronzheimer Podcast sich diese Frage stellen, die sie sich nicht beantworten können. Wird dann aber schon. Also wir nehmen uns das dann mal vor.
Ja, aber genauso verrückt finde ich, wenn sie einfach während des Gesprächs plötzlich darauf kommen. Also warum? Also sie war jetzt vorher auch nicht irgendwie so. Also das macht für mich mindestens genauso wenig Sinn. Hast du eine Erklärung dafür? Also was bringt ihr das, das in dem Moment anzusprechen?
Ich kann es mir auch nicht richtig erklären. Ich glaube, dass die Menschen in Deutschland, die Adolf Hitler für einen Linken halten, also die gibt es.
Die wählen aber eh schon AFD.
Genau, die wählen eh schon AfD.
Und vor Endes der MPD und was es alles gab.
Genau, also die wählen jetzt AfD oder noch rechtsextremere Parteien. Und das bekommt immer so was Schmuddeliges in Deutschland. Und ich hab mir nur gedacht, mein Gott. Ja, aber ich denke mir, jetzt spricht die AfD-Chefin mit dem Gründer von Tesla und dem Eigentümer von X und dem Gründer von SpaceX und kann jetzt mal so die Frau von Welt geben, oder kommt sie mit so einer Hitler-Theorie daher? Ich kann es mir nicht erklären, aber ich glaube, das dürfte ihr nicht nutzen.
So eine anfängliche Erklärung von vielen, wenn man nur aufs mediale Geschehen schaut. Wir haben einen Bundestagswahlkampf, in denen verschiedene Parteien, manche labeln sich als demokratisch und dann wird eine als nicht demokratisch gelabelt, die AfD. So die unterscheiden sich aber nicht nur in dieser ideologischen Ausrichtung, sondern auch in ihrem medialen Verhalten. Während nämlich alle demokratischen Parteien anfangen Plakate zu drucken, auf denen dann irgendwie steht die Rente, die Werbpflicht, was auch immer. Jeder hat so ein programmatisches Ding und da sitzt man einfach im Hinterstiebchen und macht so eine Strategieplanung und sagt, wir könnten noch hier in diese Richtung gehen und dann hoffen, dass dieses Laufpublikum darauf anspringt und wir die damit überzeugen. Was auch immer. Und dann hast du so verschiedene Versuche wie Jens Spahn, der auf der Bühne vor alten Leuten sagt, ich kümmere mich darum, dass sie alle eine Pflegekraft haben. Ich war erst gestern als Gesundheitsminister in Bangladesch in so einer Schule, wo die alle schon Deutsch sprechen. Ich hab die alle eingeladen. Gleichzeitig wird auf Facebook für das junge Publikum hart abgehatet. Also der ist sozusagen ideologisch nicht ganz gefestigt, weil er auf der Suche nach Laufpublikum ist, dass er mit so Wahlkampftricks, ich verschweige den so ein bisschen und so, da irgendwie einzufangen. Das machen alle Parteien so und die AfD macht es ganz anders. Der AfD-Publikum ist das Laufpublikum egal, weil sie wissen Alice Weidel überzeugt niemals Egon, der die Straße runtergeht, mit irgendeinem Spruch. Aber Alice Weidel überzeugt eben Philipp Hopf. So und Philipp Hopf übernimmt dann die Aufgabe, in alle zwei Tage einen Podcast den Egon zu überzeugen, da in die Wahl einzusteigen. Also es geht sozusagen, das kennen wir ja auch im Podcast-Geschäft. Die AfD macht eine Tagesthemsendung, wo sie möglichst alles abdecken will. Und wir sagen einfach, wir bedienen hier einen harten Kern. Kann sein, dass immer mal jemand reinkommt und denkt, ah fünf Stunden sind doch gar nicht so schlecht, ich bleib mal dran. Aber wir senden hier für einen harten Kern. Wir machen hier Podcasts für Leute, die wir einfach sagen können, wir hatten doch vor drei Jahren in diesem Buch hinter der Paywall da und darüber gesprochen und alle sagen, ja genau, stimmt. Und wir denken uns, ja genau, also darüber reden wir jetzt. Wir machen jetzt keine Oma-Erner-Moderation zum nächsten Thema und versuchen es möglichst amüsant zu machen. Ja, das ist Marietta Slomkas Aufgabe so. Das ist Olaf Scholz Aufgabe, das ist Robert Habecks Aufgabe, alle noch mal so und so weiter. Alice Weidel anders. Da wird ein harter Kern einfach immer fester geschmiedet. In der Hoffnung, dass Wärme sich ausbreitet. Und es funktioniert ja auch. Das sehen wir ja.
Und es gab hier dann auch aus dem sagen wir eher gemäßigten konservativen Lager oder rechten Lager Stimmen, die sagten, naja so ganz falsch ist es ja nicht. Also Hitler war ja schon auch in dem Sinne Sozialist und dann gibt es ja gleich so eine Argumentation. Das zieht sich ja durch bis hin zu irgendwelchen Zentren für liberale Moderne und wie die sich alle nennen, die dann immer sagen, naja, so die Nazis waren eigentlich schon auch sozialistisch. Das heißt, das ist ja eine Debatte, die sicherlich in dieser Zugespitze hat, sich die meisten verbieten würden, aber die durchaus in gewissen Kreisen gern gesehen ist, nämlich in Kreisen, die sehr stark gegen alles Linke gerichtet sind. Und im Übrigen auch häufiger gegen Russland. Also das ist ja auch interessant, dass man sagt, ja, Hitler hatte ja auch die Bolschewiki da. Also das ist ja quasi diese ernstnaulte These, die dann da zum Teil weitergesponnen wird. Also man hat hier tatsächlich so etwas, das in dieser Zugespitze selten zu hören ist, was aber durchaus bei vielen diskursfähig ist, Hitler als einen Politiker zu bezeichnen, der sozialistische Ziele verfolgt hat. Das ist eine rechte Strategie schon länger. Das ist jetzt nicht was Neues bei Alice Weide. Deswegen finde ich es gar nicht so obskur, dass das dort stattgefunden hat. Wir müssen aber kurz eine Exkursion machen. Du hast jetzt wieder von Egon und sogar von Oma Erna gesprochen. Es gab Zuschriften, in denen sich Menschen beschwert haben, dass du über Oma Erna immer lässt, wo kommt der Begriff Oma Erna her?
Also das ZDF, das zweite deutsche Fernsehen, macht natürlich Analysen, statistische Erhebung über das eigene Publikum. Deshalb der große Nachrichtensprecher Klaus Kleber damals bei seiner Antrittsvorlesung in Tübingen, wo er so einen Lehrstuhl für irgendwas, keine Ahnung, sie sind berühmt, machen sie doch hier mal ein paar Amtveranstaltungen, sagte, dass am schnellsten wachsenden Publikum sind die 60-Jährigen. Und wir hören ja heute Alain Mafalani mit seinem Sammelband über die Kinderrechte. Wir haben doppelt so viele 60-jährige Geburtstage wie, und da können wir sie in dem zwischen Null und Volljährig so. Also wir haben es mit einer relevanten großen Gruppe zu tun, bei der wir immer denken, hä, wo sind denn die? Also auf Twitter, auf Instagram, ich seh immer nur junge Leute im Fernsehen. Klar jetzt Friedrich Merz ist diese Altersgruppe, aber so Robert Habeck, Annalena Baerbock, diese ganzen CDU-Nachwirkungen. Wo sind diese 60-Jährigen? So und dann stellt es sich raus, das sind ganz stille Leute, die einfach Nachrichten gucken. Und zwar 60-jährige Frauen. Ja, also wenn sich das ZDF auf ein was verlassen kann, dann diese Altersklasse 60 bis 80 weiblich. So. Nicht nur weil die alle zuschauen, sondern weil die anders als die Männer auch noch das alles annehmen, abhaken und geruhsam ins Bett gehen, statt wie Egon, der eben erreichbar ist, sich abends denken.
Ich denk da jetzt nochmal selbst drüber nach.
Genau. Ich guck nochmal nach im Internet. Was ist in der Sachlage? Also in deren Fall, es ist Oma Erna. Das ZDF sendet für Oma Erna, weil Oma Erna einfach treu ist.
Und der Begriff wurde auch von denen so verwendet?
Ja, es ist Elmar Thewesen, der zum einen sagte, die Leute fahren slalom um die Nachrichten. Und wir haben jetzt diese Podcast-Auswertung von Bloomberg bekommen. Diese neuen Podcasts, die die da beobachten, 2000 Stunden lang, 1300 Videos, oder umgedreht, 1300 Stunden von 2000 Videos, ja ist auch egal. Die reden nicht nur über Politik.
Nein, nein.
Aber wenn sie über Politik reden, doppelte Einschaltzgurten, also 20 Prozent der Gäste sind politisch, aber 30 Prozent des Eyeball-Contacts läuft über diese Themen. Das bedeutet eigentlich sind wir hochpolitisiert. Nur die alten Nachrichten kriegen es nicht hin. Warum? Weil sie Oma Erna Programm machen.
Und dieser Begriff Oma Erna ist da ein fester Begriff?
Das ist Elmar Tiewissen selber. Also Elmar Tiewissen hat selber schon mehrfach von Oma Erna gesprochen. Das ist ein Zitat, Elmar Tiewissen.
Und das ist auch gar nicht so ungewöhnlich. Es gibt jetzt zum Beispiel auch für Zeitungen solche Lesewertanalysen. Wer liest welche Seite wie lang. Und dann bekommen zum Teil auch die Redaktionen den Idealleser vorgestellt. Dann bekommt beispielsweise eine Kulturredaktion gesagt, dein Durchschnittslöser ist weiblich und heißt Saskia. Schreib die Artikel für Saskia. Die Sportabteilung bekommt gesagt, dein Leser heißt Matthias, ist 37 Jahre alt, will am liebsten was zum Fußball und noch Handball, aber auf keinen Fall dies. So und das ist durchaus üblich in solchen Analysen, dass dann so ein Name, der Sinnbild für etwas steht, weil natürlich die meisten 19-Jährigen eher nicht Erna heißen.
Ja, wir haben selbst schon Ernas geschrieben, die meinten, ich gehöre da aber nicht dazu. Ich bin das nicht angesprochen und ich denke mir, ja du bist ja auch nicht Oma Erna, nur weil du Erna heißt. Also Erna ist nur das Label für diese Oma Erna und nicht der Name. Gut, zurück zum Kern. Also die AfD kümmert sich um einen Kern, den schmiedet sie, der ist aus Stahl, der soll fest sein, der soll Jahrtausende überdauern. Es geht hier um die Schaffung eines großen Reiches. Problem ist nur, der Rechtsradikalismus wurde diskreditiert durch so ein Vogelschiss, Holocaust, Shoah, Drittes Reich.
Das meinen wir jetzt hier alles in Anführungszeichen.
Das ist für die Leute ein Problem.
Dass nachher jemand klippt und sagt, der Stefan Schulz verbreitet war oder es wird verbreitet und mir dann in die Schuhe geschoben, dass ich es gesagt habe.
Wir kennen das so ein bisschen aus unserer Richtung. Also du bist ein großer Karl-Marx-Leser.
Ja.
So, dann kommt aber einer, aber der Marxismus, Wolfgang, der Marxismus, was hat der Stalin gemacht? Und du denkst dir, ja, ist schon ein bisschen diskreditiert, aber deswegen ist doch noch lange kein Grund, jetzt Marx nicht zu lesen. So, und so die haben jetzt keine Ausgangsschwelle. Die haben ja keine Theorie.
Aber was sie ja machen müssen, ist ja das rechte Gedankengut retten.
Genau.
Und versuchen von Hitler selbst loszulösen. Und deswegen muss auch Elon Musk nochmal bei dieser Veranstaltung sagen, ja, lasst euch da mal von eurer deutschen Schuld und so nicht zu sehr auf den Wecker fallen. Ihr seid schon mit eurem rechten Weg auf dem wirklich richtigen Weg.
Sechs Millionen Tote waren Ausrutscher. Ja, so wird das gekündigt. Also mehr im Sinne von, eigentlich wollen wir doch anderes Besseres wie auch immer. So, wir hören es hier mal von Jens Christian Wagner. Er ist der Leiter der Gedenkstätten Buchenwald, der im Deutschlandfunk zugeschaltet war.
Tatsächlich ist der Rechtsextremismus in Deutschland ja durch die nationalsozialistischen Verbrechen diskreditiert. Und wenn Rechtsextreme wie die AfD mehrheitsfähig in Deutschland werden wollen, dann müssen sie versuchen, sich vom Makel der NS-Verbrechen gewissermaßen zu befreien.
Und dann wird Hitler zum Kommunisten?
Das rechte Denken zu entkriminalisieren und dann redet man entweder wie Gauland davon, dass die nationalsozialistischen Verbrechen ja nur ein Vogelschiss in der deutschen Geschichte gewesen seien. Oder man fordert wie Höcke eine änderungspolitische Wende um 180 Grad. Oder sie haben recht, man behauptet, völlig krude wie Frau Weidel, Hitler sei ja in Wirklichkeit ein Kommunist gewesen. Das ist natürlich vollkommen lächerlich und Unfug. Aber etwas, wenn es nur häufig genug wiederholt wird, was Menschen auch glauben. Und sie glauben gar nicht, wie häufig entsprechende Kommentare wir unter unseren Posts in den Social Media finden. Also das ist tatsächlich ein Mythos mit den linken Nazis, der mittlerweile weit um sich greift, wie auch andere geschichtskribinistische Mythen sich viral verbreiten. Insbesondere natürlich durch die Möglichkeiten des Internet.
Sehr richtig. Es geht ja so gar so weit zum Teil, dass in rechtsradikalen Gruppierungen, es heißt die Nazis waren nicht das Problem, sondern Hitler. Warum war Hitler das Problem? Deren Analyse ist dann, ja weil Hitler eigentlich ja ein Akteur des internationalen Kapitals, also selbst eigentlich jüdisch infiltriert war und nur Deutschland okkupiert hat für seine Zwecke und hat deshalb alles in den Untergang geführt. Also diese Loslösung von Hitler, um gleich noch sogar die Nazis dadurch freizusprechen, ist auch eine, die bislang natürlich in ganz marginalen Gruppen präsent war, die aber jetzt von Alice Weidel auf die große Bühne gehoben wird und dann wird es dankbar aufgegriffen von anderen.
Also da kann man schon mal drauf achten, es gab jetzt ein wahnsinnig interessantes, aber eigentlich kaum klippbares Gespräch, wir hören trotzdem gleich Clips, Gespräch von Esra Klein mit James Pogu, P-O-G-U-E, der selber knapp unter 40 für den New York Times Opinionseite schreibt und der JD Vans schon begleitet hat, als der damals noch Kongressabgeordneter werden wollte, also 2016, 17, 18 ist er auf diese Partys mitgegangen und so. Und da, die haben so eine Theorie vom Regime. 20 Prozent der Gesellschaft ist so eine Gemengelage aus Eliten, Geld, Politik, akademisches Zeug und so weiter. Die bringen ihre Kinder immer nach Harvard, die werden danach immer Kongressabgeordnete und die werden immer Milliardäre. So. Und gegen die wird hart gearbeitet. So.
Die Kathedrale. So nennen die das, ne?
Die Kathedrale, das Regime, wie auch immer, da gibt es verschiedene Begriffe und jetzt wird das ja ausgelebt. Also Jane Evans ist ja angetreten um gegen dieses Regime und stellt jetzt fest, er ist ja selber von Milliardären umgeben in diesem Kabinett. Ja, also da sind ja im Dunstkreis jetzt irgendwie 26 Milliardäre, die so mit echten Tätigkeiten für die Regierung da aufwarten und so. Was ja bedeutet, ah ja, jetzt passiert ja genau dasselbe wie damals, als es schon mal hieß, wir haben hier eine echte Ideologie, wir wollen die Deutschen befreien von was auch immer, aber dann kam dieser Hitler, hat mit Milliardären zusammengearbeitet. So, nach einer Woche schon ist das die so langsam aufkommende Kritik in Amerika, dass man dachte, hey ihr räumt doch die Milliardäre ab und jetzt noch nie so viel Milliardäre wie, also die stolpert man gerade in dasselbe Hitler 2.0 Problem rein, aus dieser Beobachtung von außen, dass sich der Einzelkämpfer, der zu Hause sitzt und dachte, endlich hab ich jemanden, der gegen die Macht, gegen das Geld, gegen die akademische Prominenz und so weiter antritt. Und jetzt stelle ich fest, nee, noch nie so viel Macht und Geld bei meinen Leuten, die ich gerade noch gewählt hab.
Noch nie war es so richtig von Oligarchie zu sprechen.
Genau. Und so ist es ja mit Weidel auch. Also solange sie noch so Hardcore-Opposition macht, alle sich vor sich her treibt, ist jedem egal, dass sie von Goldman Sachs kommt und eigentlich in der Schweiz lebt und der ganze Kram. Aber das ist sozusagen, sie ist jetzt schon Hitler 2.0. Also sie kann so gar nicht die Macht ergreifen oder übernehmen oder man kann es ihr so gar nicht so geben, weil sie sofort wieder in diese Falle reinstoppert.
Ich bin damit ja gar nicht mehr so sicher, ob das nicht jetzt Leute auch in einer anderen Weise toll finden. Denn es gibt natürlich da vielleicht von eigenen Leuten bei Republikanen auch keine Theke. Was ich aber beobachte ist, dass es gerade bei diesen Krypto-Pros, den rechten Krypto-Pros will nicht alle über einen Kamm scheren und bei vielen anderen dieser Leute eine so hohe Identifizierung mit den Superreichen gibt, als seien sie es selbst schon, als könnten sie dadurch auch ihren Reichtum manifestieren, dass sie sagen, ja ich will beherrscht werden von Superreichen, nur bitte andere Superreiche als die, die einer beiden Administration gedient haben. Das heißt, man hat es da wirklich mit dem autoritären Charakter, da ist das absolut richtig, was Theodor Adorno sagte, zu tun, also Leute, die es lieben, in dieser Weise beherrscht zu werden. Nämlich von diesem Strongman, von einer Alice Weidel, die Gift und Galle spuckt auf der Bühne, die richtig herrscht, süchtig ist, dass einem diese Art des Beherrschtwerdens offenbar lieber ist, als ein Beherrschtwerden durch, ja sagen wir, linksliberalen Sprech.
Genau und das sehen wir jetzt auch schon. Dass es nämlich genau diese Bemühungen gibt, zu sagen, wenn schon, denn schon, also wenn dann Elon Musk und nicht Bill Gates. Aber ich will dann auch, dass Elon Musk Bill Gates besiegt. Also ich will das ausgekämpft sehen. Ich möchte die Niederlage von Bill Gates sehen. Also den Milliardären soll das Geld dann auch weggenommen werden. Was jetzt zum Beispiel dazu führt, dass wir in Amerika Trump jetzt schon in der dritten Woche das Justizministerium angewiesen hat, mal zu ermitteln, ob das mit dem Sponsoring von NPR und, wie heißt die zweite, NPR und PBS, also Fernsehen und Radio, das ist öffentlich-rechtlich, in Anführungszeichen. Das wird eben so getragen von Stiftungen hier und da. Ich hab's ja häufiger am Fernsehpodcast.
Und das sind wirklich nur noch Schwundstufen, die sich rechtlich sind.
Absolut, das sieht aus wie Schülerfernsehen, wenn man sich das anschaut. Und die gehen einfach nur die Nachrichtenlage durch. Aber die Sendung beginnt eben mit zwei Minuten lang. Diese Sendung wird ermöglicht von der, hm hm hm hm, dann kommt irgendein Familienname-Fundation, wie auch immer so. Und das ist genau dieses Regime, so gegen das jetzt vorgegangen wird. Das heißt, Trump wird jetzt ein Jahr lang versuchen, den Leuten zu erklären, ja, wir sind Milliardärin, wir sind die guten Milliardäre. Weil wir haben ja noch die schlechten. So wie jetzt auch immer noch versucht wird, dieses Flugzeugabsturz, der ist passiert, weil die beiden Regierungen diese DEI-Programme gemacht hat. Und das werden wir jetzt ausmerzen. Einmal mehr sehen wir, das war der falsche Weg. Wir müssen, wir können ja nicht einfach Frauen einstellen, nur weil es eine Quotenregelung gibt. Der Pilot muss ein aufrechter Mann sein, ausgeschlafen, das kann man nur dem Stärksten übergeben. Also diese Programmatik, die werden sich da rein radikalisieren.
Ja, das Kapital ist ja dann quasi so ein Schutzraum. Also es gibt ja sowieso so eine Lust daran, man will es ganz sicher haben. Wir müssen hoch aufrüsten, dann fühle ich mich morgens gut, wenn ich aufstehe, weil ich weiß, da stehen hunderte von Panzern irgendwo rum. Und es geht, glaube ich, dann auch bei vielen Leuten so, dass man sagt, wir haben dieses ganze Kapital im Hintergrund. Also man sieht das ja auch, dass doch so manche Springer-Journalisten wahnsinnig breitschuldrig auftreten, wo die ja auch nur quasi kleine Angestellte sind. Aber sie haben so diese Milliarden von Friede und Matthias im Hintergrund. Ich bin eigentlich auch schon so stark wie Matthias selbst.
Das ist Gemütszustand, Triggledown, ich kenne den Milliardär. Wenn es hart auf hart kommt, schicke ich den zu dir. Man hat zwar noch nie mit dem gesprochen und kennt ihn auch gar nicht, aber der ist auf meiner Seite. Ich habe es gestern im Internet gelesen, so ungefähr. Und dann fühlt man sich irgendwie stark. So, also Alice Weidel kümmert sich nicht um Laufpublikum. Die redet über Hitler, die redet über irgendwas, die wart in der Partei mit, das war doch nur ein Vogelschiss und das ist deren Ding. Also die machen den festen Kern. Um die Laufkundschaft kümmern sich jetzt andere Leute. Die Diskurslandschaft wird nicht von Alice Weidel gepflegt, sondern jetzt von, bei diesem Beispiel für uns heute, Horst und Hopf. So, Horst und Hopf ist ein wahnsinnig erfolgreicher Podcast. Also wir sind auch ein erfolgreicher Podcast, aber die sind fünf, sechs, siebenmal erfolgreicher als wir.
Das heißt also, jetzt diese Folge überall teilen, damit wir erfolgreicher werden als Horst und Hopf.
Wir können die beiden auch begrüßen, denn wir wissen genau, wenn so wie wir jetzt gleich über Horst und Hopf reden, wenn mal über einen neuen 20er Podcast irgendwo gesprochen wird, hören Wolfgang und ich das sofort. Wir lassen uns aber nichts anmerken. Also Grüße an euch beide nach Dubai in die Schweiz. Hoffentlich ist das Wetter so gut wie hier.
Du hast es dir angetan. Also erst mal Respekt dafür, dass du das...
Ich höre jede Folge.
Du hörst jede Folge.
Es kommt aber schon ganz schön auf, jeden zwei Tag oder so.
Aber man wird ja richtig verrückt dadurch, oder? Nein.
Nein? Ich bin Klardänger geworden.
Mich macht es ziemlich fertig, aber wir werden diese Clips jetzt gemeinsam hier...
Klardänger. Ich könnte sofort dem öffentlich-rechtlichen Funkbogen anbieten. Was Simon Gottlieb nicht gelang, mach ich den wahren Fleischhauer. Die Sendung, die redlich konservativ ist, weil ich weiß wovon ich mich abgrenzen muss. Das hören wir jetzt, wovon wir uns abgrenzen müssen. Also Hoss und Hopf, Diskurs Landschaftspflege für dieses Neurechte-Denken, das sich leider mit dem diskreditierten Hitler nochmal rumschlagen muss. Weshalb wir hier hören, dieses Gespräch von Alice Weidel mit Elon Musk war ganz wichtig.
Der Grund, warum dieses Gespräch so ein großes Ding ist, es gibt eigentlich zwei Gründe. Der erste Grund und das ist für mich auch der relevanteste Grund und was ich auch hier ganz klar hervorgehoben habe, worauf man sich hier eigentlich stürzen sollte und nicht darauf, dass es jetzt mit dieser Person, nicht mit der aus meiner Lieblingspartei oder deiner Lieblingspartei oder der Lieblingspartei von meiner Oma passiert ist, sondern erstens, hier wurde wirklich auf internationaler Ebene mit dem Reichstemann des Planeten ein Gespräch über die Probleme, die Deutschland aktuell hat geführt und ich finde gut, dass Aufmerksamkeit auf internationaler Ebene auf die Probleme, die wir in Deutschland haben, gebracht wird. Das finde ich erstmal grundsätzlich gut und dafür ganz klar ein Dankeschön an Ilorle Masck.
Ja schön, dass der Reichstemann sich so rührend um unser Land kümmert, dass er da große Sorge hat, dass er auch als Amerikaner das nicht in Konkurrenz sieht oder so, sondern wir sind ja alle partnerschaftlich natürlich nur einem großen Projekt verpflichtet, der Liebe.
Jetzt hören wir natürlich immer in diesen ganzen nachrichtlichen Besprechungen, Hitler, Hitler, Hitler, sie hat über Hitler geredet, Alice Weidler hat über Hitler geredet, warum hat sie über Hitler geredet, Philipp, weißt du warum? Nein, Rondsheimer, ich weiß das nicht und so. Also, denen geht es hier darum, dass dort die deutschen Probleme angesprochen wurden. Ich hab jetzt das Gespräch auch nicht in voller Länge gehört, typischerweise mach ich das, aber in dem Fall habe ich mir so gedacht, ja okay, also die reden halt, ich muss jetzt nicht noch die weitere vollständige Stunde hören. Aber ich hab natürlich GPT mal gefragt, ganz neutral, nenn mir nur die Themen. So, GPT sagt und ich hab gesagt nach Priorität geordnet.
Also jetzt von Haus und Topf?
Nein, von Weidel gegen Masken. Wo sie ja sagen, da wurden noch über die deutschen Probleme gesprochen und es stimmt. Also wichtigstes Thema Energiepolitik in Deutschland, Klammer auf, Abschaltung der Kernkraftwerke, erneuerbare Energien, Energieabhängigkeit von Russland. Wir können uns alle denken, was da besprochen wurde. So, zweitens Wirtschaftspolitik und Bürokratie, hohe Steuern, übermäßige Regulierung, bürokratische Hürden. Punkt drei, Migrationspolitik und innere Sicherheit, illegale Migration, soziale Auswirkung, Kriminalität. Viertens, AfD und ihre politische Positionierung, libertär-konservativ, Medienberichterstattung über die Partei, Vorwürfe des Extremismus. Punkt fünf, Bildungspolitik und Vogue-Agenda, Leistungsabfall im deutschen Schulsystem, Genderdebatte. Punkt sechs, Medien, Zensur und Meinungsfreiheit, also Digital Services Act wurde besprochen, Vergleiche mit historischen Diktaturen. Punkt sieben, Krieg in der Ukraine und geopolitische Entwicklung, europäische Abhängigkeit von den USA, mögliche Lösungen für den Konflikt. Punkt acht, Israel, Nahe Osten. Punkt neun, Elon Musk Vision für die Besiedelung des Marses. Zehn, Glaube und Existenz Gottes.
Ja, da konnte Elon Musk ja nicht so richtig sagen, dass er vom lieben Gott nicht so viel hält und musste sich dann auch so ein bisschen rauslavieren.
Ja, muss er ja häufiger. Sie sind ein sehr guter Gamer, Herr Musk. Ja, ich bin Top 20.
Ja, er hat ja wohl da jemanden bezahlt, der für ihn spielt. Ja, er als besserer Gamer dasteht.
Stefan schultz.com, ich blokke jetzt wieder. Ich nehme mir jetzt wieder das vor, von dem alle sagen, interessiert niemanden, geschriebener Text, bist du bescheuert auf einer eigenen Webseite. Aber ich denke mir so, für mich ist es wieder 2008. Gut. Ich habe auch über Elon Musk Gamer-Gate geschrieben. Das ist nämlich sehr witzig, denn jemand, der Leute bezahlt, damit sie für ihn irgendwelche Dinge in spielen. Ja, wer baut denn seine Raketen und seine Autos? Also das ist doch was für eine alberne Diskussion. Natürlich lässt er für sich spielen. Gut, also wir haben hier durchaus Themen, die in einem Gespräch stattfanden, die uns interessieren. Das sind die Standard-Nachrichten-Themen. Halt mit einem anderen Einschlag, aber das sind die Standard-Nachrichten-Themen. So, wurde über Hitler in dem Gespräch gesprochen? Ja, für ungefähr sieben Minuten. Es ging um Vergleiche mit der aktuellen Zensurpolitik, Darstellung Hitler als Sozialisten und sich stellt einen Zusammenhang zwischen Sozialismus, Neid und Antisemitismus her. So, der Antisemitismus wird jetzt über Neid den Sozialisten in die Schuhe geschoben. Ist natürlich ein cleverer Weg. Warum sollte man das nicht machen? Aus dieser Richtung. So, Elon Musk ergänzt, dass tutatilitäre Regime oft durch Kontrolle der Wirtschaft und Bildung Macht gewinnen. Ja gut, das wäre jetzt schon ein interessanter Fall, da würde ich nochmal nachhören, um was es da genau geht, aber gut. Muss jetzt hier an dem Punkt nicht interessieren und Antisemitismus und historische Vergleiche. Okay, also diese Leute normalisieren uns hier diesen ultranationalen, ethno-pluralistischen, hartrechten, rechtsradikalen Kern, indem sie eine Diskurslandschaft mit Themen drum herum, die uns im Übrigen ja sowieso auch interessieren, gestalten. Hier kommt also die Radikalität von Weidel nicht zu sprechen, sondern es wird drum rum geredet. Allerdings mit dem klaren Zug, es gibt da jemanden, den ihr wählen könnt, wenn ihr so denkt wie wir. So das ist der Weg. Also andersrum als wir es bisher denken, dass die ganzen Parteien so hier und da mal ein Angebot machen und stundenlange Reden halten wie Helmut Kohl, wo alles drin vorkommt und die Journalisten dann so harte Kerne definieren. Nein, es ist hier genau umgedreht. So, Hitler war links, wird jetzt hier aufgegriffen, auch bei Hoss und Hopf, mit einem uns bekannten prominenten Leumund an dieser Stelle. Und ich hab hier auch was gefunden, was man absolut hier nehmen kann als Quelle, wo man nichts sagen kann, dass die irgendwie im Verdacht stehen, pro Nationalsozialismus zu sein und das... Das was jetzt kommt, mein ich noch nicht. Es gibt dann einen anderen Leumund. Jetzt sagt er uns erstmal den Namen der Zeitung. Das ist ihm so wichtig, dass er uns dreimal sagt. Also die Strategie ist sehr übersichtlich und einfach.
Das ist die Jüdische Rundschau.
Das ist ein deutsches Magazin, die Jüdische Rundschau. Und hier in der Jüdischen Rundschau wird... Also wo? In der Jüdischen Rundschau? Im deutschen Magazin der Jüdischen Rundschau, die Jüdische Rundschau.
Jetzt werden die meisten Leute sich fragen, jüdisch rum, ich hab noch nie gehört, was kann das sein? Und ich habe auch jetzt überlegt, was soll das sein? Na ja, meinen Sie vielleicht die Jüdische Allgemeine? Nein, Sie meinen die Jüdische Rundschau, die gibt es. Wenn man diese Internetseite einmal öffnet, dann stellt man fest, okay, die sind jetzt also sehr rechts in allen möglichen Belangen.
Haben wir es etwa in Israel mit einer rechtsradikalen Regierung zu tun? Und die Jüdische Rundschau kann dementsprechend vielleicht ein Magazin sein, das in diese Richtung denkt und zu schreiben.
Also man geht auf die Seite und nach 15 Sekunden weiß man genau, was da los ist und denkt, wo ist eigentlich der Link noch zu tischies Einblick und was weiß ich alles. Also es ist ja, aber es ist so schön.
Mir ging es noch nicht mal um die Jüdische Rundschau, sondern mir geht es ja noch um andere.
Das sieht es aber dreimal erwehren, um so zu tun. Seht her, wir wissen natürlich um unsere Geschichte und müssen da gucken.
Auch die Juden sagen, Hitler mal leben. Irgendwie im Verdacht stehen pro Nationalsozialismus zu sein und das ist die Jüdische Rundschau. Das ist ein deutsches Magazin, die Jüdische Rundschau. Und hier in der Jüdischen Rundschau wird folgendes geschrieben. Adolf Hitlers Weltanschauung wird bis heute als rechtsextrem eingestuft. Doch das neu aufgelegte Buch von Dr. Dr. Rainer Zittlmann widerspricht dieser Einordnung. Die nationalsozialistische deutsche Arbeiterpartei. Wie viel mehr Links braucht man eigentlich noch in seinem Namen? Das schreiben die hier. War zu Beginn eine linke Präkaritätsbewegung und ein Sammelbecken besonders gegen Juden, neiderfüllter und häufig gescheiterter Lebensläufe. Also gescheiterte Lebensläufe bei den Linken? Hm, haben wir sowas schon mal gesehen? Jo. Das haben auch die JR., also die Jüdische Rundschau und ihr Herausgeber Dr. Raphael Kurzenzecher schon in der Vergangenheit in klarer Übereinstimmung zu Dr. Zittlmann festgehalten. In Zitat Hitler selbstverständlich eines Revolutionärs zeigt Zittlmann überzeugend, dass Hitler sich nicht als rechter Verstand, sondern als antikapitalistische Revolutionär, das ist das Gegenteil von einem Rechten, der Konservative verachtete. Ich bezeichne mich selber als liberal-konservativen, das heißt ich wäre von Hitler verachtet worden, weil man uns ja auch gerne den Vorwurf macht Rechtsextrem zu sein. So, also in einer Ideologie, in der man die alten Institutionen angreift, und das hat ja Weidel in dem Gespräch mit Musk auch gemacht, unsere Studenten lernen nur noch Vogue-Gender-Agenda und dann muss selbst Musk mal kurz nachfragen, hey ich dachte ihr habt so ein gutes Ausbildungssystem. Also es wird alles diskreditiert, es sei denn Doktor Doktor schreibt ein Buch und Doktor Herausgeber jüdischer Allgemeine sagt, dann ist es immer nur noch Doktor Doktor Doktor Doktor Doktor, ganz wichtig Doktor, wer würde denn einem Doktor widersprechen? So und dann natürlich die Standardideologie wird dann ausgebreitet. Hitler war ein Nationalsozialist, der sich einmal in der Macht angekommen, den Milliardären unterworfen hat, um deren Kapitalismus-Kruppstahl-Agenda durchzuziehen. So Hopf holt das jetzt in die Gegenwart. Also Hitler wird jetzt sozusagen die Geschichte überlassen. Es wäre noch schön, wenn Politiker ihr Land mal wieder lieben. Kommt jetzt sozusagen dieser Diskurs Landschaftspflege daher und ich sage mir, ja warum? Also das kann man doch einfach mal sich so anhören, wie es da besprochen wird. Wir müssen uns natürlich dann weiterführende Gedanken machen. Die Volksvertreter, ein Teil von ihnen, Robert Habeck kann mit Vaterlands Liebe nichts anfangen, kann mit Deutschland und dem Konzept Volk per se nichts anfangen. Der ist Minister in unserem Land und er kann mit dem Land per se nichts anfangen, mit dem Konzept eines Nationalstaates. Da kann man dann schon von Verachtung und Hass auf das eigene Land sprechen. Ich finde das ist ja, das ist eigentlich nichts, nichts irgendwie was da außerhalb der Norm erscheint.
Also was sie da sagt... Es ist halt wirklich eine sehr wichtige Rolle.
Klar, aber wenn du etwas nicht liebst, wenn du etwas nicht liebst, wenn du etwas nicht liebst, dann gibst du auch nicht acht darauf. Wenn du etwas nicht liebst, dann kümmerst du dich nicht darum, dann denkst du nicht daran. Wenn du etwas wirklich liebst, dann ist es dein wichtigstes dich darum zu kümmern. Wer sein Land liebt oder wer, was weiß ich, sein Auto liebt, der gibt es zur Autowäsche, der poliert es. Wer sein Zimmer liebt, der hält es in Ordnung, der hält es sauber. Wer sein Land aber nicht liebt, wer es verachtet. Nun, der hat das Ergebnis jetzt in Deutschland und das sehen wir, was hier passiert an allen Ecken und Enden, erodiert es, es fällt auseinander. Wir sehen es. Wir sehen Magdeburg und noch hunderte andere Dinge, Massenvergewaltigungen, Vergewaltiger, die mit Bewehrungsstrafen rauskommen. Das kann nur, diese Urteile können nur von Leuten gesprochen werden, die tiefe Verachtung für das eigene Land und für die Menschen im eigenen Land haben. Das ist meine persönliche Meinung und meine Erfahrung, die ich in den letzten Jahren gemacht habe. So, hier muss man jetzt sehen, es wird kritisiert, dass der angesprochene Habeck immer nur von Deutschland, die Wirtschaft von irgendwas spricht, aber nicht die Leute meint, die hier leben, die Deutschen, die doch dieses Land brauchen. Es geht doch um uns. Wir müssen doch unser Land lieben. Wir müssen doch alle unser Land lieben. Und das ist eine ganz interessante Gleichsetzung von privaten und öffentlichem Haushalt. Dunja Hayali, und das muss man jetzt wirklich mal ganz deutlich sagen, ich eröffne mein Buch mit dieser Poante, kann jetzt schon mal verraten, kommt jetzt März, aber mit dieser Poante Dunja Hayali macht Abendnachrichten und sagt, das ist genau ein Zitat, steht im Buch sinngemäß, wer seinen Haushalt zu Hause führt, weiß, man darf nicht immer über die Stränge schlagen. Was ist also mit der Schuldenbremse? Und man denkt sich so, nein, Dunja, das ist genau das Problem. Diese Gleichsetzung, dann kannst du dich gleich einsortieren bei Hoss und Hopf, die genau diese Ideologie auch weitertragen.
Das ist die schwäbische Hausfrau, die kümmert sich noch.
Ganz genau. So und das ist einfach nicht so. Wir können nicht die ganze Zeit sagen, ich hab doch auch ein Auto. Also wer seinen Gartenzaun nicht zu macht, muss sich doch nicht wundern, dass Leute eindringen und so weiter.
Das ist ja übrigens dieser berühmte Roman des Franzosen, der davon handelt, dass Frankreich von Migranten überflutet wird und ein alter Herr dann da den Gartenzaun zu macht und sich versucht abzuschotten von der Welt. Und das ist genau diese Denkweise.
Genau. Also wenn schon das Land vor die Hunde geht, dann muss ich auf meinen Rasen halt besonders selber achten, also mich selbst ermächtigen, das wird dann auch gleich, wie das dann weitergedacht wird. Aber es ist wirklich sehr dramatisch.
Vor allem diese Vaterlands Liebe, die da angesprochen wird. Also es ist ja so, dass wir einen neuen Patriotismus schon seit der Sommer-WM haben, seit diesem Sommer Märchen, dass man hatte. Damit fing das an, wir brauchen so einen fröhlichen Patriotismus, eine positive Identifizierung mit dem Land, da ging das ja alles so los und doch mal wieder mit den Fans. Und dann nahm das immer stärker zu. Dann in der Hip-Hop-Szene, jetzt hat ja gerade Flair, der sich auch immer als Patriot bezeichnet hat, irgendwelche Fotos gemacht mit Philipp Amthor. Das war immer diese Idee, naja, genau der Patriotismus ist ja das, was alle brauchen und was uns auch alle eint. Was natürlich da immer verdeckt bleibt, ist, dass es Widersprüche gibt, Klassenwidersprüche nämlich, zum Beispiel zwischen dem Mieter und dem Vermieter oder dem Angestellten und dem Chef. Da ist nicht irgendein patriotisches Wir. Und dieses Vaterland, das da heraufbeschworen wird, ist jederzeit bereit, wenn du nicht entsprechend die Leistung bringst, die von dir erfordert wird, dich in Bürgergeld zu drücken und dich mit Sanktionen zu malträtieren. Und dass das aber immer wieder jetzt aufgerufen wird als das Wir, ist etwas, was allgemein verbreitet ist. Und deswegen ist es auch genau richtig von dir, dann auch jetzt mal eine Dunja Hayali oder wegen mir auch die Grünen mit ins Boot zu nehmen. Denn das Interessante ist ja, dass ja Robert Habeck tatsächlich patriotisch dann immer in dieser Weise ist, er sagt, ja es geht um das ganze Land und wir und der Wirtschaftsstandort. Ich habe mit dem Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland nur dann positiv etwas zu tun, wenn mein Lohn erhöht wird. Sobald ich aber für den Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland auf eine Lohnerhöhung verzichten soll, um das BIP, um die Profite von Herrn Kühne und weiß ich nicht wem zu steigern, dann ist das nicht mehr mein patriotisches bla bla bla. Deswegen ist dieses nationale Wir an sich schon ein Irrsinn und der wird natürlich jetzt hier besonders überspitzt, sodass wir das alle sehr gut erkennen ins Feld geführt. Aber generell kann man mal drauf achten, wie sehr diese Art der Denkweise schon verbreitet ist. Und dann wird sich nur noch darüber gestritten, ja wer ist denn der bessere Patriot? Und dann gibt es nämlich auch von von bis links liberal dann so eine Argumentation, ja die AfD das sind gar nicht die richtigen Patrioten. Wir sind die viel besseren Deutschen.
Also wenn wir jetzt Söder, Dunja Hayali, Merz nehmen, die wissen einfach nicht, wie ihn geschieht. Also die greifen so eine Stimmung auf und dann kommt sie wieder irgendwie mit. Alle Kinder in Bayern sind unsere Kinder. Wir lieben alle unsere Kinder. Wir möchten, dass alle Eltern ihre Kinder abends in den Arm nehmen. Man denkt sich so, nee auch in Bayern leben ein Drittel der Kinder in Armut. Und auch in Bayern ist es das normale Schicksal für leinerziehende Eltern, dass natürlich diese Mütter, weil sie sich um ihre Kinder kümmern, abends arbeiten, nach Büroschluss, nach Feierabend, weil der meist häufigste Beruf unter alleinerziehenden Frauen ist der Raumpfleger. Weil man da dem Kind einfach sagen kann, so alles ist ja ledig, du bist gut durch den Schultag gekommen und so weiter, jetzt guck noch Netflix und geh dann alleine ins Bett. Ich hab endlich Zeit zu arbeiten. Also fährt man dann in diese Büros und weiter. Also niemand kümmert sich irgendwie. Aber dann kommt diese großen, dieses Gerede die ganze Zeit.
Es gab mir eine Studie vom Verbraucherverband in diesem Monat, eine Umfrage. 39% der Menschen in Deutschland schränken sich beim Lebensmitteleinkaufen ein, müssen sich einschränken. Das heißt, sie kaufen weniger gesunde Produkte für ihre Kinder. Das heißt, die Kinder sind schlecht ernährt in Deutschland, weil ein so liebevolles Land so viele Leute in Armut hält und in Niedriglohnsektoren steckt, wo sie nicht genügend Geld haben für den Familieneinkommen.
Genau. Und jetzt kann man sich überlegen, während, also ich hab jetzt gesagt, Merz, Söder, Dunja Healy, die wissen nicht, wie ihnen geschieht, die gehen mit so einer Stimmung, mit so einem Vibe und merken einfach nicht, wie sie so eine Ideologie bedienen, indem sie so eine Unverwechselbarkeit von privater und öffentlicher Haushaltsführung und so weiter herstellen. Nur, Taka Carlsen, Hoss und Hopf, Alice Weidel, Elon Musk, wenn die irgendwie auf der Bühne stehen, wir haben ja Taka Carlsen gehört, der sagt, lieber will ich, dass mein Land abbrennt, bevor sich die Kultur, mein Haus abbrennt, bevor sich die Kultur meines Landes ändert. Ich lebe lieber obdachlos unter meinesgleichen, als jetzt irgendwie von Ausländern überflutet. Elon Musk, bei dem Alex Jones sagt, oh, er hat einen Hit entgegen seine eigene Company genommen, fürs Land, für die Republik, verzichtet. So und jetzt kommen die Hoss und Hopf und sagt, ja, kümmert euch. Diese Leute, die wissen ganz genau, das was wir hier planen, ist ein Runterfahren der Wirtschaft. Also wenn wir die Ausländer, wir müssen sie gar nicht vertreiben, wir müssen einfach nur, sagen wir mal, den Zustrom der nächsten fünf Jahre dämpfen. Wie so ein Vogelvergrämmer am Flughafen, der irgendwie sagt, ihr kommt hier nicht her und so. Das bedeutet weniger für alle. Aber nicht ganz für alle. Denn die sind in Sicherheit. Tucker Carlson verzichtet nicht auf sein Haus. Elon Musk verzichtet nicht auf sein Haus.
Die bekommen ja noch mehr. Also alle Finanzströme, die noch da sind, bündeln die auf sich. Das wäre etwa so, als würden wir sagen, wir treten jetzt an, werden die Regierung und sorgen dafür, dass Podcasts verboten werden, außer unserer. Wir sollen bleiben.
Genau. Wir sind ja im Dunstkreis und wir haben auch nie wie PBS irgendwelche Stiftungsgelder entgegen genommen. Wozu auch? Wir brauchen ja kein Budget um irgendwie, keine Ahnung, was ist denn ja sonst noch los jenseits meines Dunstkreises und so und so. Sieht ihr halt nicht.
Und dann bündeln wir einfach alle Finanzströme, die im Podcast-Business sind, auf uns und sagen, ja, ist doch gut gelaufen.
Was aber eben bedeutet, wenn man hier undurchdacht an die Sache rangeht, wie Dunja Hayali und viele andere in den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, wie Friedrich Merz, der einfach nicht weiß, wie ihm geschieht, unterstützt man diese Ideologie.
Ja und ich...
Und die ist eine große Lüge für die einzelnen Leute, die jetzt Hoss und Hopf zuhören und denken.
Ich wollte eigentlich nicht heute wieder so sehr die Medien kritisieren, aber ich komme nicht umhin. Denn als dieses Erschaffenburg war, haben irgendwelche Funkjournalisten und so weiter schon bei Twitter geschrieben, da war das nur in die Meldung, wenn sich das bewahrheitet, hat dann ein Funk-Heini geschrieben, dann wird das alles verändern. Und ich dachte so, ha, wieso? Also entweder gab es schon vorher Probleme mit Migration, oder es gab sie nicht, oder es gab sie nur so halb oder was. Aber das ist ja jetzt ein Fall, der schrecklich ist und der aufgeklärt gehört etc. Aber warum verändert das jetzt alles? Und das ist aber genau die Logik, nach der dann die ganzen Medien, uns wirklich alle, darauf gegangen sind. Und sie haben ja auch nichts geliefert zu den Wahlprogrammen. Das konnte man doch wunderbar sehen. Es gab diese merkwürdige Äußerung der Grünen, ja, wir müssten bei Kapitalerträgen auch die Krankenversicherungen so was mit einbeziehen. Also die Beitragsbemessungsgrenze muss da angepasst werden mit Kapitalerträgen. Man hat nicht so richtig rausgefunden, was die Grünen da wollten. Dann gab es da mal so einen kleinen kurzen Aufschrei. Man hat sich aber nicht die Mühe gemacht, da wirklich eine interessante Debatte draus zu machen. Man hat sich ja nicht einmal journalistisch die Mühe gemacht, mal in die anderen Programme reinzuschauen, wie geht man da mit Kapitalerträgen um. Dann wäre man beispielsweise darauf gestoßen, das Linke, SPD, Grüne, BSW, alle sagen, wir müssen die Kapitalerträge wie Einkommen besteuern. Dann könnte man ja überlegen, wäre das eine gute Angelegenheit. Dann könnte man zu der Schlussform kommen, ja, für etwa 95% der Menschen in Deutschland wäre das wunderbar, denn dann gäbe es erhebliche Mehreinnahmen, weil die obersten 5% von Kapitalerträgen leben und die weniger besteuern müssen als ihr Einkommen. Und das wäre die große Debatte gewesen. Da ging es nämlich mal um ganz viele Steuereinnahmen. Da könnte man sogar noch, wenn man diese Steuereinnahmen hätten, über Steuernachlässe bei der Einkommenssteuer nachdenken. Um Arbeit weniger zu besteuern. Das wäre die Debatte gewesen, die wollte man nicht führen, hätte man ja vielleicht mal ein paar Seiten lesen müssen. Von dessen hat man gesagt, ach ja, Anschlag in Aschaffenburg mit Magdeburg, hat es nicht so richtig funktioniert, weil der Fall ein bisschen kompliziert war. Ja, war doch schon lange da und hat auch AfD-Content geteilt. Was war denn das für ein komischer Mann? Aber hier ist es jetzt eindeutiger. Also gehen wir nur auf dieses eine Thema noch. Und damit haben wir, du hast es ja schon prophezeit, aber auch in dieser Dimension glaube ich nicht geahnt, so haben wir tatsächlich den dümmsten Wahlkampf aller Zeiten bekommen.
Das Problem ist hier insbesondere und ich will es ganz deutlich sagen, weil wir nähern uns auch einem Clip, in dem wir Peter Thiel gegen David Graeber in ihrer einzigen Auseinandersetzung 2017 hören. Diese Liste, die Alice Weidel angesprochen hat bei Elon Musk. Diese Themen, die ansonsten noch in diesem Hossenhof-Podcast, der alle zwei Tage kommt, was schon ein bisschen viel ist, finde ich, thematisiert wird, sind auch alle meine Themen.
Ja.
Ich finde auch, dass die Schule scheiße läuft. Beim Thema Migration, Deutschland hat keinen Plan von nichts. Das institutionelle, die Dummheit ist so groß, ist grenzenlos. Die politische Programmatik dazu ist nicht der Rede wert. Also das ist einfach absurd, was da krass diskutiert wird. Das ist alles scheiße. Nur, warte, lass mich das sagen. Die Themen basieren auf im Kern einem Problem, das ich mit Hoss und Hopf teile. Nur die gehen den Peter Thiel Weg und wir gehen den David Grapper Weg. Aber in der Problematisierung und in der Thematisierung liegen alle genau richtig. Dabei niemand über Lösungen reden möchte, verstricken die sich gleich. Hören wir dann in so einem ermächtige dich selbst, lese unser Buch jeden Tag und du wirst besser. Du kannst dich gegen den Staat, die Gesellschaft, deinen Kanzler und so, macht dich, er tüchtige dich. Während wir denken, nein, die Lösung muss eine andere sein. Nur es wäre schön, lieber öffentlich-rechtlicher Rundfunk, lieber Doner-Heil-Lali, wenn ihr einmal, eine Minute, irgendwann mal eine Lösung präsentieren würdet, wie das ganze Zeug und nicht immer nur das Problem, das Problem. Herr Söder, wie lösen Sie Ihr Problem? Herr Merz, haben Sie eine Lösung? Warum können die nicht mal aus eigener Kraft eine Lösung präsentieren für diese Probleme, die sie uns die ganze Zeit erklären?
Ja, und da müsste man auch mal ins Regionale rein. Ich habe jetzt gerade gesehen, wie in einem Ort in Rheinland-Pfalz, dort Container errichtet werden, in dem zukünftig Flüchtlinge leben sollen. Diese Container stehen am Rande eines Industriegebiets. Um in die Stadt zu kommen, muss man über merkwürdige Wege lange mit dem Fahrrad fahren, der Bus fährt von da nicht ab. Das heißt, man produziert jetzt da gerade einen Hort für unglaublich viele Probleme.
Aber sie hängen nicht in der Turnhalle um. Siehste, Problem gelöst.
So ist die Denkweise. So ist die Denkweise. Und nachher sagt man wieder, ah ja, das haben wir alles wieder nicht gesehen und da wollte man sich nicht mit beschäftigen. Da wäre die interessante Beschäftigung da. Da könnte sie medial aufbereitet werden, findet nicht statt.
Also lieber öffentlich-rechtlicher Rundfunk, Hoss und Hopf hassen euch in einem Ausmaß, das ich teile. Das ich teile. Nur, wir werden gleich dazu kommen.
Nur in anderer Weise.
In anderer Weise. Aber glaubt nicht, dass ihr hier irgendwo sicher seid, eure neun Milliarden und so. Ja, wir sehen jetzt wie Trump da schon anfängt, das kurz zum Kleinen zu schlagen. Das lässt sich noch verhindern, aber man muss vielleicht den einen oder anderen Lösungsvorschlag den Leuten, wir kennen ja von Lenin, die große Logik, Revolutionen, können überhaupt erst nur angefangen werden, wenn es eine Perspektive gibt. Wenn nur Probleme im Raum stehen, ja dann geht man den kürzesten Weg und dann folgt man eben einfach seinen Emotionen und dann landet man schnell bei Hoss und Hopf. Die allerdings sind natürlich klug. Also die machen ja nicht nur emotional, die machen ja Programmatik, wozu auch gehört die andere Seite kurz zum Kleinen zu schlagen. Es gibt doch keine extremistischere Vereinigung in Deutschland, die noch krasser andere Meinungen unterdrückt und Gewalt anwendet, um diese anderen Meinungen stillzuhalten. Um die Leute zu diffamieren, um Leute fertig zu machen mit Gewaltanwendungen. Das ist quasi die eins zu eins Nachfolgeorganisation der SA, der Sturmabteilung im Dritten Reich, ist für mich heutzutage die Antifa. Nicht nur wir haben nichts mit Hitler zu tun, sondern die Antifa ist die Nachfolgeorganisation der SA. Das ist so absurd, aber okay, okay. Wir wissen jetzt, in welchem Rahmen das gedacht ist und wie das gemeint ist vor allem. Welche Lösung hier drinstecken soll für welche Problemdefinition. So, jetzt kommt das, worum es hier grundsätzlich geht. Diskurs Landschaftspflege. Es findet gerade eine Handball-WM statt, jetzt ohne deutsche Beteiligung, denn sie haben es nicht so richtig geschafft. Man kann es auch kaum sehen, weil das läuft auf irgend so um keine Ahnung sparten Programmen, wenn es nicht in A drückt. So, Hoss und Hopf senden fast jeden Tag. Und zwar reden die über alles, was junge Menschen bewegt, wie zum Beispiel Handball. So, das Gespräch läuft dann hier ein sehr unscheinbarer unschuldiger Clip. Wir verstehen aber jetzt, ah ja, so ist das gemeint.
Die, die es jetzt wirklich bis hier bis zum Ende anhören, die sind jetzt die Hoss und Hopf OGs. Und zwar will ich die eine Seite vom Buch heute mal vorlesen. Ich hab sie in der Hand und zwar 11. Januar.
Ich hab's auch gerade bei mir da liegen.
Du kannst nicht nach den Sternen greifen, wenn du denkst, der Himmel ist die Grenze. Handball ist ein Sport, der uns viel zeigen kann. Der Sport ist schnell, man lernt, Entscheidungen in Sekundenbruchteilen zu fällen. Er wird antizipativ ausgeführt, man muss auf dem Spielfeld vorausdenken. Es geht ruppig zu, man setzt sich in hartendes Situationen durch. Und gerade den Torhütern sagt man eine positive Verrücktheit nach, denn wer lässt sich schon freiwillig aus kurzem Abstand mit einem 120 qm schnellen Lederball bewerfen? Andreas Wolf gehört zu den erfolgreichsten Handball-Torhütern der Welt. Mit seinem Motto, du kannst nicht nach den Sternen greifen, wenn du denkst, der Himmel ist die Grenze, gewann er den Super Cup, den DHB Pokal, den EHF Pokal, die Europameisterschaft, bei den Olympischen Spielen, wurde zweimal Deutschlands Handballer des Jahres und bei der Europamassterschaft 2024 das beste Keeper des Turniers ins All-Star-Team gewählt. Also denk daran, wenn du nach den Sternen greifst, the sky is not the limit.
So ist es.
So, wenn du einmal eine gefestigte Ideologie hast, kannst du thematisch da alles dran kleben. Deswegen ist es auch kein Problem, 365 Geschichten in ein kleines Buch zu schreiben. Also das war jetzt so eine Seite. Das sind 365 solcher Dinger. So funktioniert jetzt jetzt. Also das ist diese Ausbreitung, Einfangen der Laufkundschaft und so weiter und so fort. Wir müssen nicht alles weiter zuhören, die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen. Wir müssen jetzt Hoss und Hopf hören. So, also wenn du nach den Sternen greifen willst, the sky is not a limit. Du musst jetzt darüber hinausgehen. Was bedeutet, du musst an dir arbeiten, Wolfgang. Du arbeitest ja auch schon an dir. Ja. Das sind jetzt hier, jetzt gehen wir in deine Richtung.
Das ist die wirkliche Message dieses Podcasts und unseres Wirkens.
Erreicht Freiheit, finanzielle Freiheit bedeutet, Freiheit im Leben bedeutet, ihr habt Optionen, alle Optionen, die ihr nehmen könnt. Wenn ihr woanders hingehen wollt, dann macht ihr das. Wenn ihr irgendwo Urlaub machen wollt, wacht ihr das. Wenn ihr euren Mund aufmachen wollt, dann braucht ihr Geld. Dann können sie euch den Mund nicht verbieten.
Das sind die mächtigen Leute, die sagen können, was sie wollen, nicht die mittellosen Leute.
Und deswegen jeden Tag fünf Minuten Zeit investieren, Leute. Ich finde es ganz toll, wie viele hunderte Menschen uns zu uns zuschreiben und anschreiben jeden Tag, die die Seiten posten, die das durchgehen intensiv, lesen jeden Tag eine Seite durch und ich sage euch, ihr werdet nach einem Jahr euer eigenes Leben nicht wiedererkennen, weil ihr solche Fortschritte erzielt habt. So und damit schließen wir das Ganze. Wir wünschen euch jetzt eine wunderschöne Woche.
Macht's gut.
Bis bald.
Man löscht die Gesellschaft aus und hat nur noch das Individuum und den dualistischen...
Ja man löscht die Gesellschaft nicht ganz aus.
Wenn man mit ihr Geld verdienen kann.
Ja, also man kriegt sie ja nicht los. Es sind ja noch andere Leute da, also der Fremde, das Unbekannte, das ist ja immer noch da. Aber es ist eben nicht sehr kompliziert sich in der Welt durchzusetzen, du musst nur der Stärkste sein, der am besten vorbereitet ist. Wenn du dich jeden Tag vorbereitet hast, dann ist diese Welt für dich. Denn die Welt, Wolfgang, egal welche Wünsche du hast, die Welt funktioniert, wie sie funktioniert. Versuch nicht in die Welt einzugreifen. Die Welt kennt nur ein Gesetz. Wenn die Zeiten mal hart werden wie jetzt, dann hast du nur noch Versager da, die nicht in der Lage sind, zu den Herausforderungen zu wachsen. Sie sind nicht stark genug. Warum?
Weil man Schwäche eingestellt hat.
Man hat nicht die Stärksten eingestellt, wie auch das Gesetz der Natur ist. Nur die Stärksten überleben. Nein, man hat bewusst die Schwächsten reingeholt.
Und ich denke, das riecht sich jetzt.
So, das ist eine Standardargumentation von dem HOPF. Denn es ist völlig egal. In dem Fall waren es die LA Fire. Die Feuerwehr konnte nicht löschen, weil da zu viele schwache Frauen waren. Man hat Zwerge angestellt. Wie bescheuert ist denn das? Man muss die stärksten Feuerwehrmänner anstellen. So, das Flugzeugunglück in Washington, genau dasselbe. Der Podcast beginnt mit einem Thema, um dann immer drauf hinaus zu laufen. Ist doch kein Wunder, man hat einfach nicht die stärksten eingestellt. Die Leute machen sich Gedanken über Politik. Die wollen mit Programmen irgendwas ändern. Da weiß doch jeder, einfach den stärksten einstellen, an den Posten, wo man ihn am meisten braucht. Fertig. Dann können alle wieder sich um sich selber kümmern, ins Gym gehen, eine Seite Haus und Hopf lesen. Nicht über Politik nachdenken. Es gibt nur ein Gesetz und es war immer so und es wird immer so sein. Die Welt ist schon immer so aufgebaut.
Die Natur ist so aufgebaut.
Das Gesetz des Stärkeren. Das ist nun mal so.
In der Natur stirbt der Schwache und es überlebt der Stärkere. Das ist einfach Natur-Fakt seitdem es die Erde gibt.
Das heißt es gibt keinerlei Solidarität?
Null Solidarität, Wolfgang.
Nur noch Kampf aller gegen alle und die Stärksten setzen sich durch.
Schau mal, rosse auf, gucken, fertig. Was willst denn lange reden über irgendwas, ja? Es gibt nur einen Maßstab. Wir sind alle in Eile. Wir wollen das Sachen geregelt werden. Donald Trump findet zum Beispiel Kämpfen ganz gut. Warum?
Das war ein Typ, der über Kämpfe gesprochen hat.
Wir hören hier The Daily.
Er hat eigentlich einen wirklich interessanten Niveau des Wettbewerbs über bestimmte Kämpfe und die Geschichte, die Intrikasien der UFC.
Ich sehe die UFC oder Boxen oder so, sogar Sport generell, es ist ein Mikrokosm der Leben.
Es ist eigentlich so nahe wie kontemplativ, wie ich ihn gehört habe. Er gibt diese Antwort, wenn es um Kämpfe geht, dass es ein Mikrokosm der Leben ist. Es ist so ein binäres Ding, es gibt Winnere und Loser. Und man sieht, wie das auf seine politische Weltwürde geht.
Es ist so interessant, aber das Nächste ist, es ist über eine Zeit von 30 Minuten, 45 Minuten, es ist alles über und man sieht eine Entscheidung, aber es ist ein bisschen wie das Leben, wenn man darüber denkt.
Und Trump gewinnt die Wahl im November und er und sein Team sind gut wissend, wie integriert diese Strategie war und White's Roll in it. Und am Nachmittagabend ist er seine Siegensprache.
Wir haben auch einen Mann, Dana White, der schon mal......
den Mikrofon aufsteht, um ein paar Kommentare zu geben, aber Mr. Dana White.
Dana, Dana, Dana, Dana!
Wir werden ja nachher noch in einem anderen Fall sehen, wie diese Wettbewerbslogik überall implementiert wird und dass dieser Kampf dann ja auch verknüpft wird, eigentlich mit der Idee, am Ende hat man es auch verdient. Also der, der gewonnen hat, der hat es verdient, weil er sich entsprechend angestellt hat, oder weil er dann auserwählt ist. Also das ist ja auch das Interessante, dass wir bei Trump diese Idee haben jetzt, dass er offenbar auch berufen ist für dieses Amt.
Gott hat ihn verschont.
Ja, Gott hat ihn verschont, er hat diesen Anschlag überlebt und nun ist er derjenige, der als Strongman alles richten wird und das ist genau dieser autoritäre Charakter, der von der Frankfurter Schule schon gut beschrieben wurde, dass es also nicht darum geht, um eine wirkliche Selbstermächtigung. Das tut ja dieser Podcast von Haus und Hopf immer so, als sei das jetzt an dir auch was zu tun. Natürlich wollen die jetzt dort ihre Leute ein bisschen motivieren. Wichtig ist aber, dass die Leute natürlich nicht zum Selbstdenken wirklich kommen, dass sie nicht bereit sind, in Konkurrenz zu treten zu Haus und Hopf, sondern sie sollen natürlich diese beiden weiter als ihre Gurus annehmen und sollen dann da drunter irgendwo in der Hierarchie, in diesem Pyramidensystem, das da aufgebaut wird, sollen sie sich dann auch irgendetwas erkämpfen können, aber mehr dann auch nicht.
Ja, wir haben ja von, also es war doch... Rutger Brechmann gelernt, die Intelligenz, die die Menschheit ausmacht, ist eine soziale Kategorie. Ja. Denn der Neandertaler hatte ein 20% größeres Gehirn, war stärker und klüger, aber er hat eben kein Mitgefühl gehabt, weshalb nie gemeinschaftlich eine Kultur aufgebaut wurde. Wir haben von Richard David Brecht diese Erzählung vom Tintenfisch gehört. Wahnsinnig intelligent, aber lebt nur zwei Jahre. In der Zeit kann man natürlich keine Kultur vererben und so richtig kommunizieren konnte er eh nicht. Das was uns Menschen eigentlich von diesem Naturfakt unterscheidet, es ist ja nicht mal recht das Stärkere, es ist ja fit, es geht ja um Anpassung. Und Anpassung wäre auch sehr viel ehrlicher, denn hier geht es ja wirklich um ordne dich ein, finde deinen Platz unten. Du bist im Grunde das, was wir jedem Migranten zugestehen. Du kommst als Doktor, Doktor, Arzt, du beginnst als Taxifahrer. Du kriegst drei Punkte gut geschrieben, den vierten musst du dir erarbeiten. So, das ist ja die Logik, die hier drinsteckt, bleib klein, sei zufrieden mit dem, was du hast, lese ein Seite Buch, weil mehr können wir dir unglaublich nicht zumuten.
Vielleicht bekommst du mal mehr Bizeps, aber mehr wird es auch nicht sein.
Mehr als ein Bizeps wird es nicht sein in deinem Leben.
Und das ist es ja auch, wenn man das AfD-Programm sich zum Beispiel durchliest, es steht ja nirgends etwas drin, wo man sagen kann, das wäre aber mal eine deutliche Verbesserung. Also auch nicht für jetzt die, die dort als die Deutschen wirklich angesehen werden oder so. Und das Versprechen, hier ist ja auch nur ein bisschen spät dran mit dem Krypto-Hype, aber probier's mal, investier mal noch weiter. Und der Witz ist ja, dass diese Leute, die da früh mit Krypto reich geworden sind, wie das bei Haus und Hof der Fall ist, dass die ja davon noch mal enorm profitieren, wenn jetzt noch mal Leute weiter auf diesen Krypto-Zug aufspringen. Das macht ja deren Investments sehr viel wertvoller, während die anderen auch sowieso nur noch kleine Fortschritte da erreichen können, da der Bitcoin jetzt bei 100.000 Euro nun mal schon steht. Und das ist genau diese Pyramidenstruktur, die da ist und die ja auch dann so interessant ist, wenn man sich ansieht, wie denn der Führungsstil dieser Leute ist. Dieses Gespräch zwischen Elon Musk und Alice Weidel beinhaltet ja auch, dass Weidel zu Musk sagt, niemand will ja in seiner Umgebung nur Ja-Sage haben. Und Alice Weidel hat in ihrer Partei nur Ja-Sage um sich herum.
Sie hat doch nicht im Gespräch mit Musk gegenüber nur Ja, ja, ja, absolut, absolut, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja gesagt.
Und Musk hat das gesamte Board seines Unternehmens so aufgestellt, dass da nur noch Knechte sind, die sagen, ja, machen wir genauso.
Genau. Ich will hier nur eine kleine Anmerkung machen zum Thema Familie, denn du hast ja schon häufiger betont, dass auch Markel Thatcher damals gesagt hat, es gibt keine Gesellschaft, nur das Individuum und die Familie. Das heißt, die soziale Intelligenz darf in die Familie, also die Familie darf für dich da sein. Wenn du keine Familie hast, hast du nur noch dein Bizeps. So, das ist also die Logik, die hier diesen jungen Menschen, die Hoss und Hopfeln die ganze Zeit erzählt wird, ohne jeglichen Widerspruch von Dunja Herrihali und Kollegen. Die machen das nie. So, Friedrich Merz, ja, wenn ein Kind stirbt, dann mach ich noch mal eine kurze Sonntagsrede zum Thema, wir lieben doch alle Kinder. Und alle wissen, ja genau, wir erkennen dich gar nicht wieder, Markus. Schon der Tonfall ist für dich völlig neben der Spur. Wir erkennen dich hier nicht wieder.
Vielleicht noch einen Aspekt zum Thema, weil das eben schon mal da aufkam mit Alice Weidel, ja sie kann ja nicht wie Hitler sein. Also das war ja auch das damals, was Elon Musk in seinem Beitrag geschrieben hat. Alice Weidel hat mit den Nazis nichts zu tun, denn sie ist ja lesbisch und so weiter. Das ist ja häufig zu hören auch, dass man sagt, ja das kann ja nicht so ein schlimmer Rechter sein, weil der ja homosexuell ist oder so. Das ist ja etwas, was man häufig erfährt. Und da geht es ja auch wieder um Survival of the fittest, also im Sinne von Anpassung. Das heißt, du kannst auch als lesbische Frau mit Kindern zur Mehrheitsgesellschaft gehören, wenn du bereit bist, dich dieser anzupassen. Also das Interessante ist ja, dass Alice Weidel bei all ihrer Macht, die sie da jetzt hat, zugleich sich unterwerfen muss. Also sie muss schon das Paradigma der heteronormativen Familie als das absolut Erstrebenswerte darstellen. Sie selbst entspricht ihm zwar nicht, deswegen muss sie sich besonders konform auch dann verhalten in der Ideologie, damit sie in dieser Weise da geduldet wird. Denn sonst wäre sie ja irgendwie queer oder so. Und das wäre ja etwas, was man wieder aussondert. Und das kann man ja auch bei vielen, vielen rechten schwulen Politikern erleben, dass die bereit sind, dann besonders hart die Linie auch durchzusetzen, weil sie damit nochmal ihre Anpassungsbereitschaft unter Beweis stellen. Sie sagen dann zwar, dass sie schwul sind und leben das auch öffentlich, aber zugleich sind sie absolute Hardliner, womit sie sagen, also das, was ihr als Mehrheitsgesellschaft für akzeptabel unterstrebenswert haltet, das ist etwas, dem ich mich unterwerf und da werde ich auch niemals euch irgendein Steinchen in den Weg legen.
Also Weidel wird natürlich dankbar an diesem politischen Vorfeld, das wir betrachten, aufgenommen, weil kann so eine Frau Hitler sein? Also die Argumentation ist auch explizit, den Clip hab ich auch da, lieg mal gucken, ob wir den da noch spielen. Jetzt haben wir erstmal so eine Problemlage, die jungen Leute sollen mal gucken, wo sie bleiben und mehr als eine Seite rosse und hopfe am Tag. Nein, lesen ist nicht so. Die Gesellschaft hat nichts für dich im Angebot. Trifft das auf Resonanz? Herr Feldenkirchen macht in seinem Podcast mal eine kleine Studienschau.
Fühlen sich online nicht angesprochen. Junge Menschen empfinden Politik als Gegner. Darüber berichtet das RND. Sie informieren sich vor allem online und stoßen in den sozialen Netzwerken meist auf die, genau, AfD. Junge Menschen erkennen laut dem Generationenforscher Rüdiger Maas Politiker nicht als ihre Verbündeten an. Sie haben sogar das Gefühl, die Politik arbeitet gegen sie oder nimmt sie gar nicht ernst, sagte Maas im ARD-Morgenmagazin. Der Forscher beklagte, das Politikverständnis von manchen jungen Befragten sei unterirdisch. Viele hätten ihr Hauptwissen über die Politik aus sozialen Netzwerken. Dort spreche fast nur die AfD die Sprache der jungen Menschen, wodurch ein Ungleichgewicht entstehe. Andere Parteien müssten dringend Präsenz zeigen, komplexe Themen herunterbrechen, Inhalte beleben.
So und jetzt wundern wir uns, dass 18-jährige Neuwähler Hitler gar nicht so wichtig nehmen und sich denken, ja klar, wir sind AfD, warum denn nicht? Macht doch total Sinn, ich kann das nicht wählen. Wie heißt das nochmal? März? Also ist doch völlig normal. So jetzt haben wir ja diese Problemlage, dass wir unendlich viele Journalisten haben, die unfassbar oft zum selben Thema reden. Ich glaube, wir werden im März auch mal die Bro-Politiklandschaft in Deutschland, Politik-Podcast-Landschaft, also Michael Bröker, Gordon Rapinski, Robin Alexander und so. Das ist ja unerträglich. Vor allem, wenn sie sich gegenseitig im Podcast besuchen, um sich nochmal zu erzählen, dass hier diese kleine Nuance in der Meinung zu März, die du hattest, nein, ich sehe das so. Zum Glück streiten wir uns mal wieder. Während gleichzeitig in Amerika Trump, anders als März, weiß, was er tut, weil er kann sich jetzt zurücklehnen. Es ist jetzt Stephen Miller und so, der die Agenda durchfährt. Also werden da PBS-Hops genommen und die ersten Razzien finden irgendwie statt und in drei Trillionen Dollar werden da blockiert, damit die Länder jetzt mal nicht finanziert werden. Die müssen erst mal Konzession machen und so. Ja, also die ganze Agenda wird jetzt durchgesetzt. Wenigstens in einem kleinen Punkt, Miriam Lau im Zeitpodcast macht mal kurz eine Anmerkung, von der wir sagen, ja, das ist halt so ist jetzt die Ideologie. Sollen sie doch selber gucken, wo sie bleiben?
Die einzige Nachricht, die mich richtig erschrocken hat letzte Woche war, dass Donald Trump als eine von diesen Executive Orders den Schutz für einige Leute, unter anderem John Bolton, aufgehoben hat. Also Leute, die eigentlich so klassische Republikaner waren. Und wenn du den Schutz aufhebst und gleichzeitig Leute begnadigst, die Gewalt gegen das Kapitol und gegen Polizisten und so weiter ausheben, das ist ja so wie so eine Art Vogelfrei. Ich erkläre diese Leute für vogelfrei. Und das hat mich fast noch mehr erschrocken als irgendwelche anderen Dinge. Also ich glaube, wir machen uns alle noch gar kein Bild davon, was da auf uns zukommt.
Der Staat ist nicht für mich da. Warum soll der für John Bolton da sein? Soll doch selber gucken. Bleibt sind doch alles Millionäre, kann sich doch mal jemanden kaufen. Ach so, der hat dann nur Bizeps, aber keinen Zugang zu Sicherheitsinformationen. Ja, das schaffen die schon. Bizeps reicht doch aus so, ne? Also es ist ja nicht nur John Bolton, sondern es ist auch Mike Pompeo und so. Also das ganze alte Kabinett ist vogelfrei erklärt worden. Gleichzeitig ist ja klar, gegen einige von denen läuft ja wirklich so fadwarmäßig vom Iran aus, wir wollen die töten. Und wir haben hier noch diejenigen, die damals schon Mike Pence töten wollten und deswegen im Gefängnis gelandet sind. Zum Teil mehr als zwei Jahrzehnte mit Urteilen, die jetzt wieder auf freiem Fuß sind. Das ist jetzt sozusagen, könnte man nochmal eine Netflix-Serie zumachen, die alles übersteigt.
Das sind unsere Werte-Partner.
Das sind unsere Werte-Partner, das ist das transatlantische Bündnis.
Für die gibt es dann bald auch die Wehrpflicht. Also ich sage das auch nochmal, hier hören ja auch mitunter Junge Grüne und sowas zu, die müssen ja auch danach ja alle noch mal mit Bauchschmerzen sagen, aber wir brauchen die Wehrpflicht in der Koalition mit Friedrich Merz. Wir kämpfen an der Seite der Kapitolstürmer, um Grönland, Kanada oder was auch immer zu erobern und um unsere Werte auch da zu platzieren.
Also das Aufwachen und diese Erweckungsmomente, die Aufklärung unter deutschen Journalisten ist so zäh und so lahm, Auschwitz könnte wiedereröffnet werden, weißt du?
Und wenn die sagen, ist das jetzt ein Hitler-Post? Ich weiß es doch nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, dass das Tor, aber es steht nicht der Spruch drüber, so was.
Ich hab diesen Post mitgebracht von Julia Klöckner. Da postet sie, also vor Aschaffenburg war das noch alles, da postet sie, für das was ihr wollt, müsst ihr nicht AfD wählen. Dafür gibt es eine demokratische Alternative, die CDU.
Das, ja.
Guten Morgen, wir machen AfD-Politik.
Die AfD hatte immer recht und jetzt, wo es hart auf hart kommt, sagen wir, sie hatte immer recht und das muss jetzt auch gemacht werden, keine Kompromisse.
Auf sowas kommt dann höchstens eine Journalistenfrage in den Tagesthemen, trügt der Eindruck oder rückt die CDU jetzt auch stärker nach rechts? Würde ich sagen, nee, die ist da jetzt schon. Die rückt nicht mehr wohin.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns, jetzt hören wir kurz einen Clip, der ist wahnsinnig interessant, ich empfehle das ganze Gespräch, Esra Klein mit diesem James-Poor-Goo oder wie er heißt. Die reden über Maskulinität. Wir sollten uns davon jetzt nicht allzu sehr ablenken lassen, aber es ist schon ein zentrales Thema. Und es ist auch für uns ein zentrales Thema, warum sind es vor allem Männer? Bei uns im Podcast sind 75 Prozent männliche Zuschauer, bei Haus und Hof sind es wahrscheinlich 99 Prozent. Frauen hören das typischerweise nicht, sie können damit nichts anfangen und zwar völlig zurecht, sie sind einfach, muss man jetzt so sagen, soziale Wesen. Anders als UF 30 Männer. Die glauben, sie können es alleine oder wie auch immer. So ja, irgendwann kommt schon das Aufwachen, meistens auch mit gigantischen Lebenskrisen, wünschen wir niemanden, aber wenn es sein muss, okay, ist irgendwie der Lauf der Dinge. Aber die unter 30 jährigen Männer sind spezifisch, sagen wir mal so. Wir lassen uns aber nicht allzu sehr ablenken, denn in diesem Clip wird jetzt auch erinnert an Grabber gegen Thiel und Up Here. Ja, das ist der Clip, den alle deutschen Standardisten jetzt verstehen müssen. Up Here muss jetzt lösungsorientiert gearbeitet werden. Der Clip ist nicht allzu gut verstehen, der ist auch viel zu kurz, um das zu verstehen, aber wir werden den gleich entfalten.
Was wir in den letzten wenigen Monaten gesehen haben, ist ein Konsens gebaut, dass die Wege zurück in den Vergangenen durch den Wettkampf in die Zukunft geht. Und einiges davon ist eigentlich Koalitionspolitik. Einiges davon ist, glaube ich, in meiner Meinung, einige Leute, die mehr Text skeptisch sind, nur irgendwie sagen, okay, lass uns das probieren. Und so kannst du zurück zu, zum Beispiel, ich war mit David Graeber, dem großen Anarchistenphilosoph. Und David hat ein Gespräch mit Peter Thiel über Technologie gemacht. Und die Kritik war, Technologie hat uns nicht wirklich benötigt. Es ist jetzt dieses rentsehende, kapitalistische, irgendwie böse, in Fakt, wie Check auf den Menschenprozess. Und das ist ein bisschen ein berühmter Moment für einige Leute, die diese Sachen folgen, Teal saß mit David zusammen und hat in hohen Strömen begonnen. Wenn du die Möglichkeit von unerwarteten Verlusten minimieren willst, nimm die gleichen Leute und sag ihnen, sie werden keine Ressourcen bekommen, unless sie die Mehrheit ihrer Zeit mit einem anderen beteiligen, um zu zeigen, dass sie bereits wissen, was sie werden kreieren. Das ist das System, das wir haben.
Und es ist sehr effektiv, wenn man die Möglichkeit von Innovation stifelt.
Ich lasse mich an das beenden und sehe, was Peter sagen muss.
Well, es gibt eine bewegende Zahl, die ich mit David hier anstehe.
Er hätte gesagt, dass wir das so verhindern, wie wir das verhindern, durch den Verlust des Kapitalismus. Und Graeber dachte, es sei dadurch, eine mehr kommunale Gesellschaft zu bauen, wo die Menschen mehr Beziehung zwischen sich haben. Aber der Trick hier ist, wenn du zum Beispiel über Masculinität sprichst, gibt es eine wirklich fundamentalistische Frage, ob man sogar Menschen wie Mark Zuckerberg mit kämpfen kann, wo er sagt, Masculinität ist aus amerikanischen Korporatkulturen ausgelöst. Und die Leute fragen sich, ob Männer mit Gewalt gut fühlen müssen. Sind Männer ultra-kompetitiv zu sein? Und die besten Männer bekommen die besten Frauen, und die anderen sind von der Seite geschnitten. Das ist das Bronze-Age-Verwaltende. Müssen Männer eine physische Kultur brauchen, um in ihrem Leben gut zu fühlen und zu progressionieren Also, wir haben hier zwei große Denker, die sich nicht unbedingt groß im Hintergrund gehielten.
Also David Krabber ist natürlich jetzt leider tot, aber Peter Thiel ist ja noch da und es ist jetzt auch nicht ungewöhnlich, dass er mal in Podcasts sitzt und stundenlang erzählt.
Ja, der hat ein Buch geschrieben, Zero to One.
Genau, genau. Ja, das ist super interessant. Dieses One, also eben diese radikale Monopolisierung. Sobald eine Idee gut ist, die Marktwirtschaft komplett überspringen, direkt monopol. Ja, also wir wollen jetzt hier auf Fortschritt. So, was hier thematisiert wurde, ist, beide, David Krabber und Peter Thiel, stimmen überein 2017, dass es irgendwie keinen richtigen Fortschritt gibt in dieser Gesellschaft. 40 Jahre lang. In Amerika gibt es keine High-Speed-Züge, es fährt kein Transrapid-Vakuum im Tunnel, irgendwas. Alles ist wie früher. Nur wir haben jetzt Facebook, Short-Videos, wie auch immer. Also wir haben einen Fortschritt bei den Bits, aber nicht bei den Atoms, bei den Atomen. Und das ist dieser Punkt, wo er sagt, ja genau, wo sind die Breakthroughs, die unerwarteten? Wir verstricken uns hier in so einem, keine Ahnung, können Sie bitte mal im Programm schreiben, was Sie jetzt wollen und dann, ja, dann machen wir das halt oder so. Ja, also es ist so, alle sind so im, ich mach mal ein Drehbuch und dann reicht das ein und dann sagt das Gremium, können wir machen, schaffen wir es mit einem halben Budget und dann hat man schon keine Lust mehr und nichts geht vorwärts. So, und jetzt gibt es zwei Lösungsansätze. Und bei diesen Problemen, ich würde sagen, wir stimmen alle überein. Horst und Hopf sagt, die Bürokratie ist scheiße, die Behörden funktionieren nicht richtig, das Bildungssystem ist Mist und niemand kommt vorwärts. Und ich sage, stimmt, absolut. Bildungssystem ist Mist, niemand kommt vorwärts, die Behörden sind scheiße, der Staat lässt mich im Stich und so weiter. Alle stimmen hier überein.
Aber du würdest es ja nicht in dieser Radikalität formulieren, du würdest ja schon sagen, auch dass das Bildungssystem in Deutschland ja nicht das schlechteste ist. Du würdest auch festhalten wollen, dass die Züge zwar spät kommen, aber es ist ja in anderen Ländern durchaus schlimmer. Also wenn wir in den internationalen Vergleich gehen, sind wir natürlich ja...
Würde ich gerne, würde ich gerne. Aber an dem Tag, an dem Trump ins Amt eingeführt wird, kriege ich eine Nachricht, dass die Schule ausfällt, weil die Heizung nicht geht. Und ich mir Gedanken machen muss, wie ich die nächsten Tage rumkriege, weil hier wieder Homeoffice, Homeschooling angesagt ist. So zwei Tage später erfahre ich, dass man jetzt einen Termin hat mit denjenigen, die das reparieren. In zwei Tagen. Das sind also schon vier Werktage verglichen.
Okay, ich nehme alles zurück.
Das ist alles völlig absurd.
Wir sind am Arsch.
Ich reise nicht so gerne, nicht weil ich ungern in fremden Betten schlafe oder ungern vor Publikum auftrete, sondern weil ich mir nicht sicher sein kann, dass es reicht, 16 Uhr in den Zug zu steigen, sondern ich am besten 10 Uhr morgens schon in den Zug steige. Wenn der Zug nicht kommt, okay, noch mal gut gegangen. Ich musste nur vier Stunden am Bahnhof warten. Es ist doch alles absurd. Es ist wirklich alles absurd. Ich will hier nicht zurückstecken in Sachen Radikalität, denn in Sachen Pädatil, ja, das ist dieser berühmte Spruch, die haben uns fliegende Autos versprochen und alles, was wir bekommen haben, sind 140 Zeichen. Ich kann meine Wut rauslassen ins Internet. Und was hab ich dann jemanden, der mir die Ideologie erklärt mit, ja, dann geh doch ins Gym.
Ich hab ja anfangs gesagt, als wir über Aschaffenburg sprachen, alle sind so wahnsinnig emotional involviert und engagiert, weil das die einzige Möglichkeit ist, noch ein Engagement vorzutäuschen, denn sonst haben die Parteien wenig anzubieten und die Parteien, gerade die Konservativen, sagen, ja sowieso wollen wir den Status Quo erhalten, wir können nur an dieser einzigen Stellschraube noch Engagement zeigen und sind dann besonders hart gegen Leute, die hier hinkommen oder die schon da sind. Und daran kann man eigentlich noch mal so deutlich sehen, wir hatten jetzt jahrelang, und der ist es hier im Podcast ja sehr gut dokumentiert, von der ersten Folge an eine Diskussion über Schuldenregeln, Schuldenbremsen etc. Es ist jetzt in den Wahlprogrammen, außer bei Linke und zum Teil noch bei SPD, nur sonst zu finden, ja wir müssen die Schuldenbremse reformieren, um auch mal in Deutschlandfonds oder was zu machen. Da stehen keine Zahlen. Da stehen nicht die großen Projekte, die jetzt in Gang gesetzt werden sollen. Da ist nicht der Green Deal, den die Grünen uns jetzt anzubieten haben. Der ist in dem Programm nicht aufzufinden. Es ist ein Anschmegen an eine Schuldenbremsenreform, wie sie auch der CDU-Recht wäre. Es wird nicht so sein, dass diese Parteien die Schuldenregeln so verändern, dass Investitionen stattfinden, dass du pünktlich bald mit dem Zug fahren wirst. Und zwar auch nicht in den nächsten fünf Jahren. Also was man daran sehen kann ist, es tut sich da fast nichts. Dieser ganze Reformstau, von dem die Rede ist und all das, das wird noch mal gesagt, das wird auch noch mal benannt in den Programmen. Aber du wirst nichts da finden, dass entsprechende Maßnahmen als Maßnahmen da sind, die als Lösung begriffen werden können. Es gibt in keinem Programm ein großes Infrastrukturprojekt. Es ist dort nicht zu finden. Und das ist ja das interessante. Das heißt, die Politik ist weitgehend blank. Die ist weitgehend blank.
Journalismus auch.
Und das, was angeboten wird, ist, wir können jetzt noch mal darüber diskutieren, ob Hitler ein Kommunist war, wer wirklich deutsch ist und wer ganz deutsch ist. Das ist die Möglichkeit, die wir haben.
Da können wir 10 Uhr morgens Holocaust gedenken und 16 Uhr Stimme bedanken.
Und wir können es schaffen, noch mal einigen Menschen in Deutschland, die nicht so aussehen wie Stefan und Wolfgang, das Leben noch mal richtig, noch härter zu machen als es ohnehin schon ist. Das ist das Angebot, das die...
Dann geht es uns relativ besser.
Dann geht es uns relativ besser. Das ist, wenn der Nachbar sich auch nur einen Golf leisten kann, da bin ich mit meinem kleinen Peugeot ja auch nicht so schlecht dran. Also das ist die Logik, die jetzt vorherrscht. Und ja, von daher hast du recht, muss man eigentlich diesen Zorn haben. Ich will sagen, ja es gibt natürlich progressivere Ansätze, aber die sind in den Parteiprogrammen nicht zu finden, in den Wahlprogrammen nicht zu finden. Ich würde da mal ausklammern, bei der Linken verhält es sich da ein bisschen anders. Aber sonst ist es wirklich erstaunlich, trotz all dieser Diskussionen und der Expertisen, also Adam Toos beispielsweise ist jemand, der die Grünen und die Grünen Spitzen beraten hat, wie wenig am Ende von all dem in den Programmen ist. Auch will ich das ganz deutlich sagen in Bezug auf BSW. Da haben ja auch viele gedacht, na ja, aber das wird schon jetzt in die linke Richtung ökonomisch ein Wahnsinnssatz, der da gemacht wird. Mal von den Migrationsfragen und so abgespalten wäre das doch was. Wenn man sich das BSW-Programm ansieht, ist auch da, dass eine Politik der Mini-Schritte, wo man sagen kann, ja, das trägt sozialdemokratische Züge, aber dass man das als großen Wurf verkaufen. Und selbst wenn das BSW die absolute Mehrheit hätte und dieses Programm eins zu eins durchsetzen würde, wäre die Situation in Deutschland, was Infrastruktur, was die soziale Frage anbelangt, nur minimal besser. Das heißt also selbst bei den Programmen, die man hier einfach mal so ins Blaue hineinschreiben kann, was ja auch SPD, Grüne und so weiter machen könnten, haben sie kein großes Konzept anzubieten.
Die 100 Milliarden, die die CDU dann noch nicht finanziert hat, die Wahlgeschenke, sind einfach nur die Hoss und Hopf Idee von hier Taschengeld gegen Gym.
Ja.
Wir haben kein Angebot, wir geben dir das Geld lieber wieder. Ja, das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Aber nur wenn du zu den oberen zehn Prozent gehörst.
Genau. Und dann ist deren Angebot, ich weiß, wir müssten hier eigentlich Politik machen, aber hier bitte nimm dein Geld wieder. Machs selber. Also das geht einfach nicht.
Und ich würde sogar sagen, für viele der oberen zehn Prozent rechnet sich das nicht. Also für die Superreichen, da hat Friedrich Merz natürlich dann tolle Lösungen parat. Aber ich sag mal jemand, der 6.000, 7.000, 8.000 netto im Monat verdient, der könnte vielleicht auch mehr davon profitieren, wenn die Schule, in die seine Kinder gehen, gut funktioniert, als wenn er 3.000 Euro weniger im Jahr Steuern zahlen muss. Denn davon kann man noch nicht eine Privatschule finanzieren. Genau.
Ja eben. Also es gibt sehr viele Synergieeffekte, die hier einfach in die Luft geschlagen werden. Und das ist auch, finde ich, hier muss man jetzt rein, die unterschiedlichen Lösungsansätze für dasselbe Problem bei Peter Thiel und David Graeber. Also Thiel, just do it. Wer Macht hat Recht. Wenn jemand was macht, geh ihm aus dem Weg. Lass ihn machen. Wenn er ein Monopol hat, ja, da sich er durchgesetzt. Ist doch nur ein Erfolgsausweis. Bürokratie, Staat, alles weg, weg, weg, weg, weg. Lass den machen. Frag nach Vergiftnis, aber nicht um Erlaubnisfragen. Einfach machen, machen, machen. David Graeber. Nein, wir brauchen hier grundlegende strukturelle Veränderungen. Die Financialisierung und die Bürokratisierung. Also ein Wirtschaftsgebaren, das sozusagen ach du hast eine gute Idee, nee, brauchst Geld. Also um Geld zu kriegen, musst du dich uns unterwerfen und so. Ja, das hindert die Kreativität. Ach du musst erst sieben Anträge stellen, um was zu machen. Nee, Bürokratie, bitte klüger machen. Fördernd, Kreativität fördernd. Wir brauchen hier große Gemeinsamkeiten. Und dann eben dieser grundsätzliche, wir machen es gemeinsam, wir nutzen die Synergieeffekte, wir gestalten Programme und dann Trial and Error, probieren wir sie aus. Aber eben nicht, indem wir uns die ganze Zeit abhaten und gehämisch, siehst du, hast du wieder eine schlechte Idee gehabt und so, sondern nein, einfach klug gemeinsam nach vorne gehen. Das sind diese unterschiedlichen Ansätze. David Graeber will also die kollektive Intelligenz mobilisieren. Wir sind die Träger dieser Intelligenz, aber eben nur, wenn man es kommunikativ so gestalten, dass es zu diesen entsprechenden sozialen Effekten führt. Oder Hoss und Hopf, Peter Thiel, jeder macht es selbst. Die Natur hat es so vorgegeben, der Stärkste setzt sich durch. Keine Rücksicht, keine Erlaubnisfragen. Vielleicht nochmal sich entschuldigen ja, wenn irgendwer so hopsgegangen ist dabei. So das sind die unterschiedlichen Ansätze. Könnte man natürlich jetzt in Tiefe und Breite diskutieren. Ich hab eine Diskussion gefunden, in der das diskutiert wurde, nämlich Umgang mit dem Staat. Wir hören erstmal Merz, bevor wir da ins Gespräch mit Rainer Hank, das ist der, der bei mir mit Lanz im Gespräch saß. Patrick Bernau, ich weiß, das geht jetzt ein bisschen drüber mit meinem Urteil, aber wirklich ein vulgär-libertärer FAZ-Redakteur der sozusagen und so. Und Stefan Kohle, wissenschaftlicher Leiter des Ludwig Erdforums. Erstmal hören wir aber, wie sich Friedrich Merz aus lauter Blödheit und Verlegenheit hier schon mal auf eine Seite schlägt.
Er von Altenbock und das andere große Thema.
So, das ist jetzt ein Gespräch in der FAZ. Simon Strauß redet mit Jasper von Altenbock um darüber, was Friedrich Merz gesagt hat. Den O-Ton hören sie gleich. Wundert euch nicht, dieser O-Ton, weil Merz einfach grund-, also wirklich unglaublich bescheuert ist, hat einen entscheidenden Wortfehler. Den muss dann Simon Strauß erst mal reparieren, bevor dann Jasper von Altenbock, also man glaubt es nicht, wie blöd das alles ist.
Ich meine, diese Woche war Trump. Darüber haben Sie mit Friedrich Merz auch gesprochen und hat durchaus ebenfalls Überraschendes im Sinne von überraschend Positives über Trump gesagt.
Und mir hat gestern eins gut, vorgestern eins gut gefallen von Trump, nicht alles, aber das hat mir gut gefallen, zu sagen, wir treffen jetzt hier in Zukunft in Amerika keine einzige Entscheidung mehr, die unter der Überschrift steht. Dient sie der Wettbewerbsfähigkeit unserer Industrie? Ja oder nein? Und ich glaube, das ist ein Beispiel für Deutschland. Und Trump wird uns jetzt zwingen, dass wir uns auf die wesentlichen Themen konzentrieren, die wir in Europa nur zusammen machen können.
Da hat er glaube ich ein Nicht-Vergessen-Nicht. Also in Amerika wird keine einzige Entscheidung mehr getroffen, die nicht unter der Überschrift steht. Dient sie der Wettbewerbsfähigkeit unserer Industrie?
Man kann ja mal ein Wort vergessen. Also wirklich, ich verstehe das alles nicht.
Dann nein. Wird denn ein Bundeskanzler Merz anders auf einen amerikanischen Präsidenten Trump reagieren als ein Bundeskanzler Scholz? Was meinen Sie?
Ach in der Praxis würde ich sagen, wir werden die Unterschiede gar nicht so groß sein. Also aber vielleicht verbal in der moralischen Bewertung, da hält sich Merz wesentlich, da hält sich Merz zurück.
So in der moralischen Bewertung, ja okay, kann irgendwas sein, dass man darüber so und so reden kann, aber eigentlich ist es unverwechselbar. Merz und Trump ist dasselbe und Merz sagt ja auch, also mir hat nicht alles gefallen von Trump, als er gesagt hat, Primatwirtschaft, Primatding, Primat der Stärkere.
Er hat ja bei einer Wahlkampfveranstaltung eine Rede gehalten, ich hab es mir rausgeschrieben, da sagte er, wenn die Bundesjugendspiele nur noch Teilnehmerurkunden ausstellen, was sie nicht tun, dann kriegen wir bald auch Olympiaden, das müsste ja Olympische Spiele heißen, dann kriegen wir bald auch Olympiaden nur noch Teilnehmerurkunden. Ja, ich kenne jetzt keine Olympiade mit Teilnehmerurkunde. Interessant ist ja hier...
Dabei sagt alles, es ist das Motto.
Ja, eben. Es ist ja interessant, dass er hier von den Olympischen Spielen spricht und den Erfolgen, die er in der Zukunft für Deutschland sehen will. Wenn man sich mit irgendwelchen Olympioniken unterhält, dann werden die alle sagen, es hapert an der staatlichen Finanzierung. Die werden keine Antwort geben. Sie werden nicht sagen, es ist wegen der Teilnehmerurkunden oder so etwas, sondern es ist, dass der Sport und zwar nicht nur jetzt die Förderung der Exzellenzen, sondern dass die Sportförderung, dass die immer mehr nachlässt und dass die Kinder oft keine Möglichkeit haben, überhaupt ein sportliches Talent auszubilden. Das ist die Antwort dieser Sportler und er sagt einfach nur Wettbewerb, Wettbewerb ist gut. Wenn der Wettbewerb da ist bei den Bundesjugendspielen, dann wird er auch schon zu olympischen Fähigkeiten führen. Das ist einfach so ein Unsinn.
Ich will dazu immer sagen, hier merken wir so an Gefühlslagen, also die ich einfach in mir spüre. Wir haben hier drüben eine Schule, in der, wenn man in den Eingangsbereich reingeht, unseren Olympioniken viel Erfolg gewünscht wird. Weil das einfach, die sind zur letzten Olympischen Spiele gefahren. Was bedeutet, wer diese Art von Sport auf diesem Niveau nicht nur im Fernsehen sieht, sondern auch persönlich Leute kennt, die das da mitgemacht haben, da ist einfach völlig klar, eine Goldmedaille ist sozusagen die Landung auf dem Mars. Die Teilnahme bei solchen Spielen bringt ganze Stadtteile in Wallung. Ja. So, und es reicht auch völlig. Mehr ist nicht zu erreichen. Und wenn man dann als Politiker, der es eigentlich in der Hand hat, das da den finanziellen Grund lang zu sorgen, sagt, ne, also wenn du nur teilnimmst bei olympischen Spielen, dann haben deine Eltern, deine Freunde und du selbst noch nicht genug Beitrag geleistet. Du musst gewinnen. Das ist einfach absurd. Also das zeigt echte Menschenverachtung eigentlich. Das ist ein völlig falsches Menschenbild.
Und immer vorgetragen von Leuten, bei denen man sich tatsächlich fragt, wo ist die Leistung? Also wo ist die Leistung?
Wenn du doch mal 100 Meter, wann hast du wirklich?
Wo ist die Leistung bei Hoss und Hopf, dass sie gut schnell in Krypto investiert haben? Ist das eine unternehmerische Leistung?
Absolut.
Also wir können uns ja wirklich mal bei Hidden Champions unternehmerische Leistungen ansehen, in denen Leute jahrzehntelang ein Unternehmen groß aufbauen. Da sind unternehmerische Leistungen ja durchaus da und die kann man auch wertschätzen. Da finden wir sie nicht. Finden wir die bei der CDU? Was wäre Jens Spahn, wenn er nicht jeden Tag irgendwas Neues in den Medien fordern könnte? Naja, maximal hätte er wohl irgendwo in einem Dorf und Posten bei einer Sparkasse bekommen, wenn er Glück hat. Würde es den Kollegen nicht auffallen, dass er nicht der Beste ist. Das wäre die eigentliche Situation, in der diese Leute sich befinden.
Und das ist das eine. Das Friedrich Merz hier irgendwie sagt, der Kampf, die Wirtschaft, das Primat, das Ökonomischen ist hier ganz wichtig. Nicht nur das, sondern es gibt nur einen zweiten O-Ton. Wir hatten jetzt, also wie er die Politik selbst auch aus dem Spiel nimmt, wir hatten jetzt 75 Jahre Grundgesetzfeiern. Was bedeutet, es gibt dazu natürlich große Ausstellungen. In Bonn oder ich glaube es war in Bonn im deutschen Haus, so wie es heißt, gab es eine Ausstellung zum Thema, also Grundgesetz war das Thema, der Kompromiss. Weil das Grundgesetz organisiert Kompromisse. Das organisiert nicht das Recht des Stärkeren, sondern es ist klug. Die Leute haben sich was dabei gedacht und sie haben in die Hölle geschaut, als sie es geschrieben haben. Der Kompromiss. So, jetzt hören wir hier, richtig Schmerz dieser Tage.
Mir ist es völlig gleichgültig, wer diesen Weg politisch mitgeht. Ich sage nur, ich gehe keinen anderen. Und wer ihn mit mir gehen will, muss sich nach diesen fünf Punkten richten. Kompromisse sind zu diesen Themen nicht mehr möglich.
Also wenn ein Politiker so redet, dann bitte Bundestag abbauen, Boxring aufbauen, sich durchsetzen, dann tritt Robert Habeck mit in den Ring und dann schafft man es, die Nieder zu schlagen oder halt nicht. So, dann klären wir das so. Na ja, hören wir mal in dieses Gespräch über Millay, denn es gibt ja natürlich nicht nur Horst von Hopf als Dunstkreis dieser Idiotie, sondern es gibt ja auch andere Leute, die seriöser aussehen. Genau, die ein bisschen seriöser aussehen und uns versuchen hier jetzt in dieser großen Gemengelage, die wir bis hierhin aufgearbeitet haben, Orientierung zu geben. Und zwar in dieser, Stefan hat gesagt, es sind jetzt Lösungen gefordert. Was könnten denn Lösungen sein? Also Rainer Hank. Und ich will noch was sagen, also ist der Typ, der bei Lanz neben mir saß, der hier, die Vermieter, die mieten und so. So Rainer Hank, was gibt es zu sagen? Was ist hier los?
Und ich darf mal die ehemalige Justiz...
Oh, wir sind noch gar nicht in diesem SWF2 Forum, das hören wir gleich. Rainer Hank war bei Corinna Butras im FAZ Podcast und hat dort, geht auch nicht, es ist Liberale vorgestellt. Also wir haben ja Lösungsvorschläge von Millay und so, anarchokapitalistisches, wozu den Staat, also so einen ultralibertären Ansatz, den verteidige ich dir hier.
Die ehemalige Justizministerin Sabine Leuthaar-Schnarrenberger an diesem Punkt zitieren, immerhin ja auch eine große Liberale, die sagt, Deutschland braucht eine starke liberale Kraft, die einen klaren Gegenpult zu staatlichem Lirigismus bildet und die Rechte und Freiheiten der Bürger nicht nur wirtschaftlich, sondern auch in allen Lebensbereichen verteidigt. Dazu gehört, gegen soziale Ungleichheit vorzugehen, Aufstiegschancen durch Bildung zu führen, den Klimawandel zu bekämpfen und die Verteidigungsfähigkeit des Landes zu sichern. Eine libertäre Zerstörung des Staates, wie Millezi plant, ist damit unvereinbar.
Also da fragen wir erstens, woher weiß sie, dass er eine Zerstörung des Staates plant.
Vielleicht hat sie einfach hingeguckt, Nachrichten.
Hat den mit der Kettensäge gesehen.
Den sie dabei sagt, ist mit Verlaub ein bisschen trivial. Kann jeder unterschreiben, aber kostet einen dann auch nichts, das zu unterschreiben. Also das ist, denke ich, doch dem Zeitgeist geschuldet, dieses Zitat, weil sie weiß, dass es nicht gut ist. Das wird sie die FDP sicher nicht über die 5 Prozent bringen, wenn sie jetzt sagen, wir machen hier Kettensägenpolitik. Verstehe ich schon.
So, und jetzt fügt er noch etwas an, was so in die Märzrichtung geht.
Die Liberalen sind für Institutionen, aber sie sind zugleich staatsskeptisch. Und das geht schon zusammen und man kann es sogar härter sagen, sie sind auch demokratieskeptisch, was ich finde in Zeiten des Populismus kein schlechter Ansatz ist. Weil Demokratie heißt zunächst nur, Mehrheiten bestimmen, wer die Macht hat. Und dagegen würden Liberale immer sagen, wir müssen Institutionen, unabhängige, staatsferne Institutionen schaffen, die dafür sorgen, dass die Mehrheit nicht über die Stränge schlägt, die Minderheiten unterdrückt und populistisch versinkt.
So, jetzt haben wir ja thematisiert, die Schuldenbremse ist vor allem deswegen ein Problem, weil da irgendwer auf die Idee kam zu sagen, nee, das können wir auf gar keinen Fall der Demokratie und den Demokraten und den demokratischen Parteien und den Mehrheitsfindungen im Parlament überlassen. Das muss politikfern in einer eigenen Institution, an der man nicht rütteln kann, institutionalisiert werden.
Genau so wie die EZB.
Genau, so wie die EZB, genau. Also da ist sozusagen der demokratischen Handhabe entzogen. Jetzt haben wir hier thematisiert, monatelang, dass die Schuldenbremse den Staat auf so privates Haushaltsniveau runterzieht, wo es einfach heißt, also wenn du morgens um acht nicht zur Arbeit gehst, hast du 16 Uhr nichts zu essen. So, nein, könnte man ja auch mal umgedreht denken oder anders. Nein, geht nicht, weil Schuldenbremse. Und jetzt sagt Rainer Hank, ja und jetzt sehen wir ja auch diesen Populismus. Wir brauchen noch mehr solche Lösungen wie die Schuldenbremse. Wir müssen noch mehr Fernen der Demokratie installieren. Und diejenigen, die dann sagen, aber dann funktioniert die Demokratie nicht mehr, ja, das ist völlig zu Recht, dass die das sagen. Diese Demokratieskepsis ist schon, das ist gut begründet. Man sieht ja, dass nichts mehr funktioniert. Da denkt man sich so, hm, okay, also, ja.
Diese Ideologie hat ja Grigory Chamayu in seinem Buch Die unregierbare Gesellschaft sehr gut aufgezeigt, wie eigentlich diese Neoliberalen alle sagen, eigentlich ist das Wahlvolk das Problem. Ja, wir müssen natürlich so tun, als würden wir eine Liberalität in dem Sinne verkaufen, dass wir demokratisch sind. Aber eigentlich sehen wir das Wahlvolk als Problem an. Das könnte ja dies und das auch noch wollen. Und deswegen müssen wir sehen, dass wir sehr viel absichern vor dem Demos. Und das ist etwas, was natürlich so Institutionen dann hervorgebracht hat wie die EZB. Insofern ist es auch interessant, dass die Linkspartei die einzige jetzt gerade ist, die fordert, dass die EZB demokratisch gewählt wird, also das Gremium und dass die EZB auch an das EU-Parlament und durch eine gewisse Ausgabenpolitik und Entscheidungspolitik gebunden sein soll. Das heißt, es geht also hier um eine Politisierung der EZB. Also genau das, was natürlich für Rainer Hanke und die anderen zum größten Problem wäre. Und damit greifen sie wirklich diesen MMT-Gedanken von Stephanie Kelten am radikalsten auf, weil die das ja auch genau sagen. Sie sagen, dieses Geld des Staates ist ja das Geld der Wähler, die darüber bestimmen können. Und es ist eben nicht das, was man vor den Wählern schützen soll. Was hier eigentlich Rainer Hanke sich vorstellt, ist ja eine technokratisch-oligarchisch-organisierte Gesellschaft. Und da passt es natürlich sehr gut, dass man so eine Strongman-Politik hat. Denn die starken, die sich durchgesetzt haben, die werden ja schon wissen, wofür es gut ist. Und die anderen haben sich dann in ihrem Platz einzuordnen.
Ja, stell mal vor, die EZB hätte nicht nur ein Mandat, zwei Prozent Inflation, sondern auch Arbeitsmarktzahlen oder so.
Steht tatsächlich im Parteiprogramm der Linken drin, das eigentlich es doch um Vollbeschäftigung gehen müsste.
Womit die Linke dann sagt, wir möchten uns gern orientieren an einem Beispiel, dem Hardcore-kapitalistisch-Amerikanischen. Wer kann denn was dagegen haben? Man fragt sich so, ja genau, wer kann denn da jetzt was dagegen haben? Wenn schon, dann doch, warum nicht? So jetzt zu diesem SWR Kultur Forum, wie es jetzt heißt. Stefan Koleff ist wissenschaftlicher Leiter des Ludwig Erhard Forums. Man redet über Melee.
Und ich widerspreche, dass wir sozusagen von Musko und Melee nichts lernen könnten. Ich halte die Kettensäge-Metapher für problematisch, aber gleichzeitig auch für ein Stück weit wegweisend, wenn wir uns vergegenwärtigen.
Problematisch, aber wegweisend.
Dass man vielleicht keine Kettensäge braucht, weil das tatsächlich ein Instrument der Revolution ist.
Das ist eigentlich witzig, die Kettensäge und die Gießkanne, das sind ja alles so, wir gehen jetzt mal raus arbeiten, wir erledigen jetzt mal Sachen, am Ende des Tages wissen wir, was wir getan haben. Die Blumen gegossen, den Baum geschnitten.
Aber eine Gartenschere oder eine...
Jetzt kommt die Gartenschere.
Das ist im Prinzip diese Idee von der Frau, von Robinson Crusoe.
Zum Haushalt wird ein Garten.
Der diesen Garten pflegt und da seinen Haushalt macht.
Heckenschere jedenfalls...
Na gut, wenn du alleine auf der Welt bist, ist natürlich der Start, bist du, weißt du? Dann gilt ja die Logik auch.
Das wär ja der Wunsch.
Dann musst du mit dein Bizeps klarkommen.
Das wär der Wunsch der meisten dort.
Oder eine Heckenschere, jedenfalls ein reformerisches Instrument.
Denn wenn wir sagen, Die Heckenschere als reformerisches Element, das ist also das wirklich alles.
Wirtschaft und Gesellschaft ist ein Garten, dann sind wir uns glaube ich momentan alle einig, dass es dem deutschen Garten nicht gut geht. Und eine schwungvoll, stetig und kontinuierlich geschwungene Garten oder Heckenschere ist glaube ich durchaus etwas, was wir gebrauchen können. Disruption, komisches Wort, ist vielleicht nichts anderes als das, was Bundespräsident Roman Herzog mit seiner Ruckrede meinte. Und wenn man sich diese Ruckrede ranhört, dann hört man heraus, dass da ein ähnlicher Wunsch danach ist, dass sehr viel Gartenschere notwendig ist, damit Deutschland wieder nach vorne kommt.
Die Ruckrede, ganz interessant. Roman Herzog bezog sich ja in dieser Rede auch auf Bill Gates, der damals als der große diskursive Akteur aufgetreten ist. In den 90er Jahren war Roman Herzog. Ja und dann hat er sich auf Gates bezogen, also dass jemand da in der Garage und du kennst diese ganzen Silicon Valley Geschichte. Also das ist eigentlich der Bezug da, dass da plötzlich so viel passiert. Und es stimmt, dass das eine disruptive Rede ist. Also diese Ruckrede sagt ja eigentlich, wir brauchen mehr Privatisierung, mehr Neoliberalisierung, weniger Staat. Wir brauchen jetzt diese schlanken, flexiblen Strukturen, was heißt Arbeitsrechte schleifen und und und. Tatsächlich hat Roman Herzog hier nicht einfach so eine Aufrüttelrede gehalten, so so eine mentale Sache der Gemütszustand Deutschland passt mir nicht, wir brauchen anderen, sondern es war schon damit ausgesagt, wir brauchen jetzt neoliberale Reformen. Und da hat er völlig recht, dass das so ist. Das wurde aber von den meisten nie so erkannt, sondern man hat einfach nur gedacht, das ist aber gut, dass da mal eine markeige Worte an den Tag legt.
Okay. Patrick Bernau findet das natürlich alles grandios.
Also man kann das schaffen. Man kann das schaffen. Man kann das auch schaffen ohne so zu werden wie Maske und Millet. Aber man muss wirklich jetzt und ich nehme das Bild von Stefan Koleff da auf, man muss da jetzt wirklich mit der Heckenschere rangehen.
Ja und ich bin sehr dafür, wir setzen die Heckenschere an bei den Multimillionären und Milliardären, bei den Vermietern. Also da müssen wir überall mit der Heckenschere ran.
Ganz genau. Ich finde auch der Staat ist so aufgeblätt. 60 Milliarden für Dienstwagen und so ein Scheiß, das ist doch alles bescheuert. Das sollen die doch, also der Stärkste bitte. Bitte aus eigener Kraft, nicht einfach glauben, mit Geld könne man sich jetzt Muskeln kaufen wie einen großen Motor oder so. Also die Ideologie, man muss halt mit ihr dann mal ins Gericht gehen und dann wird es glaube ich auch amüsant und spielerisch, aber nicht, wenn man so in der Early zuschaut, wie sie ohne es zu merken, ohne es zu wollen und deswegen besonders wirkmächtig aus einer Hauptideologie macht und dann sitzen alle vorm Fernseher und sagen, ja seht ihr, sagt es doch auch. Gut, Österreich. Was ist in Österreich passiert? In Österreich ist Deutschlands Zukunft. Diese Pointe ist nicht ganz falsch. In Österreich passiert es einfach immer alles nur ein bisschen früher und deswegen gucken wir jetzt in die Zukunft und wir hören uns aber, wir wissen ja was passiert ist, nur die Urteile so ein bisschen an.
Vielleicht machen wir kurz einen Hinweis auf den Salon an dieser Stelle und was wir lesen wollen. Dann möchte ich mir auch noch erlauben zu sagen, weil du schon Österreich jetzt erwähnst, dass ich bald auch in Wien sein werde.
Oh, ich auch, im April.
Und zwar am 1.3. bin ich in Wien mit Ole und Jean-Philippe zusammen.
Die internationale Tour.
Auf meiner Homepage kann man dann schauen, wo es Karten gibt.
Sehr gut, sehr gut, ja mach die Welttour.
Und wir sind am 11.2. auch in München und am 25.2. bin ich in Berlin und halte dann bei der Böckler-Stiftung einen Vortrag. Alles weitere findet man da auf der Homepage. Wir werden ja jetzt weiter über die Demokratie reden. Müssen wir sie schützen? Wenn ja, vor wem? Und da passt es natürlich gut, dass Mark Schieritz, der Zeitredakteur ist, ein Buch geschrieben hat mit dem Titel Zu dumm für die Demokratie? Fragezeichen. Wir wollen sehen, ob es ein Ausrufezeichen wird, wenn man das ganze Buch gelesen hat. Naja, wir müssen schauen.
Kommt ja erst am dritten, wir kennen es.
Wir versuchen, diese Debatte natürlich wieder aufzugreifen, die wir jetzt schon hatten mit Veit Selig, Blüthorn, Manow. Haben wir eine Demokratiedämmerung? Woran hapert es eigentlich? Das ist also das Buch eigentlich der Stunde, denn wir können uns diese Frage zu dumm für die Demokratie von sehr vielen Richtungen ausstellen und werden sehr häufig den Eindruck haben, ja offenbar sind da viele zu dumm für die Demokratie. Das ist jedenfalls das Buch, das wir im Salon lesen werden. Für die Leute, die jetzt zum ersten Mal zuhören oder noch nicht so richtig zugehört haben bei den Folgen davor. Der Salon ist der Zusatzinhalt der neuen Zwanziger. Das heißt, was ich mal bekomme, wenn ich eine E-Mail und werde gefragt, ja aber warum gibt es nur den Salon Teaser? Da fehlt da noch irgendwas und dann sag ich, ja das genau ist hinter der Paywall. Also es gibt meistens einen Salon oder es gibt immer einen Salon Teaser. Da reden wir aber meistens noch mal über ein eigenes kleines Thema. Und dann sprechen wir im Salon über ein Buch gemeinsam, das wir gelesen haben. Das wird dann in diesem Falle Mark Schiritz sein. Das war das letzte Mal das neue Buch von Eva Illus. Und außerdem, nachdem wir dann so meistens zwei Stunden darüber diskutiert haben, über das Buch, sprechen wir dann noch jeweils über unsere Empfehlungen. Jeder bringt fünf Empfehlungen des Monats mit. Das können Artikel sein. Ich bringe meistens auch noch einen Roman mit. Das, was wir als wichtig empfinden. Und da sich ja jetzt viele vorgenommen haben, mehr zu lesen. Also das ist ja immer auf diesen Listen, was kann man im neuen Jahr so machen. Dann ist natürlich Sport an erster Stelle, zweitens vielleicht Ernährung. Und dann kommt aber meistens schon an dritter, vierter Stelle Lesen. Also wer sich jetzt vielleicht auch vorgenommen hat, mehr zu lesen, soll jetzt nicht nur den Salon vielleicht nur hören und sagen, naja, dann brauch ich das alles nicht zu lesen, sondern es kann natürlich auch der Anlass sein zu sagen, gut, dann lese ich das Buch auch oder eines der Bücher, die empfohlen werden. Das ist also auch eine Möglichkeit oder auch mal darüber hinaus dann was lesen, was wir so empfehlen. Der Salon ist wie folgt zu erreichen?
Man geht auf neuezwanziger.de und folgt dem goldenen Button, da steht Salon und er führt zu Steady. Das ist also dann die Paywall-Seite, da wird man aufgefordert, drei Euro im Monat zu bezahlen und dann kann man das ganze Archiv hören, weil es einfacher haben will bei Apple Podcasts ist mit einem Klick der Salon verfügbar oder bei Patreon, falls jemand schon einen Account dort hat, kann er dort konsumieren. Apropos lesen, oder möchtest du noch was sagen?
Nein.
Okay, Apropos lesen, also ich blogge jetzt wieder, geht auf meine Webseite, lese meine Texte. Ich gebe mir sehr viel Mühe mit der Wortwahl, weil das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Selbst typografische Uneinheitlichkeiten kann ich noch mit GPT und Claude und wie sie alle heißen so weit klären, dass die Texte, was Grammatik und Textgestaltung, Typografie einfach perfekt sind. Und ich meine wirklich perfekt. Also da ist jedes kleine Apostroph, wie macht man das mit diesem Genitiv, wenn der März mit einem Zischlaut endet und was auch immer. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Das sind einfach so Rundowns in der Post-Production, die man heute so machen kann. Also falls ihr kleine Konjunktiv-Fehler noch findet, das sind bewusste Sätze. Alles was zu lesen ist, ist bewusst gewollt. Okay. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Also falls ihr Zeitungsredakteure seid und so, schaut euch das mal an, wie diese Technik da funktioniert. Also ich meine jetzt hier GPT und Clot und so, wie weit die einen da helfen kann. Wirklich erstaunlich. Außerdem, du hast mich ja drauf gebracht, eine Signieraktion für die Kinderwüste zu machen. So langsam wächst der Bestand und ich hab natürlich angekreuzt, dass ich persönliche Grußworte schreibe, was zu Arbeit führen wird.
Ich denke, dass Stefan mal richtig ans Arbeiten kommt. Deswegen ist es wichtig, das Buch vorzubestellen.
Ich verlinke euch das.
Und zwar auf eine Widmung zu bestehen. Und zwar findet man da dann einen Link in der Folge und dann geht man zur Autorenwelt, kann da das Buch von Stefan bestellen.
Dann gibt es da die persönliche Widmung. Also Fußworte, persönliche Namen.
Wir wollen ihn schon hart ans Arbeiten bekommen. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie viele Bücher du am Ende dort nicht nur unterzeichnen, sondern auch widmen musst. Insofern, ja, das ist dann neben der Salon-Lektüre auch noch vielleicht eine spannende Lektüre.
So, gucken wir uns noch schnell Österreich an zu diesem Themenkomplex. Vier Clips, alle von Florian Gasser, den ich wirklich grandios finde. Er macht vor allem den Transalpien-Podcast der Zeit mit seinem deutschen und schweizer Counterpart, was die Federführung für die politischen Teile angeht, der Zeitung. Und wir hören ihn hier in seinem eigenen Podcast, Servus heißt er, oder eben im Politikteil, wo er noch mal zu Gast ist und er thematisiert mal ein Problem, dass wir in Deutschland als allererstes angehen müssen. Es ist eine Anklage an die Politiker, aber es ist auch eine Anklage an uns selber.
Also meine Behauptung wäre, vielleicht kommen wir noch mal dazu, dass es vor allem in der EVP, in den wirtschaftsnahen Kreisen, die sehr mächtig dort sind, die Überlegungen gibt, es ist uns eigentlich egal mit wem wir regieren, hauptsache unsere Interessen werden umgesetzt und diese Interessen sind zum Beispiel eben geringere Steuern und so weiter. Und mit wem wir die umsetzen ist uns eigentlich wurscht. Das wäre meine Antwort darauf. Und zurück zu den Wahlkämpfen mit diesen Richtungsentscheidungen und diesem Ausnahmezustand, dem man ausgerufen wird. Was halt dann ist, wenn die Wahlen vorbei sind, dann fängt man an Koalitionsgespräche zu führen in einer Art und Weise, als sei nichts passiert vorher, als sei es eben keine Zäsur, die da gerade passiert ist. Es seien einfach normale Gespräche. Und am Ende zerkracht man sich wegen Dingen wie der Körperschaftssteuer. Schau mal schnell, was das ist. Körperschaftssteuer. Oder die Bankenabgabe war zum Beispiel auch so ein Ding, die gibt es in Österreich, ich nenne sie Stabilitätsabgabe, seit 2011, Banken müsste ab einer gewissen Summe, ab einer Bemessungsgrundlage von 1 Milliarde Euro an 0,0 irgendwas abgeben. Du hast mir gestern den Betrag zu 150 Millionen geworfen gehen und ich musste gut lachen. Also ich meine, das ist ja spiegel. Und an sowas zerstreitet man sich. Wegen sowas lässt man was auseinander fliegen und ebnet Herbert Kickl einen Weg ins Kanzleramt. Das ist eine Form der Unernsthaftigkeit und Unaufrichtigkeit im Umgang mit autoritären Kräften, dass man wirklich schlecht werden kann.
Den Transfer kann man hier schon leisten. Wir sehen jetzt schon in einem Video Friedrich Merz, da stehen ja sagt, der Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland ist bedroht. Alle, die morgens auf die Arbeit gehen oder auch noch wollen, dass ihre Kinder einen Job haben, müssen verstehen, dass wir nur mit einer Senkung der Unternehmensteuer, wir haben da ein fünf Programmplan, was wir davor stellen. Nur diese Vision ist die einzige, die wir verfolgen.
Kompromisslos.
Egal, wer mit stimmt.
Ja, so wird es sein. Man wird sagen, wir sind diejenigen, die unseren Wirtschaftsstandort schützen und wer für unseren Wirtschaftsstandort ist, der stimmt für diese neue Resolution. Also ganz egal, wer es sein wird, auch die AfD wird gern genommen. So wird es kommen. Ich sage es dir, denn die Koalition, die wir erst einmal bekommen, wird nicht eine schwarz-blaue sein. Davon gehen wir jetzt mal nicht aus. Aber man wird dann solche Kämpfe dort erleben und am Ende wird es um ein paar Millionen oder vielleicht auch ein paar Milliarden Euro gehen. Man wird sagen, jetzt ist aber hier Schluss. Irgendwo müssen wir auch noch vernünftig bleiben. So ist ja immer eine Rede von Friedrich Merz. Er ist ja der Meister der Vernunft. Das heißt meistens der einfältigen Gedanken. Und deswegen ist uns jedes Mittelrecht.
Also wir haben es jetzt ein bisschen im Blick. Heute ist noch nichts passiert im Bundestag, aber es ist ja auch noch Mittag. Aber es ist ja das nächste Gesetz in der Wache, das schon auf diese Art und Weise noch zur Migration. Als nächstes dann, naja gut, bei Migration, okay, das war ein Fehler, das tut mir auch leid. Aber jetzt bei Wirtschaft, also da kann mir jetzt wirklich egal sein, wer da mit stimmt. Das sind jetzt die vernünftigen Sachen.
Also das AfD-Wirtschaftsprogramm und das CDU-Wirtschaftsprogramm, wenn man mal diese Währungsidiotie von wir gehen aus dem Euro raus bei der AfD und so, wenn wir das mal wegnehmen, dann ist das in vielen Punkten sehr deckungsgleich.
Genau. Das Problem ist eben, dass das, was die Partei eigentlich will, steht halt nicht im Programm. Also da kommt es dann halt zu unschärfen, aber konnte man ja nicht wissen, war ja nirgendwo zu lesen.
Ja, du sagst da jetzt gerade etwas, denn mir ist was aufgefallen, es gibt ja immer so eine Steuer, die kann man anheben, mit denen kann man ärmere Leute starker belasten, mit der kann man eine Rentenkürzung vollziehen und mit dieser Steuer kann man auch dafür sorgen, dass es den anderen besser geht und die Staatsanahme erheblich steigen. Das wäre die Mehrwertsteuer. Die Mehrwertsteuer ist da kein Thema. Sie ist aber in Österreich Thema gewesen.
Ja, können wir ja mal hören hier.
Sie steht nirgends drin. Aber es steht auch nirgends, wir schließen eine Mehrwertsteuer aus.
Ja, du weißt ja, wie es ist. Wenn du es vorher reinschreibst, schreibst du 16% rein und dann wären es aber 19% und so. Also deswegen wird halt einfach gemacht.
Und Österreich hat sich das mit Österreich mitbekommen, dachte ich, okay, achte mal in den Programmen drauf, da kommt es aber nicht vor.
Genau, also es steht nicht in den Programmen, aber die Ideologie ist klar. Also was Mehrwertschauern so angeht, da sind sie sich einig. Wir hören das jetzt über die ÖVP. Es gilt wortgleich auch für die CDU.
Also einerseits in der ÖVP hassen weite Teile die Sozialdemokratie. Also da reden wir wirklich über Tiefsitzenden, Hass.
Aber das hat doch mit der Frage nichts zu tun.
Doch, jetzt warte. Vor allem gegen Andreas Babler, der die SPÖ nach links gerückt hat, der so klassenkämpferischer Töne anschlägt und so weiter. Und im FPÖ-Programm steht auch was drinnen, nämlich, dass sie niedrigere Steuern wollen. So, ist doch cool. Und was man mit der FPÖ nicht muss, das ist total praktisch, man muss nicht schauen, dass man die untersten sozialen Schichten in irgendeiner Weise unterstützt, sondern denen kann man im Zweifel auch noch was wegnehmen. Das haben sie von 2017 bis 2019 auch schon gemacht. Und das geht mit der Sozialdemokratie halt zum Beispiel nicht, das wäre mit den Neos übrigens auch nur schwer gegangen. Es steht natürlich nicht drinnen im FPÖ-Parteiprogramm, wie die irgendwas von dem finanzieren wollen, was sie da verlangen.
Also auf die Ärmsten Bizeps. Der Staat wird mit deren Bizeps verteidigt. Ihr eigenes Schicksal wird mit ihrem Bizeps, also gehen Sie ins Gym. Warte nicht auf den Staat, er hat Ihnen nichts am Angebot. Im Politikteil bringt er das nochmal schön zusammen.
Also man macht dann im Anschluss fantasielose Koalitionsgespräche, tauscht in alter Manie die Themen ab, obwohl man irgendwann da vorne gesagt hat, ja, wir haben verstanden, ja. Man nimmt dem einen was weg in diesen Koalitionsgesprächen, freut sich diebisch darüber, zieht rote Linien ein, bei denen klar ist, dass der andere nicht drüber kann. Also das ist eine Form von Unernsthaftigkeit.
Damit ist hier zum Beispiel gemeint, Söder sagt nicht mit den Grünen.
Ja.
Das ist diese Unernsthaftigkeit.
Im Umgang mit diesem Phänomen von allen anderen Parteien, die wirklich atemberaubend ist. Und Lenz Jakobsen hat das in unserem Podcast diese Woche eine Form von Arbeitsverweigerung genannt. Ich finde das trifft schon ganz gut. Also man muss eine Zäsur schon erstens erkennen und wenn man sie erkennt, auch Schlüsse daraus ziehen und die ernst nehmen.
Zäsur und erkennen. Wir haben es hier schon ein paar mal gesagt. Er kommt jetzt mit einer Lösung für ein sehr großes Problem. Es könnte auch für die CDU eine Lösung sein. Wir kriegen ja wohl jetzt die nächsten Tage erster Hochrechnung, in der es heißt CDU minus zwei Prozent und wie auch immer, denn es gibt ja noch andere Leute, sind ja nicht nur rechtsradikal in Deutschland.
Angela Merkel hat sich ja gegen Friedrich Merz gerannt mit einem Statement. Michel Friedmann, nach 40 Jahren aus der CDU ausgetreten. Der Holocaust-Überlebende Albrecht Weinberg ist so weit gegangen, dass er das Bundesverdienstkreuz zurückschickt. Das sind schon Dinge, die dafür sorgen, dass manche bei der CDU vielleicht einmal nachdenken werden.
Was jetzt bedeutet, Merz ist verbrannt. Also es ist einfach sozusagen, der Markel hängt jetzt an ihm, selbst wenn man so noch Kanzler wird, ist das Biegen und Brechen.
Kommt drauf an bei wem, ne? Also bei Leuten, die jetzt noch klar denken können. Aber es war zugleich an dem Tag, hat unsere geliebte Marion Horn von der Bild-Zeitung, hat dort geschrieben, das sei ein wunderbares Statement für Klarheit und Entscheidungsfreude und was weiß ich.
Kann man natürlich auch so sehen. Florian Gasser erklärt jetzt hier, wo noch die Einflugsschneise für konservative Kräfte sind, die noch etwas bewegen wollen und vielleicht noch mal Lust haben auf ein bisschen mehr politische Unterstützung, als nur so ein 30 Prozent Scheiße eigentlich Überlebenskampf. Oh krass, 28 Scheiße, allem schlechte Laune, das führt ja nirgendwo hin. Wir brauchen redliche Konservative.
Variier noch mal meine Frage vom Anfang.
Jetzt unseriös?
Genau, die chronologische. Wenn wir jetzt noch mal auf die ÖVP gucken, was müsste die denn jetzt tun oder was könnte die denn tun, damit es sie jetzt nicht zerbröselt in dieser Gemengelage?
Boah, das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Darf ich die vielleicht ein bisschen anders, also ich komm drauf, versprochen.
Du darfst sie umschreiben, die Frage.
Weil es ist ja so, es gibt sehr viele Bücher und kluge Texte dazu, dass es, wenn es um die Frage geht, ob ein Land Richtung autoritär kippt, es um das Verhalten der konservativen Kraft geht. Es braucht in einer Demokratie eine redliche konservative Kraft. Das Problem der ÖVP ist, dass sie unredlich worden ist. Und zwar spätestens unter Sebastian Kurz. Sie hat mit Populismus geliebeäugelt, sie hat die Justiz angegriffen, sie hat xenophobische Ressentiments benutzt, all diese Dinge, die man eben von der FPÖ kennt. Und sie hat es nicht geschafft, in dieser nicht sehr langen Post-Cruz-Zeit, sich aus diesem politischen Schmuddelgeschäft wieder auszusteigen.
Ja und das ist doch ein Problem für sich. Jetzt unabhängig von AfD und Bundestagsdebatten und was auch immer, zu behaupten, man könnte Deutschland abschotten. Kein einziger kommt hier mehr rein, ist unredlich.
Ja.
Diese Idee von Sicherheit für alle, es wird nichts mehr passieren, unredlich. All diese Vorschläge, die da jetzt kommen, sind einfach unredlich. Also für sich alleine schon. Dass sie dann noch verkauft werden mit dem Subtext, die AfD hatte immer recht und jetzt müssen wir es auch kompromisslos umsetzen, liegt ja nur noch sozusagen ein Schleier drüber, der die Färbung mitgibt. Aber inhaltlich und intrinsisch ist die Programmatik der CDU absolut unredlich. Sie läuft auf Lüge hinaus und sie wird unauthentisch vorgetragen. Wir haben jetzt hier nicht so einen Friedrich Merz, der wie Meloni antritt und am Ende stellt man fest, sie hat es nicht so hingekriegt mit ihren Zielen, aber wir haben es ihr geglaubt. Sie will es wirklich. Das ist ja bei Merz nicht so. Bei Merz sehen doch alle, will seine Biografie veredeln, empfiehlt noch der letzte Tritt gegen Angela Merkel. Er möchte, und das er ausgerechnet jetzt sie bekommt, so ist natürlich auch absurd. Ich möchte euch einen Podcast empfehlen, der es ein bisschen richtig macht, denn wir haben hier Strongmans, die glauben ihr Bizeps, die diese Ethologie vertreiben und so weiter und so fort. Und es gibt einen, dem muss man auch so ein bisschen amüsiert gucken, The Midas Touch, irgendwie relativ neu, ich kenne ihn noch gar nicht so lange. Und mir gefällt einfach der Sing-Sang die ganze Zeit. Also wer in der Frequenz von Hoss und Hopf jetzt einfach Gegenrede haben will, und zwar innertlich auf demselben Niveau, aber auch in einer Art und Weise vorgetragen, in der nicht die ganze Zeit in diesem Podcast nochmals dafür gedankt wird, dass und bitte lest unsere Bücher so appellativ und befehlstot. Sondern einfach nur so, nee wir haben uns das angeguckt, irgendwie blöd, das ist bescheuert, wir machen uns immer drüber lustig. Der hört diesen Podcast, wir hören uns das anderthalb Minuten an, an der Stelle wo man Trump auch ärgern kann, weil es ihn einfach kränkt. Einschaltquoten seiner Amtseinführung war bisher gar kein großes Thema. Hier dann doch.
Trumps Erneuerungsschaltquoten sind großartig von Biden. Es geht darum, zu sagen, wie 24,59 Millionen Zuschauer in die Trump-Erneuerung beteiligt sind. Das ist 27% weniger als die 2021-Erneuerung von Präsident Biden, die 33,76 Millionen Zuschauer von 17 Kanälen geträgt hat. Donald Trump hatte auch 19,75% weniger Zuschauer als seine erste, pathetische Erneuerung. Er hatte diese sehr kleine Crowd-Size und sein Presse-Team versuchte, wie das größte Erneuerung in der Geschichte war. Du hattest weniger Ratings als Donald Trump und Präsident Biden hat dich gewonnen. Auch diese ganze Erneuerung war wahrscheinlich die weichste, die spathetisch und humilierendste Erneuerung in der Geschichte. Nicht nur aus der Sicht dieser sehr hohen, kleinen Ratings, Donald, aber auch Donald Trump blamierte kaltes Wetter als der Grund, warum er die Erneuerung von außen, innen, in die Rotunda brachte. Guess what, Donald, when President Obama had millions of people show up for his inauguration after the 2008 election, it was basically the same exact weather.
Ja, in meinem Podcatcher, Hoss und Hopf und Maiders Touch, das wechselt sich die ganze Zeit ab. Ich werd hier nur.
Schön. Gratuliere. Wir haben jetzt schon ein bisschen über Wirtschaft geredet haben, aber ein ökonomisches Feld bislang außer Acht gelassen. Und zwar... Die Milch. Nein, die Sammelkarten. Und zwar war es so, ich habe mit Thomas und Michael zusammengesessen, die drei Jahre alt sind. Nein, die von FatboyFilm sind und erwachsen sind und meine Filmanalyse drehen. Und Thomas erzählte mir dann irgendwann sehr begeistert von seinen Sammelkarten und von diesem ganzen Hype. Und er redete immer weiter und dann dachte ich, das ist das Thema. Das ist das Thema, das wir hier unbedingt verhandeln müssen. Vielleicht werden sich manche erinnern, wir haben mal über NFT-Karten gesprochen. Die gibt es auch nach wie vor, aber dieser NFT-Hype ist ja etwas abgeflaut. Aber dieses Sammelkarten-Ding ist eines, an dem wir ganz viel jetzt lernen können. Also es geht jetzt nicht darum, dass wir jetzt Expertise nur erwerben in Form von, was muss ich jetzt investieren in Sammelkarten, sondern über die Idee Wirtschaft oder sagen wir eher, wie Leute heute über Wirtschaft denken, was das eigentlich bedeutet, wenn jetzt so ein Donald Trump im Amt ist und der umgibt sich mit lauter Influencern für so Sammelkarten-Kram und so, was das eigentlich bedeutet. Das heißt, da hängt also sehr viel mehr dran. Ich sage hier als Disclaimer, ausdrücklich habe ich jetzt auch Sammelkarten-Anhänger kennengelernt. Nicht heißt das Sammelkarten-Sammler sind rechts oder sind irgendwie sonst dubios. Ich will nur sagen, das gesamte System, das da aufgebaut wird, das ist eines, das tatsächlich an ein Pyramidensystem erinnert, das tatsächlich daran erinnert, dass wir es hier mit Strukturen zu tun haben.
Gut, das nämlich schon alle 8-Jährigen, die ich kenne, werden jetzt plötzlich als rechts und dubios hängt.
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Das aber das, was da so noch dranhängt an Ökonomie, was da sich jetzt drum gebaut hat, etwas ist, was uns sehr viel darüber aussagen kann, wie viele Leute jetzt über Wirtschaft nachdenken. Und dass es hier auch wieder geht, Survival of the fittest, oder sagen wir eher, wer zuerst kommt, mal zuerst. Man muss clever sein, man muss Glück haben, die ganze Glücksspielindustrie. Wir werden nachher auch Montana Black hören. All das, was heute so in den Köpfen vieler junger Menschen, aber dann auch älterer Menschen drin ist, denn dieses Sammelkarten-Phänomen ist nicht eins von 8-Jährigen, ist auch nicht eins von 18-Jährigen, sondern das geht weit durch alle Alterskohorten hindurch. Das ist eines, das so dominant ist, dass wir an ihm allegorisch sehen können, wie Leute eigentlich darüber nachdenken. Also wer immer so sagt, das Squid Game ist ja interessant, das erzählt so viel über den Kapitalismus, dann würde ich sagen, ja das stimmt, aber die Sammelkarten und die Ökonomie, die erzählen auch wahnsinnig viel über den Kapitalismus.
Hab ich eine Impression schildern? Du erzählst jetzt irgendwas von allegorisch und ich denk mir nur, Wolfgang, da liegt eine sehr bunte Packung mit Dingern, machen wir die jetzt endlich auf oder was ist denn los?
Nein, so schnell geht das ja nicht. Wir machen das spannend. Ich habe mir...
Ich bin auch schon ganz angefixt von den Karten.
Mein lieber Freund Thomas hat mir eine Packung besorgt, denn ich dachte, ich kaufe einfach mal Sammelkarten, ich bestell was im Internet. Nein, um Gottes Willen, es müssen natürlich bestimmte Sammelkarten sein. Ich kann das schon mal ankündigen, wir öffnen nachher Pokémon-Sammelkarten und zwar aus dieser Reihe prismatische Entwicklungen. Sehr begehrt, hat man mir gesagt. Und man hat mir auch gesagt, worauf wir zu achten haben. Also man darf da jetzt auch gleich die Finger auch sauber halten und so. Und dann darf da jetzt gleich, wir fassen hier möglicherweise gleich pures Gold an. Okay. Ja, also das sind wertvolle Sachen. Wir nähern uns dem aber erst einmal über einen Netflix-Trailer. Es gibt eine Serie, die heißt King of Collectibles, die geht jetzt bald wohl in die dritte Staffel schon. The Golden Touch. Dieser Golden ist ein Mensch, der nicht nur gerne sammelt, sondern eine Plattform errichtet hat, auf der alle möglichen Sammler-Objekte verschreitert verkauft werden können. Das fängt dann bei Sammelkarten. Eine Börse. Eine Börse geht über zu original getragene Trikots von Michael Jordan und, und, und. Also alles Mögliche kannst du dort. Alles, was irgendwelche besonderen Gucci-Taschen.
Alles das, was Trump in seinem Büro aufstapelt, als die Insignien der amerikanischen Geschichte, die er jetzt weiterschreiben möchte.
Zum Beispiel kannst du noch, gibt's auch eine Folge zu, nicht die ganze Folge zu, aber in einer Folge kommt das vor. Dort geht es um die amerikanische Verfassung. Da gab es so einen Sammler-Hype im 19. Jahrhundert. Dann hat man die teuer reproduziert oder nochmal abgeschrieben und so. Und diese Sammlerstücke sind auch ganz selten. Und da kannst du dir ja vorstellen, da scharen sich dann auch viele Darum, um da so ein uraltes Stück Papier in der Hand zu haben. Wir versuchen uns über diesen Trailer einmal einen Eindruck zu vermitteln, worum es da geht. Und wir sehen hier Golden schon im Privatjet, fliegt er natürlich zu den einzelnen Meetings.
I've been in this business since I was a little kid. And I'm motivated by three things. Competition, ego and money.
Competition, ego, money. Kommt uns irgendwie alles bekannt vor? Haben wir doch heute schon mal gehört. Hochkompetitiv, jeder wettet gegen jeden. Wer macht das beste Offer? Beyond Rare.
Hidden Treasure exist out there, that you couldn't possibly imagine. It could be 500, 600 thousand dollars. Wow, you haven't seen anything yet.
This is the original Apple One computer.
The actual Jackie Robinson jersey.
When Ken puts a task on you to get something done, you gotta get it done.
We're literally talking hundreds of thousands of dollars. Awesome. What can you offer us right now?
Wenn er es nicht erfolgreich machen kann, dann macht es ein Gegner ein Wettbewerb.
Das ist diese Welt der Atome, die Grubber und Teal da so interessiert hat.
Ja.
Nicht die Bits, sondern die Atome. Und wenn schon nichts weitergeht, dann zumindest nochmal die Geschichte.
Ja und wir sprechen über die materielle Welt jetzt. Das ist das Interessante jetzt hier. Wir haben es mit einem Business zu tun, dass absolut die Digitalisierung braucht, insofern als dort die Plattformen sind. Aber es geht jetzt wirklich um die Gegenstände. Hat dieses Glas vielleicht schon mal, Prinz weiß ich nicht, wer angefasst, ist dieses alte Trikot noch ungewaschen und sofort wieder verpackt worden?
Das ich muss kurz, Chris Christie war bei John Stewart im Podcast und hat dort erzählt, wie er zu Trump ins Weißer Haus ging und Trump auf den Schreibtisch von Lincoln zeigte und meinte, dort hat er die Gettysburg-Address geschrieben und Christie so, nee jeder weiß, der saß da im Zug. Und dann Donald Trump so, aber ich bin der Präsident. Das ist der Schreibtisch.
Er authentifiziert das und dann ist das so. Ja, wie hoch wird es gehen? Er hat sich natürlich auch in dieser Serie mit Logan Paul getroffen. Dort ist es so, dass sie ganz teure Pokemon-Karten-Sets aufmachen.
Das hab ich mal gesehen.
Da sind dann 80, 90 Pakete drin. Also Logan Paul macht das ja auch zu einem Dauerprogramm bei sich. Jedenfalls treffen sie sich und dann fährt Logan Paul noch mal los und sagt, ja jetzt war das erste nicht gut, jetzt machen wir noch mal eins auf, das ist 230.000 Dollar wert und das ist aber dann auch wieder nichts. Wir hören da mal kurz rein.
Wenn wir Charizards holen, ist es eine gute Chance, dass es ein 10 wird.
Das ist gut, ihr habt Geld in der Packung, ein 12.000 Dollar Karte, ein PSA 10.
Will McCracy, kannst du ein 3P machen?
Oh mein Gott, du hast das beste Glück!
Ein Nine Tails, oh mein Gott!
Perfekt.
Ein schönes Karte.
Will, du hast es schon wieder gemacht, etwa.
Logan Paul muss man vielleicht für die Leute, die den nicht so kennen, erklären, ist ein Influencer, der über Musical.ly berühmt wurde. Dann anfing auch mit solchen MMA-Fights, der darüber hinaus mit solchen Krypto-Investments reich geworden ist und auch selber irgendwas auf den Markt geworfen hat, alles Mögliche tut und auch diese Pokémon-Karten und weitere Karten sammelt. Und zu seinen Inhalten gehört es auch, dass er besonders teure Sammlerstücke aufreißt, sie vor der Kamera präsentiert. Oder er ist auch der Besitzer der teuersten Pokémon-Karte. Hat für über 4 Millionen Dollar eine Pokémon-Karte gekauft und bekommt dafür jetzt von einem Herrn vom Guinness Buch der Weltrekorde ein Zertifikat, das noch niemand so blöd vor ihm gewesen ist, so viel Geld auszugeben.
Wir beschreiben kurz das Bild. Er ist noch in Kampfmontur. Er fasst die Handschuhe noch an und freut sich aber wie ein Sechsjähriger darüber.
Ja, dass er jetzt eine Urkunde bekommt und keine Teilnehmer-Urkunde, sondern er ist wirklich der Sieger.
But it's even cooler that you, yes you at home, can own this card with me.
Aha, also er hat diese Karte gekauft, aber du kannst du kannst jetzt Teil sein, Stichwort autoritärer Charakter. Jetzt musst du natürlich auch eigentlich ein Strongman sein. Jetzt hast du leider nicht auch 4,5 Millionen, um eine Karte zu kaufen, aber du kannst mit einem kleinen Investment Teil des Ganzen sein. Wie geht das?
Das finde ich sehr gut.
So. Right into the plug, right?
So this was a very hard decision to make, but yes, I will be listing this card on a platform that I co-founded called Liquid Marketplace. It allows co-ownership of top tier assets. So instead of one person, me owning this card, we as a collective can co-own it together. Ich werde es auch für 5 Millionen Dollar nennen, anstatt die 5,3 Millionen Dollar, die ich für gekauft habe. Also werde ich euch 300.000 Dollar Discounts geben, weil jeder Discounts mag. Und ich sollte sagen, ich werde 49% der Karte behalten, also habe ich nicht wirklich Zugang zu dem, es wird in unserem Volk sein. Aber wenn ich den Fights oder ein Pokémon Box Break oder vielleicht sogar ein Museum verwenden will, kann die Gemeinde entscheiden, ob wir das machen wollen. Als Kollektor war das eine schwierige Entscheidung, ich würde mich gerne für mich selbst behalten, um ehrlich zu sein, dass die Gemeinde es gemeinsam ko-ownen kann und das Plattformen, das ich ko-founded, Liquid Marketplace, viel mehr spannend ist.
Das ist also der Kommunismus, der hier noch möglich ist. Man kann also Milliardären das als treure Hobby unterstützen.
Ernsthaft, ne? Das ist so blöd. Also wir sind nicht nur für die Demokratie zu blöd, das ist einfach so blöd. Und wie er auch noch dreimal dazu sagt, das wäre das eine Auszeichnung statt der Hinweis, dass es alles bescheuert ist, dass er die Plattform selbst mitgegründet hat.
Also er verwirklicht sich irgendeinen Unsinn und sagt, die ist eine Plattform, da könnt ihr alle auch noch Geld einzahlen und dann hört euch das mit.
Es fällt ihm sehr schwer, die Karte zu teilen.
Also ich kaufe mir jetzt einen Rolls Royce und dann sage ich, und damit ihr auch alle was davon habt, könnt ihr jetzt da mit rein investieren und ich fahre damit aber durch die Gegend.
Es tut ihm sehr schwer, dass er jetzt sein Konto öffnen muss für die Einzahlung der Leute zu Hause.
Ja, super. Also auf diesem Niveau reden wir. Jetzt werden sich manche fragen, Sammelkarten, was ist denn da los? Also viele werden es vielleicht noch aus Kindheitstagen kennen. Man kann ja zum Beispiel so Fußballkarten sammeln von Bundesliga-Spielern oder wenn dann eine EMWM ist. Es gibt Panini, das ist der ganz große Hersteller da. Und dann gibt es Tops, die sind auch ganz relevant für das Sportbusiness. Tops war ursprünglich ein Kaugummi-Hersteller und hat sich dann aber immer weiter davon wegbewegt. Und hat diese Karten dann nicht nur in diese Kaugummis reingelegt, sondern hat irgendwann gesehen, mit den Karten selbst kann man ja enorm Geld verdienen, wenn man dort ein entsprechendes Sammlergeschäft draus macht. Jetzt ist es ja so, dass man ja erst wie das so ist im Kapitalismus mehrere Mitbewerbe hat, die auch alle irgendwelche Karten machen mit Sportlern drauf. Dann hat man aber durch Lizenzgeschäfte und Exklusivverträge ist immer mehr geschafft, dass sich dieses Geld bündelt bei Tops. Michael Eisner, der einst Disney leitete, ist dann bei Tops eingestiegen. Wir hören jetzt von dem YouTube-Kanal Sports Cards Edge eine kleine Geschichte des Unternehmens Tops.
In 2007 wurde Tops von Michael Eisner entdeckt, der Disney-CEO, seine eigene private Firma war. und Medienentwicklung ausbreiten und es ging sogar um eine Bazooka-Joe-Filme. Aber die Tops-Purchase war damals eine geniöse Purchase und ich zeige euch warum, weil Tops öffentlich war. So wie ihr seht, waren 2007 die Tops-Sale bis zu 200 Mio. Dollar pro Jahr. Und als Michael Eisner seine Firma auf die Suche ging, sahen Sie, dass sie die Revennüge der Tops-Fraktion vorher drehtrippelten.
Ein Riesen-Business und das hat man dann noch weiter skaliert durch Exklusivität.
Also es war ein großartiger Kauf und ein großartiger Plan für die neuen Händler der Tops. Und das ist wo der Tops-Monopoly zurückkommt. In 2009 wurde der Tops das erste offizielle Basketball-Kart der Major League Baseball. Und Tops hatte die Exklusivität für den Ausbau der Major League Baseball und die Team-Trademarks und Logos auf Karten, Sticker und anderen Produkten.
Weißt du was interessant ist? Hier geht es ja um Anteilnahme.
Ja.
Also Leute möchten gerne nicht einzeln alleine als Zuschauer davor sitzen, sondern die möchten gern mitmachen, teilhaben, beteiligt sein.
Das sind die Leute, die uns erklären, regelst mit deinen Bizeps, geh ins Gym, achte nicht auf die anderen, sei selbst der Stärkste, die das jetzt ausbeuten, dass die Jungs zu Hause eigentlich nur beteiligt werden möchten.
Ja, entweder an einer Karte oder dazugehören, dass sie zum Beispiel dann von einem Debüt eines Sportlers einen Teil zu Hause haben. Also es gibt bei Tops zum Beispiel die Rookie-Card, RC genannt. Das ist also die Sammelkarte, die kommt dann auf den Markt, wenn ein Athlet seinen Debüt gibt in der höchsten Wettbewerbsstufe des Sports. Und eine solche Karte ist dann besonders beliebt, kann man sich denken. Und jetzt ist es ja so, Karten kann man ja eigentlich drucken ohne Ende. Da gibt es ja keine Limitierung. Aber man muss natürlich eine künstliche Verknappung einführen, damit überhaupt diese Karten begehrenswert sind. Jetzt kann man das zum einen über den Druck regeln, wir werden das gleich noch sehen. Man kann das zum Beispiel dann so machen, dass man sagt, naja, manche Grafiken sind nur auf manchen Karten anzutreffen. Also es gibt zum Beispiel die Holos bei den Pokémon-Karten. Das sind also die Karten, die so ein Hologramm haben, aber da gibt es auch verschiedene Holos. Ich hab's mal rausgeschrieben. Holographic Rare. Diese Karten haben ein glänzendes holographisches Design auf dem Pokémon-Bild. Der Rest der Karten ist matt.
Reverse-Holo.
Bei diesen Karten ist der gesamte Kartenhintergrund holographisch, während das Pokémon-Bild matt bleibt. Full-Art-Holo, das sind die besten. Diese seltenen Karten haben ein vollständig holographisches Design. Ja, und da gibt es dann natürlich dann Schnellkarten, die 100 und mehr Euros wert sind. Dann ist es so, dass man bei diesen Sportkarten natürlich noch ganz anders Exklusivität herstellen kann, nämlich so.
Und dann auf Kartenautographen und auf der rechten Seite die Rookie-Patch-Autos, die eigentlich auch mit Spielverwendeten, Memorabilia und Jersey-Patchen in Schnellkarten sind. Ich liebe es. Das ist ein großartiger Teil meines Hobbys und es ist eine lustige Sache, das zu fassen. Aber es ist auch eine große Explosion in der Nutzung der Karten.
Du kannst also, wenn du so ein Set kaufst, man kann ein Set kaufen, das kostet vielleicht 150 oder 250 Euro. Da sind 180 Karten drin, immer in so einzelnen Packages. Und dann reißt du die auf, suchst alles durch und dann hast du vielleicht eine Karte, auf der ein Autogramm ist. Da ist das schon mehr wert. Oder es kann sogar eine Karte sein, da ist ein Zipfel von dem Trikot des Sportlers. Woran erinnert uns das? Natürlich an die Reliquie. Wenn wir in Dorfkirchen gehen, werden wir in fast jeder Kirche.
Nein, nein, wir gehen in den Kölner Domen.
Nein, nein, ich will jetzt nochmal sagen, um das Bildklatsch machen. Also wenn man jetzt in eine Dorfkirche geht, dann findet man häufig auch dort Reliquien mit einem Kreuzsplitter.
Ja, aber typischerweise.
Von der Kreuzigung Jesu. Nun ist es aber so, wenn man mal diese ganzen Splitter zusammen werfen würde, hätte man vermutlich einen Wald.
Genau. Also das ist ja wie in Eisenach. Jeder nimmt sich und dann malet irgendwann, wird die Tinte einfach nachgemalt als Luther den Teufel an der Wand sah und so weiter. In Köln haben sie es ja ganz clever gemacht. Das sind ja die Reliquien einfach versteckt. Man sieht sie nicht. Also sind halt die Gebeine der Heiligen Drei Könige, aber halt in diesem Goldsakofag, der für sich schon wieder selber Pilgerstätte geworden ist. Ja. Da hat man diese Art von Virtualisierung auch schon geschafft.
Dann kommt es natürlich auch darauf an, was hat man also bei einer Reliquie? Ja, das geht ja darum, die wertvollsten Stücke zu haben. Wir sehen uns kurz eine Werbung an von Tops, Werbung für eine Rookie-Card und wir beschreiben mal, was wir da sehen. Auf diesem Trikot der, was sind das für Schläger? Das war jetzt Baseball. Ich hab mich tiefer eingearbeitet, wie du merkst, wir sind mittendrin. Auf diesen Trikots der Baseball-Spieler ist am Arm noch mal der Button des Vereins. Das ist natürlich was ganz Besonderes, denn den gibt es ja nur einmal auf einem Trikot, das ist ja nicht irgendein Rock-Fitzel. Und dieser kann jetzt auch auf diese einen Karte sein, das heißt auf diese Karte gibt es nur einmal, 1 zu 1 ist das.
Ein hoher Rund für Dominguez in seinem ersten Liga-Bast.
It's the ultimate rookie card. And it can be yours.
Du musst also jetzt ganz viele Karten kaufen, investieren und sehen, dass du vielleicht diese eine bekommst.
Donald Trump hat ja bei seinen 100 Unterschriften auch Stifte mit gehabt, auf denen seine eigene Unterschrift, mit der er diesen Stift macht, schon drauf gedruckt ist. Und dann hat ja jede Executive Order ihren eigenen Stift gehabt. Und die Stifte werden natürlich dann auch hier und da und so.
Ja, so wird das gemacht. Das sind Reliquien. Das ist moderne Form von Reliquien. Und wenn man sich aber das Business dahinter ansieht, dann geht es da wenig um Emotionen, Nostalgie und weiß ich nicht was. Sondern wir haben schon gehört, Tops wurde eine Zeit lang dann dort gekauft von Michael Eisnern. Der hat das dann skaliert und hat es verkauft an Fantastix.
So jetzt im Januar 2022, ist Tops aufgrund von Fantastix für 500 Millionen Dollar gekauft, die Dollar auf den Penis, als die Firma wert war. Aber ohne die Major League Baseball Players Association-License, war Tops selbst wahrscheinlich nicht wertvoll. So jetzt sind wir in dem, was ich nenne, der Fantastix-Ära. Und so ist Fantastix jetzt so der echte Monopoli. Und die einzige Frage ist, was wird die Zukunft von Baseball-Karten von hier aus sein?
Eine halbe Milliarde hat man das Business jetzt verkauft an Phantastics, Phantetics und Phantetics ist der weltweit größte Anbieter von lizenzierter Sportbekleidung. Die haben dann auch Marken wie NFL, UEFA, Bundesliga und auch bald die englische Premier League. Phantetics erzielte im Jahr 2024 einen Umsatz von 8,1 Milliarden US-Dollar und dieses Unternehmen ist also das Führende bei Sport Merchandising. Wir haben es also mit einem Konzern zu tun, dessen Interesse es ist, den Gewinn möglichst zu skalieren und wir haben eine Fangemeinde und eine Sammlergemeinde. Das müssen nicht alles Fans sein, es können auch ganz viele sein, die einfach nur investieren wollen, die man eben mit solchen Systemen, die auf eine künstliche Verknappung hinauslaufen, dazu lockt immer mehr, diese Karten zu kaufen, während die bei der Produktion halt aufpassen müssen, dass sie den Markt nicht in der Weise überhitzen, dass die Leute wütend werden. Aber sie dürfen auch nicht so viel produzieren, damit die Leute dann nicht sagen, ja jetzt ist das ja gar nichts mehr wert.
Ja, kein Wunder, dass überall die Flugzeuge abstürzen und die Wälder brennen, wenn die Männer in diesem Business hängen.
Könnte man auch so mal sagen, ja. Ja, also das ist, es ist ein Riesenhype und zwar global. Ja, das ist jetzt auch nicht nur auf Amerika bezogen, sondern in asiatischen Ländern ist es natürlich auch ganz groß.
Oh, das glaube ich.
Und jetzt ist interessant, welche Geschäftsformen da immer noch so angedockt sind. Jetzt könnte man ja sagen, ja Fanetics hat jetzt Tops gekauft, Tops, da werden diese Karten produziert, dann werden die über Händler verkauft. Aha. Und hat man die oder hat man die nicht? Weit gefehlt. Es geht natürlich viel weiter. Nehmen wir mal an, du hast jetzt so eine ganz besondere Karte. So eine Holo weiß ich nicht was oder irgendwas mit einem Autogramm. Dann kannst du auf Marketplaces nachschauen, wie viel die wert ist. Aber das ist noch gar nicht sicher, wie viel deine Karte genau wert ist. Denn es kommt auch darauf an, wie der Druck ist der Karte. Und dann gibt es zum Beispiel Karten.
Statt einfach nur Hologramm und dann verschiedene ist jeder Druck.
Nein, da man, also man produziert natürlich, weiß nicht was die Produktion kostet. Es wird sehr billig sein solche Karten zu produzieren. Man produziert jetzt nicht so hochwertig, dass jede Karte wirklich identisch ist, sondern manchmal ist die Zentrierung ein bisschen verrückt. Dann ist der weiße Rande rechts ein bisschen breiter, einen Millimeter breiter als auf der anderen Seite. Oder der Druck ist nicht so farbkräftig wie auf anderen Karten. Und das alles mindert dann den Preis. Das heißt also, du bist, weil wir eben von kompetentiven Lebenssprachen, von Wettbewerben und all das, wir sind also hier in einer Situation, wo man nicht nur jetzt so einen Wettbewerb hat um diese Kisten, wer kommt an die Kisten und wer hat dann die entsprechende Karte drin, sondern es gibt dann weitere Fragen. Also der Kampf, der geht noch viel weiter, nämlich du musst natürlich auch eine Karte haben, die besonders gut zentriert ist, die besonders gut gedruckt ist und die auch keinerlei Spuren am Rand hat von Gebrauch.
Du willst mir also sagen, die kaufen jetzt Sachen, bei denen die Frage im Raum steht, wie wurde es denn gelagert?
Beziehungsweise wie wurde es gedruckt? Oder ist es als es, also das wird ja maschinell verpackt. Ja, es wird ja maschinell verpackt und da kann natürlich sein auch, dass am Rande irgendwo vielleicht, wie man das auch schon mal bei einem Buch hat, dass da irgendwie was gleich leicht angeschlagen ist. Deswegen gibt es wiederum ein eigenes Geschäft, das ist PSA. PSA bewertet Pokémon-Karten. PSA heißt Professional Sports Authenticator und die geben Bewertungen ab von 1 bis 10. Und wir hören jetzt mal da etwas zu diesem Unternehmen von Buyoncore.
Wenn du in Sport oder Training Karten bist, bist du mit Unternehmen wie PSA bekannt. Lieb oder lieb sie, heute dominieren sie die Industrie und sind vertraut als Goldstandard für Kartengrading. Bevor diese Agenzien existieren, mussten die Bewerber ihre eigene Meinung aufregen. Klar, du kannst sagen, dass du einen Mind-Condition-Karten hast, aber wer ist das zu vertreten? Das ist wo PSA in 1991 in die Szene entlangkommt. Und sie haben die 1 bis 10 Gradingszahlen, die wir heute noch benutzen. Zuerst liefen die Leute nicht die Idee, eine 3rd-Party aufzuwenden, um ihre Karten zu graden. Aber besonders mit dem Wachstum der Online-Marktpläne war es ein größter Niveau für objektive Gradungen. Über die Zeit wurden die Leute ihre Karten für die Authentikation senden und die Gradung wurde der König. Und als die Industrie in den 2000er Jahren explodierte, hat PSA von Sport, zu anderen Trading Karten und Memorabilia ausgewandert. Und sie stehen heute noch als die weltweit größte 3rd-Party-Sport-Authentikations-Service in der Welt. Was ist dein Lieblings- Lass uns wissen und schau auf Encore, wenn du Karten kaufen willst.
Das heißt, wenn du jetzt eine besondere Karte hast, dann ist das Beste, du gehst zu einem lizenzierten Händler. Von dort aus wird dann die Karte in die USA geschickt, zu PSA. Die beugen sich über die Karte und bewerten die. Und wenn es richtig Bares für Rares oder wie früher Kunst und Krempel. Nur hat man früher natürlich dann irgendein Jugendstilstück oder sowas gehabt und heute beugt man sich über solche Kerzchen aus Pappe und kann dann möglicherweise sogar eine Gem-Mint-Bewertung abgeben. Das ist also eine Karte, die hat dann, heißt es da, absolute Perfektion ohne jegliche Druckfehler oder Zentrierungsprobleme. 1991 wurde das Unternehmen gegründet, ist jetzt immer wichtiger geworden und hat jetzt ganz viele verschiedene Kategorien. Mint, Near Mint, Excellent, Good, Lightly Played, Played, Poor. Also wenn du eine Poor-Karte hast, da ist es natürlich ganz schlecht.
Weißt du was ich befürchte? Mhm. Während wir vor den Hoss und Hopf Clips geguckt haben und ich wirklich keine Befürchtung hatte, dass irgend einer von unseren Hörern denkt, naja, höre ich jetzt auch mal, finde ich gut, fickst du gerade die Leute an.
Meinst du, dass ich jetzt...
Also ich gehöre ja zu den Leuten, die sagen gedruckte Bücher, was für ein Scheiß, ich will es und so. Und ich bin trotzdem fasziniert.
Du bist davon fasziniert? Ja. Wenn du jetzt so eine Karte hast und die wurde bewährt...
Mal gucken, was ich gleich habe. Was meinst du, wie ich die gleich aufmache?
Ja, ja, du musst ganz vorsichtig machen. Ich werd dir das genau erklären, wie das geht.
Ich hab schon ein Taschentücher.
Pass auf, wenn du jetzt so eine Karte hast, die wurde jetzt gut bewertet, also die ist wirklich was wert. Wo verkaufst du sie? Du kannst sie bei E-Way Kleinanzeigen verkaufen. Du kannst auf so eine Plattform gehen. Besser ist aber vielleicht, wenn du sie direkt in deinem eigenen Homeshopping-Kanal bewirbst. Kennst du Whatnot? No. Das ist eine Plattform, die gibt es schon ein paar Jahre, die wird aber jetzt immer größer. Dort verkaufen Leute ihre Karten, aber auch andere Dinge. Du musst dir das so vorstellen, du meldest dich da an, im Prinzip in so einem TikTok-Format, meldest dich da an, bist dann Livestreamer, präsentierst dann dort deine Produkte, kannst auch sagen ich verkaufe drei alte Anzüge und dann können die Leute direkt mit einem Wisch das Produkt bei dir kaufen. Du machst also Homeshopping Europe oder QVC, ja? Wir haben jetzt hier mal ein Beispiel dafür. Der YouTuber Harry Tornado macht das im Selbstversuch, erklärt das mit Whatnot.
Heute möchte ich euch meine semi-professionelle Meinung auf wie man das übernehmen kann und Whatnot als eine der größten Sellingplattformen für euch und euer Geschäft machen kann. Whatnot ist ein super Spaßes online Marketplace, wo ihr auf alle Sorten von verrückten Sachen findet. Funko-Pop, Actionfiguren, Sneakers, Kleidung, Jewelry, alles was ihr Herz will. Wenn ihr hier ein bisschen in die Popular-Show-Kategorie schaut, wird es ein Show aus Event. Wir sehen hier, was das Top-Funko-Pop-Seller auf der App gerade macht. Sie machen Sachen sehr schnell auf der App. Ich glaube, das ist ein tolles Beispiel, wie man ein Fast-Pay-Show machen kann. Alle Auctions sind nur 5 Sekunden lang und starten mit 5 Dollar. Also zum Beispiel haben wir hier diese Funko-Pop-Version von Post Malone und ich werde es einfach schnell kaufen, um euch zu zeigen, wie einfach es ist. Sobald sie die Auktion starten, wird es ein kleines gelbes Klick auf der Basis der Bildschirme. Ihr könnt klicken und es aufreißen, um zu bieten. Das dauert mir 2 Sekunden. Ich will es einfach so, und dann wird das Item direkt in meine Heimat geschickt.
So werden in Holland die Blumen verkauft. Da geht eine Tür auf und dann werden die Blumen, also ganze Paletten hingefahren und dann läuft oben so eine Uhr einfach rückwärts. Wenn sie durchläuft, dauert auch nur 5 Sekunden und niemand drückt 0 Euro nicht verkauft weg. Wenn du es kaufen willst, so schnell wie möglich drücken. Also du siehst sie und musst sofort drücken, weil der erste der drückt gewinnt, aber der erste der drückt den höchsten Preis, der langsam runterläuft. Das ist ein ganz faszinierendes System, weil es einfach komplett die kognitive Teilnahme ausschaltet.
Die Leute sind gehypt, zahlen auch dann zum Teil enorme Preise, dazu kommen wir gleich.
So macht man auch Sportswetten übrigens. Jemand kriegt den Ball, rennt los und du musst in dem Moment entscheiden, wettest darauf, schafft er es bis hinten hin oder nicht. Ja, so. Und dann kannst du...
Naja, was stellen wir dann fest? Du hattest eben, Teaser glaube ich, das kurze Event, als wir das Buch von Marc Schiritz angekündigt haben, dass du NFL guckst und dir sei dort aufgefallen, dass nur noch so virtuelles Zeugs quasi beworben wird. Also nur noch irgendwelche Wetten, Points, was auch immer. Wir haben jetzt einen Präsidenten, der einen eigenen Coin rausgegeben hat, dann sagt die First Lady, auch mache ich auch, die sind ja jetzt dadurch erstmal wirklich in diese Multimilliarden katapultiert worden. Also wie das aussieht.
Buchgeld.
Buchgeld, ja klar.
Sie sagen einfach alle Coins zusammen sind 10 Milliarden wert und sobald der erste einen zehntausendsten Anteil für den entsprechenden Preis kauft, wird der ganze hoch gewertet, aber das heißt noch lange nicht, dass...
Ja, wenn die jetzt auf einmal dazu übergeben würden, das alles auf einmal zu verkaufen, dann würde natürlich der Wert sofort einbrechen. Genau. Aber wir können daran sehen, dass das etwas ist, was momentan überall da ist. Und ich hab's jetzt, wenn ich jetzt so durch Deutschland fahre, um irgendwo einen Vortrag zu halten, doch oft gesehen, man ist manchmal in Käfern, in denen gibt es nichts, da ist keine Metzgerei, da ist kein Restaurant, nichts. Aber eines ist noch da, eine Spielhalle. Das ist das einzige, was da ist. Du findest nichts, alles hat zu, du kannst kannst du kannst in eine Spielhalle gehen. Und diese Gamification und diese Spielsucht, die überall verpeilt wird, die steckt natürlich in solchen Dingen drin. Und diese App Botnod ist natürlich auch darauf angelegt, dass man dabei bleibt, dass man jetzt plötzlich es toll findet, Home Shopping zu gucken. Wir hören weiter Harry Tornado.
Whatnot hat entschieden, ein paar von seinen Marketing-Budgets zu erläutern, um den ersten Malseller auf der App zu helfen. Und was sie tun, ist, die Säle von deinem ersten Whatnot-Show zu 100 Dollar zu zählen.
Erst was du dann also angelockt bekommst, da dein Betrag verdoppelt.
Disney-Stuff verkauft sehr gut. Cute kleine Kaffee-Mug, kleine Aprens, kleine Gourmet-Snacks und Kandys. Kandys machen wirklich sehr gut. Da gibt es eine Kandyskategorie oder eine Snackkategorie und so weiter. Ich habe viel von da her gekauft. Das ist eine wirklich interessante Kategorie, in der die Leute wirklich, wirklich bereit sind, Impulse zu kaufen.
Weil es konsumibel ist, es interessant ist, sie kaufen es für 5 oder 10 Dollar, was auch immer, Du kennst vielleicht dieses SWR-Format, in dem Moderatoren Leute zuhause aufsuchen, die Kamera wird positioniert dann frontal und hinter ihnen sind lauter Gegenstände, die sie verkaufen wollen und dann können Leute anrufen und sagen, ja hinne der Krug aus dem Kannebäckerland, den hätt ich gern und dann fährt die Kamera auf diesen Krug zu. Es kann doch sein, dass es nicht mehr kommt.
Öffentlich-rechtliches Zeug.
War vielleicht nicht das tollste Format der Welt. Dann fährt die Kamera auf diesen Krug zu und ja, was wollen sie denn dafür haben? Und dann sagt er sieben Euro, ja für sechs würde ich ihn nehmen. Und das ist im Prinzip, hat es schon whatnot vorweggenommen. Oh.
Zwei, dreimal das Geld, aber die Leute bekommen einige tolle Verkaufsverkäufe und andere Dinge wie das. Also das musst du aufhören. Ich würde wirklich versuchen, deine Versorgungsstrategien zu optimieren, wo du etwas für fünf Dollar verkaufen kannst und es trotzdem profitabel ist. Sollte man etwas für zwei Dollar verkaufen und es trotzdem profitabel haben. Das ist schwer, wenn man in einer Thrift-Store hervorgeht und 5, 6, 7, 8 Dollar für einen Poloshirt bezahlt. Es wird schwer, mehr als 5 Dollar für einen Poloshirt zu bekommen.
So was funktioniert natürlich nur da besonders gut, wo von der Regierung nichts mehr zu erwarten ist. Dir werden nicht höhere Löhne bald zukommen, sondern du hast jetzt die Möglichkeit, nochmal so eine Mini-Mini-Selbstständigkeit aufzubauen, in dem du Poloshirts für 5 Euro bei Whatnot verkaufst und musst aber selbst die auch noch präsentieren vor einem Publikum, das dir bis dato nicht bekannt ist. Harry Tornado probiert es dann auch selbst aus, er hat dann selbst noch keine Follower dort und sagt, ich versuche jetzt mal etwas dort zu verkaufen.
Was würde ich denn als Person sein, wenn ich euch sagen würde, wie einfach es ist, wenn ich es nicht selbst versuche? Eine Sache, die ich auf dem Show verkaufe, ist das Game Boy Advance SP. Es ist das Modell AGS-001, das ist das NES-Modell. Ich verkaufe es nur für Teile.
Jetzt probiert er aus, dort etwas zu verkaufen, nämlich so einen Game Boy, der aber eigentlich kaputt ist. Er hat dann herausgefunden, er kann bei eBay eigentlich das Doppelte verdienen, erklärt aber, warum er es trotzdem bei Whatnot versucht.
So ich werde hier einen Sekunden drücken, denn ich bin mir sicher, dass jemand denkt, hey, warum würde ich das für 30 Dollar verkaufen, wenn ich natürlich 65 Dollar für eBay bekommen würde? Und das ist eine tolle Frage. Und wenn man sich will, das eBay-Work zu machen, 6, 8, 10 Fotos von diesem Ding zu nehmen und einen Titel zu machen und eine Deskription zu schreiben, um zu zeigen, wie es nicht funktioniert, und die mehrere entsprechenden Items zu füllen, und dann 30 oder 45 oder 60 Tage warten, um den richtigen Kaufzimmer zu finden und Kundenfragen zu antworten und wahrscheinlich mit einem Rückwärtsproblem zu verhandeln, weil sie nie die Deskriptionen lesen, um zu sehen, dass es nicht funktioniert. Wenn du all das machen willst, um deine 65 Dollar zu bekommen, dann mach das auf alle Fälle. Aber was wir hier reden, ist die pure Essenz der Phrase, der fasten Nickel oder der langsamen Dime.
Hm, wir hören mal rein in diese Verkaufsshow.
Ich bin froh, dass ich alles beantworten kann. Es wird nicht aufgeschüttet. Physisch ist es gut, es hat ein paar Schmerzen.
Ein Unternehmer, kannst du es jeden Abend sein. Ein Ehepaar, das vorher Karten bei Ebay verkaufte, verabschiedet sich bei YouTube und sagt, wir sind ab sofort bei Whatnot zu treffen.
Wir treten Patrick Stewart, Jamie Lee Curtis, beide Autos. Wir haben vorhin viele unserer persönlichen Kollektionen weggebracht, um unser Whatnot-Business zu finanzieren. Wir haben ungefähr 400 Dollar an Schlägen gekauft, und wir werden sie auf Whatnot auktionieren, an einem Dollar pro Stück. Wenn ihr ein paar Schläge interessiert, kommt rein, schaut uns an, bei DKTCG Cave. Wir runnen jeden Montag, Freitag, Freitag und Mittag. Wir sehen uns dort.
Trottelmarkt.
Jetzt haben wir hier ein sehr kleines Set. Bevor wir das aber öffnen, müssen wir noch erst noch was hören. Ich will es noch spannend machen. Jetzt kann man häufig sehr große Sets kaufen. Da sind dann so 80 kleine Päckchen drin. Die sind natürlich sehr teuer. Das heißt, man muss ja auch erstmal Kapital haben, um das zu machen. Das ist jetzt für Teenager oder so gar nicht so einfach möglich oder Leute, die ohnehin nicht viel Geld haben. Da gibt es aber Leute wie Montana Black, die kaufen dann so ein großes Paket, öffnen das bei Whatnot Live und dann kannst du einzelne Spots kaufen. Also du kannst sagen, ich kauf dann so ein Päckchen daraus. Wir hören mal rein in so ein Whatnot Stream von Montana Black. Also er öffnet jetzt hier, zeigt dann einzelne Karten, Pokémon-Karten.
Tangela Merkel.
Oh, Dodo hatten wir auch noch nicht, glaub ich, oder?
Doch, wir hatten einmal Dodo bei Merzpack.
Tangela Merkel ist wirklich ein krasser Sport.
Die Vorentwicklung, also er hatte Elektroball vorhin.
Und da hat er fast alles.
Smog on.
So.
Energy.
Oh wow.
Was kommt danach?
Energy.
Okay, Hugo.
Ich muss mal kurz sagen, dieser Stream dauert über drei Stunden und so sind die auch in der Regel immer. Das Einzige, was die da machen, ist, dass da drei zusammensitzen in der Mitte in Montana Black, reißen Päckchen auf und lesen die Kartennamen vor.
Also sind wir zu dumm für, ist die grundlegende neue Frage für alles.
Ich würde auch sagen.
Bist du bereit?
Drei, zwei, eins.
Oh, Garados. Geil, schöne Karte.
Garados.
Garados, Mann.
GGs, geil.
Glaubt man gar nicht, dass so ein dicker Fisch aus Carporto sich entwickelt. Carporto eigentlich so da nichts zu nutzen, dann kommt so ein Drachentier. GG.
Garados.
Ist eine sehr schöne Karte.
Was geht der?
Im besten Rating, was wäre der?
Zwei Fünf.
Zwei Fünf im besten Rating, okay.
Diese Karte könnte also im besten Rating 200.000 Euro wert sein. Bestes Rating bedeutet natürlich, man muss diese Karte jetzt einschicken zu, schon erwähnt PSA. Die müssen das dann testen.
Also es gibt... Hier verpasst man nichts, wenn man daran nicht teilnimmt. Ich sehe schon wieder irgendwelche Leute, die FOMO haben und so weiter.
Nein, ich will auf Gottes Willen.
Also ich schalte da nicht ein, da wird nichts verhandelt.
Thomas, der mir das ja hier angebracht hat und so, sagt ja auch, das ist ein bisschen bekloppt und er hat natürlich vollkommen recht damit. Und ich will es auch nochmal deutlich unterschreiben. Man sollte genau das nicht machen.
Ein Qualitätsmerkmal, wenn jemand sagt, was, ich weiß nicht, worum es da geht.
Das ist wirklich furchtbar. Es zeigt nur sehr viel darüber, über die Manosphäre, über die wir viel gesprochen haben. Es zeigt wahnsinnig viel darüber, dass alles Wettbewerb ist. Und es ist aber auch interessant, dass wir zum einen bei diesen Leuten immer so einen Leistungsethos haben und zugleich sitzen sie nur da und reißen Päckchen auf, in der Hoffnung, dass irgendeine Automatisierung dafür gesorgt hat, dass in diesem einen Päckchen die teure Karte ist und sie das Glück haben, die zu erwischen. Also es ist ja eine künstliche Verknappung. Allein das ist ja schon eine Blödeit. Wir finden ja immer toll, wenn etwas nicht künstlich verknapft wird. Also künstlich was zu verknappen ist ja per se schon eine Idiotie, wo man sagt, ja warum denn, wenn man es ja so günstig herstellen kann und wenn doch jeder gerne eine bunte Karte haben will, dann druckt man sie doch jedem. Aber nur durch die Verknappung überhaupt kann man natürlich einen solchen Wert erzeugen. Das ist ja schon eine Absurdität an sich. Und dann noch so weit zu gehen zu sagen, wir verknappen noch ein paar mal mehr dadurch, dass wenn das schlecht gedruckt ist, also nur weil die zu schlampig waren die Karte sauber zu drucken, dass das auch noch mal einen Unterschied macht, dann ist ja eine Ökonomie, die man da schafft, die natürlich volkswirtschaftlich die absolute Katastrophe ist, mit der man aber die Leute bei der Stange halten kann und jedem so ein bisschen das Gefühl geben kann dazu zu gehören.
Technologie schafft ja Tatsachen. Ja und jetzt hatten wir ja von Apple dieses Angebot, kauf unseren Laptop und da ist irgendwie so ein Magnet, dann kannst du dein Handy da dran hängen und dann funktioniert das Handy als Kamera. Und dann hat der Apple damals neu so ein Desk-View, also dass man einfach zeigt, was man gerade in der Hand hat. Da fragt man sich so, was ist denn das gemeint? Ist das jetzt ein Polylux wie früher, da man schreibt was und die Leute sollen das dann sehen in der Videokonferenz? Nein, das ist natürlich für diese Situation hier, dass Montana Black da sitzt, frontal gefilmt wird, gleichzeitig im großen Bild aber und seine Hände gezeigt werden. Er deckt ja jede Karte einzeln auf und die letzte balanciert er dann auch so auf den Fingern um zu zeigen, wir sind jetzt hier nicht irgendwo, wir müssen das jetzt hier gefühlvoll machen. Das ist dieser Kameraview, den Apple eingeführt hat. Er macht den natürlich professionell, aber das können alle zu Hause. Anschlusstheorie, weil dieses Bild ja gerechnet wird von Apple, die Kameraposition ist ja völlig ungeeignet. Es ist ja kein Top-Down-View. Kann man nicht wirklich darstellen, wie die Karte aussieht, weil das Bild ist ja verzerrt. Deswegen muss man sie nochmal zu dieser Agentur schicken, die einem sagt, wie viel sie wirklich wert ist, unabhängig davon, wie gut die Kamera ist, die das Bild zurückrechnet.
Und wir haben ja so eine interessante Mischung aus Digitalität und Materialität. Denn diese Materialität, die hier so hochgehalten wird, ist ja auch nur eine Scheinmaterialität durch diese künstliche Verknappung. Denn eigentlich würde man sagen, man produziert auch so viele Karten, die gebraucht werden. Aber nein, nur dadurch geht es. Und man hat dann so eine Situation, in der wir jetzt Deep Seek haben. Quasi vielleicht dein neuer bester Freund nach Claude. Jedenfalls haben wir jetzt von den Chinesen, haben wir von den Chinesen gezeigt bekommen, dass man also mit Open Source wahnsinnig viel erreichen kann und damit weit kommt.
Also das ist weniger, das hat ja Facebook auch schon gezeigt.
Genau, Facebook fand ja deswegen jetzt Deep Seek auch gar nicht so schlimm. Und dann haben wir aber zu... Also wir haben etwas, dass es eigentlich keine Beschränkung mehr gibt. Das Digitale ist eigentlich nicht mehr, dass man irgendwas beschränkt. Aber es gibt offenbar so eine Sehnsucht nach so etwas wie Eigentum. Und das kann man nur über eine Materialität wiederherstellen. Und das geht dann einmal über verrückte NFT-Codes. Oder man macht es so, dass man sagt, ja es gibt da ganz besondere Karten, die sind sehr selten. Und wenn da aber ein Kratzer drin ist, dann ist es doch nicht so viel wert.
Ja und vielleicht verkauft Montana Black dann auch noch sein Pikachu-Kostüm, das er anhatte, als er diese Karte aufdeckte.
Ja oder Einzelteile davon.
Oder die Ohren einzeln.
Das wird natürlich auch kritisiert, was Montana Black da tut, denn der Hype wird dadurch ja immer größer. Hier meldet sich jetzt aus YouTube Steve P. Cooking zu Wort, der sagt, das findet er gar nicht gut.
Und ich bin gerade wirklich, wirklich sauer. Es ist heute der 19.01. Montana Black.
Wir sehen hier einen jungen Mann auf einem Gamers-Stuhl sitzen, der im Hintergrund in seinem Regal ganz viele Figuren, Fabelwesen und Kerzchen stehen hat.
Kennt glaube ich, jeder ist gerade noch am Streamen auf whatnot und macht unter anderem ein Base-Set-Display auf, First Edition auf Deutsch. Was ja erstmal kein Problem ist, dass Leute, die viel Geld haben, dann auch so ein Display aufreißen. Er hat ja auch viel und dass sein Streamer-Kollegen zum Beispiel dann verkauft oder verschenkt, das weiß ich nicht genau, ist ja prinzipiell erstmal okay. Was ich allerdings gar nicht okay finde, dass in dem Stream auch prismatische Entwicklungen, Booster oder Versteiger auktioniert wurden und diese Booster teilweise 100 Euro oder mehr gekostet haben. Ein einziges Booster.
Denn wie du das eben schon so schön beschrieben hast, da setzt das Hirn aus, man sagt, oh wenn ich jetzt ganz schnell wische, dann bekomme ich das.
Weißt du, was ich da gerade gehört habe?
Und dann zahlt man gerne.
Man muss ja den Clip irgendwie übersetzen, ich weiß ja nicht, worüber die da reden, aber ich habe ungefähr gehört. Ich finde es schon nicht verkehrt, den Kakao dann auch in die Milch reinzumachen, aber dass man dafür den kurzen Löffel nimmt, obwohl man weiß, dass die Tasse so lang ist, das ist schlechtes Vorbild für die Kinder, deren Eltern zu Hause sauber machen müssen, was sie beim Umrühren anrichten. Dann das ist eine Grenze überschritten, das geht gar nicht.
Andere sehen das anders. Es gibt die YouTuber Hennas und Andreas Wiener, die sind auch da ganz tief in diesem Karten-Business drin. Die schätzen das Ganze jetzt so ein. Es geht also immer um diese prismatische Entwicklung, diese Reihe jetzt von Pokémon.
Man muss halt auch ein bisschen Glück haben, ein bisschen was vorbestellt haben und wenn nicht, dann einfach warten. Es kommt was. Es wird was kommen. Kein FOMO. Ich hab's eingeschrieben in meinen Titel. Kein FOMO.
Absolut. Also ich finde, ich finde, das ist hier, also die Geschichte ist natürlich, was spannend ist, wenn du jetzt schnell öffnest, die nach Tara ziehst und die sofort verklopst. Reden wir über die Karten Hennas. Ich finde das sehr viel spannender, wenn ich ehrlich bin, weil was sagen wir denn? Wird die nach Tara noch mal einbrechen und dann kauft man sie oder wird sie jetzt immer so weiter laufen?
Also ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, die geht ja gerade für über 2000 Euro oder so was raw weg.
Jetzt noch mal bei Nvidia einsteigen oder lieber noch warten. Das sind die Fragen, die hier auf einer anderen Ebene gestellt werden. Aber es ist genau das, dass das Subjekt als Börsianer ist also auch in dieser Sammelkultur.
Ich dachte, ich hätte einen Überblick über die Sachen, vor denen ich meine Kinder schützen muss, aber nein.
Wer weiß, wahrscheinlich schimpfen sie heute Abend mit dir, dass du irgendeine Karte dir hast entgehen lassen. Denn die müssen natürlich wieder an Thomas zurück. Das habe ich ihm versprochen, dass ich das nicht gehen kann. So wir öffnen jetzt ein Paket. Dieses Paket hat 30 Euro gekostet.
29,99 Euro.
Ja, das ist ein Paket, das Sammelkarten. Hier ist eine Broschüre oder ein Poster dabei. Dort sind die in groß aufgelistet, welche Karten es gibt.
In sehr groß, ja.
Und jetzt haben wir es hier mit, du siehst da sind manche schon nach vorne gestellt, manche Karten. Diese Karten sind auch irgendwie besonders.
Ja, man kommt nicht ran.
Weil die auch einen Glanz haben oder so. Vorsichtig soll ich die anfassen, dass ich nichts kaputt mache. Blitzer ist das und die hat auch so ein bisschen Holo. Jetzt pass auf, was macht man mit so einer Karte? Ich hab gesagt, naja, ich steck die einfach, wenn ich die alle ausgepackt hab in die Tasche. Nein, auf keinen Fall dürfte ich das tun. Dafür brauche ich erst mal einen Penny-Sleeve. Das sind solche Hüllen, den Klarsichtfolien, in die man diese hineinlegt. Ich mache das jetzt mal hier beispielhaft, denn das ist auch eine Karte, die jetzt nicht besonders wertvoll ist, aber doch auch keine schlechte Karte ist. Jetzt hab ich die also erst mal in dieser Folie drin, muss aufpassen, dass ich dabei nicht die Ecken bestoße, denn dann ist die PSA-Bewertung jetzt schlecht. So, wenn ich die jetzt darin habe, dann ist das auch nicht stabil. Ja Moment, jetzt muss diese Karte noch in so eine harte Plastik hinein. Dieses Ding nennt sich Toploader. Als der Hype mal so ganz groß war vor einem Jahr, sagte man mir, waren diese Toploader ausverkauft und wurden zu enormen Preisen gehandelt. Jetzt stecke ich also diese Karte in den Toploader, dann ist sie gesichert und dann kann ich sie dir mal geben, dann kannst du mal draufschauen.
Also erinnert mich ein bisschen, wir waren jetzt mit dem Achtjährigen in der Nähe eines Schallplattenspielers und er wollte, dass da mal was rauskommt. Noch immer eben erklärt haben, wie das funktioniert. Deshalb wir eben gesagt haben, ja dann such mal eine Schallplatte aus. Und er so, wie was, wo, was soll ich aussuchen? Und wir so, ah ja stimmt, der ist ja acht. Dann haben wir ihm gesagt, guck mal her, alles was du hier siehst sind Schallplatten. Ach so, so. Und dann geht man die durch. Die sind genauso eingepackt. Die sind getopploded und dann nochmal in so einer Hülle und dann legt man die da drauf. Nur die spielen dann auch Musik. Das hier nicht.
Du hast also jetzt diese Karte. Jetzt zeige ich dir mal, wie man das wohl aufmacht. Also wenn ich das jetzt richtig, man macht das hier hinten auf und versucht dann zu ziehen. Ich gucke mal, ob das genau so macht man das auf. Also man muss vorsichtig sein, dass man nichts kaputt drückt. Und dann ist das ist die die erste Karte. Ich glaube, die muss dann nach hinten gelegt werden. Dann dreht man sie um. Das ist also eine Jetzt kann wir hier erst eine Basic Energy Karte. Dann Mill Tank, Terirobeere, ja, Efemem, weiß nicht, was das ist, Schwarzgurt Training, La Showking, dicke Freunde Knusp. Da steht dann drauf, durchsuche dein Deck nach bis zu zwei Basis Pokemon mit 70 oder weniger KP und lege sie auf deine Bank. Mische anschließend dein Deck. Ja, das habe ich ganz vergessen zu sagen. Man kann mit diesen Karten auch und das tun wohl Kinder auch spielen.
Nee, die tauschen die alle nur. Ich glaube, niemand spielt das.
Okay, aber eigentlich ist es ein Spiel und dann kommt man hier weiter und hier, das könnte schon was besonderes sein. Die heißt Evoli und das ist Full Art Holo, glaube ich. Die klitzert doch komplett.
Guck mal.
Was wird das sein? Ist das was wertvolles ist?
Full Art Holo Evoli. Das ist mehr als 300 Euro.
Vielleicht das große Los hier gezogen. Ich muss ganz vorsichtig damit umgehen. Flatterhaar und Eisenfels. Die haben auch einen leichten Kanzler, da bin ich jetzt, da steht aber Basic drauf. Ich glaube hier steht Item. Naja, wir werden sehen, jetzt gebe ich dir mal einen.
Also es sind ja so verschiedene Gefühle, du hast mir jetzt einen in die Hand gegeben. Wir sind heute Abend wieder in der Oper. Und wir gehen ja auch gerne in die Oper, weil es in der Oper so Momente gibt, in denen man weiß, ne ich muss jetzt hier nicht nachfragen, ich nutze jetzt mein Handy nicht.
Ja.
So. Und so ist das hier auch. Man sitzt so daneben und man weiß nur Montana Black darf diese jetzt anschauen.
Es ist eine Kamera auf seine Hände gerichtet und sobald er hier einen Fehler macht, ist der Chat voll.
Ja. Nur nicht zu knicken.
Das heißt ich mach die jetzt mal so auf. Ich glaube nämlich du hast die für 30 Euro gekauft und sie sind eigentlich nur 1 Euro wert.
Ja das glaube ich auch.
Das könnte sein. Guck mal wie ich das mache. So hier. Ich hab die Karten zur Hilfe genommen um Druck auszuüben.
Ich versuch's nochmal nach der alten Methode wie man es mir beigebracht hat.
Das heißt ich leg sie jetzt alle geöffnet vor mich ohne sie je belästigt zu haben. So okay gut.
Wir schauen was du da hast.
Forschung des Professors. Guck mal ich balanciere dich schon so auf den Fingern wie Montana Black.
Ja toll. Also wir müssen das erklären. Wir haben jetzt hier so etwa zehn Karten pro Paket und eine davon könnte irgendetwas wert sein.
Ich gucke nur nach Hologrammen.
Das hier ist wieder eine Evolykarte, die hat aber kein Hologramm bei mir.
Ich hab eine.
Ach ja? Und die Frage, die ja eben gestellt wurde von Hennas und Andreas Wiener ist, wird die Nacht Tara noch so viel wert sein? Nach was? Die Nacht Tara. Also hätte man die jetzt, dann haben wir das große losgezogen. Also wir suchen nach der Nacht Tara. Wir hatten die aber bislang noch nicht drin. Hippotherus, Haspirur, Pinsir, Riesenzahn, Professor, Antiquas, Vitalität.
Ich hab hier eine.
Suizune.
Die ist ganz interessant. Zum einen, die hat nur am Rand Holo.
Ja.
Und sie heißt stellvertretend für sehr viele Dummimsel.
Ja. Die mit dem Rand Holo, das ist ja eine, ich glaub, das heißt Reverse Holo.
Ja.
Thierry Rubeire, Hasbiro, Benasaro und noch eine Energy-Karte. Ich glaub, das war jetzt kein gutes Paket.
Nee. Shaomin, Shymin, Kroldra, Hundemon. Zwirrlicht.
Also keine Nachthara dabei.
Eine Donnersichel, das sieht auch gut aus.
Die ist auch Holo. Die ist auch Holo. Also es hat sich glaube ich nicht so ganz gelohnt, das Investment von 30 Euro, aber wir haben mal wieder damit für mehr Verknappung gesorgt, was natürlich im Ganzen die Preise steigern lässt.
Ja, du hast jetzt welche weggekauft.
Ich hab welche weggekauft, hab also jetzt teilgenommen an diesem Börsensport.
Wir hatten noch keine dabei, die heute als knapp gilt. Aber woher weißt du, was nächste Woche ist?
Eben. Da kann natürlich, also wir werden sie hüten.
Guck mal, wie ich die Packung ausgemacht hab. Weißt du noch früher, als man den Weihnachtsmann aufgemacht hat und danach das Papier so glatt gestrichen, um zu gucken, es ist unverletzt geblieben.
Ja toll.
Vielleicht können wir aus dem Ding noch was rausholen.
Ja.
Und jetzt ganz ohne Quatsch. Wir haben die im Neue-Zwanziger-Podcast aufgemacht. Allein das.
Wir könnten sie vielleicht signieren und dann hat man als Authentifizierung, dass wir die hier geöffnet haben. Das ist eigentlich das große Ding.
Das ist das große Ding für März.
Dann versuchen wir, wir werden jetzt immer Karten öffnen. Oder wir können ja vielleicht auch so ein Kartenprogramm anbieten für unsere Bundestagsabgeordneten.
Das ist das Rookie-Deck. Das erste Deck, das Wolfgang aufgemacht hat im Podcast.
Das stimmt, ja. Das ist eigentlich wertvoller als die Nacht-Tara.
Wir schneiden nachher ein Stück von deinem Anzug ab. Kleben das da drauf.
Ja.
Dann packen wir das in den Toploader.
Ja, der Toploader. Wir haben ja noch ganz viel hier.
Und dann fahren wir nach Dubai und machen neues Business.
Und erzählen von dort aus, wie scheiße Deutschland ist. Das ist also die neue Idee. Ja, also diese Wirtschaftswelt ist eine, wo man jetzt fragen kann, naja, aber wie dominant ist sie? Dieser eben genannte Logan Paul, der die teuerste Pokémon-Karte besitzt, war natürlich auch eingeladen auf der Inauguration von Donald Trump. Die neue Populärkultur von Trump ist die, solche Kerzchen zu sammeln bedeutet, irgendwelche alten Baseballschläge an die Wand zu hängen, bedeutet auch, das kann man in dieser goldenen Doku sehen, wir müssen das überlegen, das blendet nicht, das ist alles so schimmernd, dass man das Haus, in dem der Pate gedreht wurde, kauft, um dort dann irgendwelche Hochzeiten abzufeiern.
Okay.
Ja, das ist die Situation, in der wir uns befinden. Das ist also die virtuelle und digitale Welt. Wir raten davon nochmal ganz ausdrücklich ab, auf diesen Hype aufzuspringen. Aber wir sehen gerade, dass das etwas ist, was sich in den Köpfen so festhält. Und das zeigt natürlich auch sehr viel darüber, dass wir im Prinzip nicht mehr ein Glauben haben an eine Leistungsgesellschaft oder so etwas, sondern es ist eigentlich eine Gamble-Gesellschaft, in der man darüber nachdenkt, wie könnte ich es auch noch schaffen, meinen Arsch zu retten?
Ja, absolut.
Ob mit Krypto, mit der Karte oder eine Sportwette, mal sehen.
Ja, das ist die Anlage für den Tag X. Ja.
Wir wollen aber noch zu etwas tatsächlich sehr materiellem gehen, nämlich du hast vielleicht mitbekommen, was in Südafrika passiert ist. Man konnte es erfahren, es ist in den Medien vorgekommen. Wir hören erstmal von der BBC, einen Ausschnitt, den ich mal unkommentiert erst abspiele.
Es gibt hier eine riesige Polizei-
und Militärpreisung.
Im Prinzip, wie ich zu dir gesprochen habe, ist der Minister der Polizei gerade auf der Bühne gekommen. Und was wir vorhin gesehen haben, ist, dass ein Grupp von etwa 150 Volunteeren hier gekommen sind und sie wurden vor dem Untergrund durch die Polizei gesucht.
Das ist ein BBC-Beitrag aus dem November. Wir hören, da sind irgendwelche Leute in Minen. Es ist unklar, wen sie da rausholen. Freiwillige machen das interessanterweise. Sind ja welche in die Minen gefallen. Wir hören nochmal diesen Beitrag jetzt weiter von BBC.
Aber weil es da schon mal Ziele gibt, die unter dem Boden geschehen sind, gibt es auch noch Gangs, sehr arme Gangs mit hohen Kaliberwaffen, die unter dem Boden auch operieren. Das Regierung versucht hat, das zu schließen und alle ungeheiligen Minenstaffen zu schließen, so dass niemand unter dem Boden geht, weil es nicht nur ungesichert ist, sondern auch das Fakt, dass es so viele Töne zwischen Rivalgangs gibt, die unter dem Boden geschehen sind, das ist auch das, was die Autoritäten für sich interessiert.
Noch immer ist die Lage unübersichtlich. Wir sind also im November, springen jetzt aber in den Januar und hören die ZDF-Nachrichten.
Ein Hilferuf aus zwei Kilometern Tiefe. Ein Hindi-Video zeigt verzweifelte Bergleute unter Tage. Seit November sollen sie nicht genügend Nahrung und Wasser erhalten haben. Viele Männer haben das nicht überlebt. Sie haben sich von Zahnpasta ernährt, von Kakalang.
Manche waren wohl so verzweifelt, dass sie Leichenteile gegessen haben.
Die illegalen Bergleute in Südafrika nennt man sie die Sama-Samas, was so viel heißt wie die, die das Glück suchen. Seit Montag läuft in Silfonte in einer Rettungsaktion. Ein Kran bringt die Sama-Samas ans Tageslicht. Dutzende Leichen werden geborgen. Die südafrikanischen Behörden gehen seit Monaten hart gegen den illegalen Bergbau im Land vor. Sie haben Ein- und Ausgänge verschiedener Minen dichtgemacht und die Bergleute von der Lebensmittelversorgung abgeschnitten, um sie so zu zwingen, wieder ans Tageslicht zu kommen. Die Lage war wochenlang bekannt. Menschenrechtler kritisierten die südafrikanische Regierung massiv. Die Polizei weist jede Schuld von sich.
Wir haben nie irgendwelche Schächte blockiert oder jemanden daran gehindert, rauszukommen.
Wenn wir aber diesen Menschen Nahrung, Wasser und andere lebensnotwendige Dinge zur Verfügung stellen würden, dann würde die Polizei damit Kriminalität bestarken. In der vergangenen Woche verpflichtete ein Gericht, die Behörden sofort mit der Rettung der Bergleute zu beginnen. Für viele kam das zu spät.
Das Gambling jetzt noch mal in einer ganz anderen, sehr tödlichen Dimension. Also wir sind in Südafrika, dem ungleichsten Land der Welt, mit enormen Reichtümern, mit enormer Armut und Arbeitslosigkeit. Arbeitslosenquote bei über 30 Prozent, bei jungen Menschen über 40 Prozent. Südafrika lebte sehr stark davon, dass es dort Minen gab, in denen man beispielsweise Gold schufte. Goldminen gab es sehr viele. Es gibt inzwischen aber 6.000 stillgelegte Minen, in denen findet sich aber hier und da noch etwas. Und wir sind da in einer Situation, in der jetzt die, die arbeitslos sind und sehr viele, die aus dem Ausland illegal dort einwandern, durch irgendwelche Syndikaten darüber gepackt werden, in diesen Minen arbeiten und die sehr rechte Regierung in Südafrika hat diesen jetzt den Kampf angesagt. Und es gab eben diesen Fall dort in dieser Mine, von der da die Rede ist, wo dann viele dutzende Tote herausgeschafft wurden, dass man sagte, wir geben denen jetzt keine Nahrungsmittel mehr, wir räuchern die aus. So war die wirkliche Formulierung da. Und man hatte also dort Menschen verrecken lassen, weil man sagte, wir greifen jetzt hart durch, damit diese illegalen Minenarbeiten aufhören. Das ist die Situation.
Aber die Minen wurden aus wirtschaftlichen Gründen stillgelegt. Also da gibt es nicht wirklich mehr was zu holen.
Das sind... Ja, also es sind schon wirtschaftliche Gründe, insofern als man sagen kann, die Gewerkschaften haben es auch geschafft, höhere Löhne durchzusetzen. Und in den 90er Jahren schon, sie haben dort natürlich auch dafür gesorgt, dass gewisse Sicherheitsstandards und so weiter eingehalten werden müssen. Und haben dadurch natürlich auch dieses Mining teuer gemacht, sodass dann irgendwann die Frage ist, lohnt sich das noch? Und Südafrika hat da auch für sich einen anderen politischen Weg, wirtschaftspolitischen Weg gehen wollen. Und dadurch hat man also ja immer noch sehr viel da im Boden. Aber die Frage ist, wie attraktiv man das da sichern kann. Und wenn da gewisse politische Interessen nicht mehr mit dabei sind, dann ist das schwierig, es sei dann, da setzt sich so etwas illegal durch. BBC Reuters hat dann auch darüber berichtet. Wir hören da nochmal etwas zu.
Etwa 78 Menschen sind gestorben, in dem eine lokale Union das als die, die schlechteste staatliche Massakreinheit seit dem Ende des Apartheits beschrieben hat. Reden wir von seinem Schiff nach Hause in Kuma, nicht weit von Stilfontein, hat Meletzi die berühmte Situation im Boden erinnert.
Meletzi hat sich mit den Reuters besprochen, aber er hat ihn für seine Sicherheit verabschieden.
Er hat sich zu seinem Namen verabschieden.
Ich bin alleine am Abend. Normalerweise sehe ich viele Töne und dann schreie ich. Und ich glaube nicht, dass ich noch lebendig bin.
Er sagt, dass ohne Essen die Miner mit Kockrocken und sogar toten Körpern versuchten, obwohl Reuters diese Klampe nicht einzigartig verifizieren konnte.
Man hat also dort weiter nach Gold gesucht. Wohin geht das Gold? In die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate meistens. Dort wird es dann umdeklariert und kann möglicherweise auch an unseren Händen sein, wenn wir einen goldenen Ring tragen. Also das ist nicht etwas, was in der Illegalität bleibt. Nein, ich trage keinen Gold.
Das hat auch mit Gold nichts zu tun eigentlich.
Ich habe auch darüber nachgedacht, ob ich irgendwas mit Gold habe. Ich glaube nicht. Das, naja, jedenfalls ist Gold ja verbreitet, wie wir wissen. In dieser Mine waren zwei bis viertausend Menschen, so genau kann man das gar nicht sagen, beschäftigt. Diese Menschen sind dann bis zu einem kompletten Jahr oder sogar manchmal zwei Jahre unter Tage, kommen gar nicht raus, werden nur von künstlichem Licht bestrahlt, sind dort einfach drin, werden eingefärcht, werden in Käfigen darunter geschickt. Vielleicht haben manche mal von Emisolage Aminal gelesen, so und etwa, nur noch mal krasser, weil diese Minen natürlich von kriminellen Syndikaten überwacht werden und du musst zum Beispiel auch Geld zahlen, wenn du wieder raus willst. Das heißt, du musst also schon etwas gefunden haben an Gold, um wieder hoch verlassen werden zu können. In einem solchen System, wir haben mal über Handy-Spiele gesprochen, wie man da so Miner-Arbeiter irgendwo hinschicken kann. Die Eidl Games, im Prinzip ist das die bittere Realität, von der wir da stehen. Die Deutsche Welle hat dieses Thema auch aufgegriffen.
Illegal mining, wir wissen, ist ein Verbrechen in Südafrika. Aber unsere Menschen sind in Poverty gestartet. Die hohe Anzahl von Unbearbeitungen in den Norden, in der ganzen Lande. Das ist sehr beigetragen und sehr beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe beinahe Wir hören, dass die Menschen permanent und legal beteiligt werden können, damit es keine illegalen Aktivitäten gibt. Man muss es verstehen, meine Damen und Herren, die meisten afrikanischen Brüder kamen lange vor, um hier zu arbeiten. Sie haben dort gegründet, warum die Gegründer noch arbeiten. Aber jetzt, das einzige, was sie verstehen, ist die Gegründung. Also ist es sehr wichtig für unser Regierung, damit sie diese illegalen Gegründungen behalten können. Um uns die Rechte zu geben, um uns die Gemeinderechte zu geben, damit wir mit dem Gold produzieren können. Es kann Text werden, aber am Ende des Tages werden die Leute ihre Familien füllen können.
Als man die Minen schloss, hat man sich nicht um die Leute gekümmert, die alle arbeitslos sind. Es ist der pure Hunger, der die Leute in die Minen treibt.
Nein, lass mich das Statement beantworten. Das ist keine Ausdrucksweise, dass die Leute illegal unter der Erde gehen, wegen des Hunger. Es ist ein wirkliches Faktor eines Meters. Wenn du zu Kuma kommen kannst, Kuma war einmal eine Minenstadt, aber jetzt ist es ein Geiststown. Siehst du, wir hatten viele Firmen, diese Leute, sie haben unsere Stadt gegründet, sie haben unsere Location gegründet, Von dort kommt nichts. Also wenn immer der Hunger, der Schwierigkeit schlägt, musst du als Familie, als Familie-Mann, zu sehen, wie es geht. Weil wenn du das so gesagt hast, mein Bruder, wenn du das so gesagt hast, dann wird niemand da rausgehen und sein Leben riskieren. Diese Situation ist sehr gefährlich. Aber aufgrund des Hungeres, mussten sie da hin, um ihre Familien zu vergeben.
Man hat jetzt in dieser Situation, wo die Minenarbeiter in dieser einen Mine waren, Die man dann aufgespürt hatte, wusste, dass die da sind, sich gesagt, wir lassen sie nicht raus. Und das ist natürlich eine Verletzung der Menschenrechte sondergleichen. Und man beruft sich dann einfach darauf, dass man sagt, ja, aber wir bekämpfen ja Illegalität.
Ja.
Also das ist am Ende die Spitze der Entwicklung, die auf den Bizepswirts regeln. Ja. Hier gibt es keine Gesellschaft. Geh dahin, wo du dich auskennst, dann geht man da unter Tagun und hängt man halt. Ja.
Und dann noch mal die, die aus dem Ausland kommen, sind noch mal schlechter gestellt. Also auch da hat man natürlich wieder eine rassistische Komponente drin, in der Weise, dass man unterscheidet den wir und die anderen und die Illegalen aus den angrenzenden Ländern kommen nach Südafrika und beuten unseren Boden hier aus. Dass das natürlich alles Grundlage von strukturelleren Problemen ist, die man angehen müsste, wird dann einfach weg ignoriert und man sagt lieber, jetzt müssen wir mit harter Hand vorgehen. Nochmal die deutsche Welle.
Aber was du von den Mining-Kommunikationen hast, wo das passiert ist, die sagen, die meisten sagen, ja klar, das ist gegen die法, aber wenn du es ausnehmen, wenn du es von uns ausnehmen, siehst du diese Miningen, du verlassen die Kommunen ohne andere Grund für das Leben. Wie sonst erwarten wir sie zu leben, außer mit der Verabschiedung von Verbrechen. Das ist der Argument, den wir von den meisten Mitgliedern hören. Aber sie geben uns eine Lösung gleichzeitig. Denn wenn Sie diese Mittel nehmen, die illegal sind, die sie nutzen, um zu überleben, und in den meisten von diesen Mitgliedern sagen, ist es der einzige Weg raus. Und der Staatsminister hat auch zu einer gewissen extent einig.
Die Menschen, die da leiden und sterben, spielen keine Rolle. Es geht hier nur um wirtschaftliche Kosten und letztlich um das BIP.
Das ist jetzt BBC. Es ist nicht unbedingt in ihrem Gefecht. Viele Menschen sehen sie als Kriminelle. Sie sagen, was sie getan haben, ist illegal. Und deshalb gibt es nicht besonders viel öffentliche Sympathie für sie. Ich meine, der Minister für Mineral-Ressourcen sprach heute zur Presse außerhalb der Mäne und er sagt, dass diese illegalen Mineren die Südafrikanische Wirtschaft kostet. 60 Billionen, letztes Jahr, 60 Billionen Rand. Also, weil sie als Kriminelle gesehen sind und weil sie als von der Wirtschaft ausgenommen werden, statt sie hinzuzuwenden, gibt es keine große Anzahl von Sympathien für sie. Und dann gibt es die zusätzliche Komplikation, dass viele dieser Mineren in Südafrika illegal sind. Sie kommen aus nebren Ländern, Ländern wie Zimbabwe, Mosambik, deren Wirtschaften sehr schlecht sind. Also, Sympathie für sie ist nicht groß, aber die Rechtsgruppen sagen, dass sie, egal ob es Kriminelle sind oder sogar illegale Migranten, sie sollten früher gerettet werden.
Und der Bergbauminister hat dann neben den Leichen stehend gesagt, das sind Kriminelle und die führen einen Krieg gegen Südafrikas Wirtschaft. Und damit ist das alles gerechtfertigt. Wenn man jetzt sich fragt, wer ist da genau unter Tage, dann bekommen wir von Bloomberg eine Antwort.
Und das passiert auf einigen Niveaus, weil ich denke, der erste Punkt des Kontexts ist, dass es um alte Minerinnen und Miner, die selbst ein Teil dieser Minen waren, als sie aktiv und lizenziert waren und so weiter. Und also haben sie einen guten Sinn, wie die Dinge unter sich sind. Sie wissen, wo die Sektionen der Schafe sind, wo sie die meisten Mineralien von bekommen. Und also denke ich, das ist die erste Kategorie der Miner, die wir sehen. Man hat diese massiven, übergewaltigen, kriminellen Syndikaten, die sich hierin beteiligt haben. Und ihre Operationen sind extrem, sie sind sehr arm, sie sind sehr gefährlich. Man findet in diesen Gemeinden, wo es diese verlassenen Minds gibt, und es gibt diese Aktivität, besonders wo es diese Syndikaten beteiligen. Wir haben auch Horrorstorys von massiven Verbrechen von Frauen gehört, von extremen Verbrechen, das geschieht in den Häusern der Menschen als Ausdruck von diesen Syndikaten. Das andere Teil davon. Und wir werden das ein bisschen später darüber sprechen, als wir über die Menschen reden, die von der Schafe hervorgekommen sind, ist, dass es ein Element ist, das zum Menschenverkauf hervorgehen ist, wo man Leute aus neigenderen Ländern sieht, Malaoui, Mozambique in particular, die sich vielleicht von einem Relativ beobachten, hey, so und so ist es in Südafrika, geh und bleib mit ihnen für eine Weile, sie haben eine wirklich gute Möglichkeit für dich. Sie machen ihren Weg über die Bordern, meistens in der Zeit unvergleichbar. Sie haben gesagt, dass sie unter die Bordern gehen müssen und für dieses Gold und andere preisreiche Messen gegründet werden. Und sie sind grundsätzlich für sich verheiratet, sie sind gegen ihre Wille, sie dürfen nicht ausgehen und ihre Leben werden von diesen Syndikaten ausgeruht.
Ja, da hat der Staat noch eine Aufgabe. Sich um diese Grenze über Dritte zu kümmern.
Ja. Und dieses Gold landet wie schon gesagt den Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten oft und geht von da aus weiter. Man hat auch, und da schmerzt mich natürlich sehr, dass ich ja ein Fan dieses Landes bin, einen Weg, der dann in die Schweiz führt, in der Schweiz. Und da sind wir wieder bei so etwas wie dem Lieferkettengesetz. In der Schweiz ist es so, dass der Herkunftsort des Goldes nicht der Ort ist, wo das Gold dann tatsächlich aus der Miene geholt wurde, sondern der letzte Ort von dieser langen Lieferkette ist einfach dann der Ort, von dem das Gold herstammt. Italien. Wenn die das dann aus den Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten haben, dann ist das offenbar daher. Stimmt dann auch nicht, ist dann aus Südafrika.
Also typischerweise ist das so, dass wir Gold als Währung verstehen, wenn auch im Spezialfall so als Reservewährung oder so. Und das Prinzip einer Währung ist, dass sie gilt unabhängig davon, wo sie herkommt.
Ja.
Man kann da noch Labels verteilen, aber solange es Ungerechtigkeit auf der Welt gibt, in dieser Form, die mit der Schürfung von Gold zu tun hat, ist Gold grundsätzlich der Gefahr ausgeliefert, dass du als Goldkäufer da mit deinen Fingern im Spiel hast. Ja.
Und es sagt natürlich sehr viel aus über unseren globalen Kapitalismus. Und es gibt einen Artikel aus dem New Yorker von 2023, der heißt The Dystopian Underworld of South Africa's Illegal Gold Mines, den ich sehr empfehlen kann. Der ist etwa 15, den er vier Seiten lang, dieser Artikel. Den werde ich also jetzt nicht komplett vorlesen können, aber wir müssen uns ein paar Impressionen doch verschaffen, wie es da aussieht. Es wird dann beschrieben. Die Kamera sinkt mit fünf Fuß pro Sekunde. Bei etwa 800 Fuß erscheinen in der Ferne bewegliche Figuren, die sich mit fast der gleichen Geschwindigkeit nach unten bewegen. Es sind zwei Männer, die an den Trägern hinunter gleiten. Sie tragen weder Helme noch Seile und ihre Unterarme sind durch abgesägte Gummistiefel geschützt. Die Kamera fährt weiter hinunter und lässt die Männer in der Dunkelheit zurück. Um die horizontalen Balken unter ihnen auf 600 Fuß sind Leichen gewunden. Die Überreste von Männern, die in den Tod gestürzt oder vielleicht geworfen worden sind. Das untere Drittel des Schachs ist stark beschädigt, so dass die Kamera nicht weiter vordringen kann. Wenn es noch weitere Leichen gibt, werden sie vielleicht nie gefunden werden. Als die Bergbauindustrie in Wellcome in den 90er Jahren zusammenbrach, entstand an ihrer Stelle eine dystopische kriminelle Wirtschaft, in der Tausende von Männern in die verlassenen Stollen eindrangen und mit rudimentären Werkzeugen nach dem verbliebenen Erzgruben. Da es kaum Gemeinkosten oder Sicherheitsstandards gab, konnten diese illegalen Bergleute in einigen Fällen reich werden. Viele andere blieben in Armut und starben unter Tage. Also das ist genau dieses Survival of the fittest, das sich dann da in dem scheußlichsten Ausmaß zeigt. Der Journalist spricht mit einem Sama-Sama, Simon heißt er. Er fing an an der Oberfläche nach Gold zu graben, 2010, die mit Erzen aus der Blütezeit der Industrie übersät war. Es gab Gold neben den Eisenbahnschienen, die einst das Gestein aus den Minen transportiert hatten. Gold zwischen den Fundamenten der abgerissenen Verarbeitungsanlagen, Gold in den Betten der vergänglichen Bäche. Aber Simon verdiente nur etwa 35 Dollar pro Tag. Er strebte danach, ein Haus zu bauen und ein Geschäft zu eröffnen. Also genau dieser durch ihr Traum Eigenheim Businessman werden. Um Geld, um Gold zu bekommen, müsste er unter die Erde gehen. Das tut er dann auch und zwar geht er unter die Erde in der Hoffnung dort auf entsprechende Reichtümer zu treffen. Wir werden ihn dann gleich wiederfinden in diesem Artikel. Es ist so, dass diese Geschäfte, die dort gemacht werden im Untergrund, alle kontrolliert werden von Syndikaten aus Südafrika oder aus angrenzenden Ländern. Man kann sagen, steht hier in dem Artikel, dass jede Handyplatine, jede Anlagemünze und eigentlich auch jeder Ehering von diesen Sama-Samas sein. Simon taucht dann wieder auf. Das Syndikat verlangte von Simon mehr als das Doppelte für die Ausfahrt aus den Minen. Er blieb fast ein Jahr lang unter der Erde und ernährte sich von den Lebensmitteln, dem ihm die Läufer zur Verfügung stellten. Zu diesen Läufern kommen wir gleich. Als er mit zu wenig Geld zurückkam, ging er wieder in die Minen und bezahlte dasselbe Syndikat dafür, dass sie im Seil ihn wieder herunterließen. Er gewöhnte sich an das Leben unter Tage, die Hitze, den Staub, die Dunkelheit. Er hatte fort dort zu bleiben, bis er nicht mehr arm war. Aber am Ende kam er heraus, weil er hungerte. Es gab also eine sehr lange Geschichte dieses Untergangs dieser Goldminen oder warum die sich nicht mehr rentiert haben. Wir lassen das mal alles aus dem vor und konzentrieren uns auf David Comby, auch One Eye genannt, weil er ein Auge weggeschossen bekam in einer Auseinandersetzung da. David Comby. Er trug eine weiße Weste, zerschlissene abgeschnittene Jeans und Flip-Flops. Comby lebte auf dem Gelände, wo er sein Einkommen durch Haareschneiden, Ausbessern von Schuhen und Schneidern von Mozambikanischer Kleidung ausbesserte. Nicht lange nach der Verhaftung wurde er freigelassen und tauchte in den Untergrund ab, wo er ein kleines Vermögen verdiente, wie mir ein ehemaliges Mitglied seines engeren Kreises mitteilte. Einem Experten für den illegalen Goldhandel zur Folge soll Comby 2008 begonnen haben, sein Imperium aufzubauen. Er hat eine Pyramidenstruktur dann aufgebaut, die wirklich erstaunlich ist. Womit hat dieser David Comby sein großes Geld verdient? Erstmal nicht mit Gold, sondern mit Lebensmittel. Die Versorgung von Tausenden von Zamas-Samas unter Tage ist eine komplexe und lukrative logistische Aufgabe. Zunächst kauften viele illegalen Bergleute Lebensmittel von legalen Minenarbeitern, die ihre Rationen zu überhöhten Preisen verkauften. Also auch da noch mal Klassenkampf unter den Arbeitenden. Doch als die, also das ist so ein bisschen so, wir haben die Leute, die eine Tarifbindung haben und die, die keine haben und die stehen aber noch nebeneinander im Werk.
Ohne Personalakte im Werkvertrag.
Das ist noch 90er Jahre, dann sind die, die die Tarifbindung haben, spielen keine Rolle mehr, weil das viel zu teuer wäre mit denen, also schließt man eigentlich die Minen. Doch als die Minenarbeiter entlassen wurden und die Zahl der Sama-Samas zunahm, begannen die Syndikate Lebensmittel direkt zu liefern. Es entwickelte sich eine neue Wirtschaft, die sogar noch profitabler sein konnte als Gold. Die Männer unter Tage hatten nur eine geringe Verhandlungsmacht, die Preisaufschläge für Lebensmittel betrugen in der Regel zwischen 500 und 1000 Prozent.
Zigaretten, Waschpulver, alles Mögliche konnte man nicht kaufen. Sie bezahlten mit dem Gold, das sie verdient haben. Kombi hat dann Männer dafür bezahlt, dass sie bei Großhändlern direkt einkaufen. Die waren dann umverpackt in Luftpolsterfolie und so weiter. Und die Einnahmen stiegen dann entsprechend für Kombi. Und er begann auch das Gold von den Sama-Samas dann zu kaufen. Er baute dann ein sehr großes Haus und tat sich als Philantrop hervor, der die Menschen unterstützen will und eigentlich nur Gutes will. Zugleich musste dieser Kombi aber Schutzgebühren auch zahlen, an die Banden, an die Maraschea heißen die, die diese Minen bewachen. Also auch die haben wieder eine eigene Wirtschaft darum gebaut. Das funktionierte aber sehr gut. Diese Banden haben auch so eine eigene Kultur hervorgebracht. Die kamen immer an mit Akkordeonspieler, die dann auch heroische Lieder schrieben auf die Banden und so weiter. Und Kombi selbst fing dann an, auf Instagram seinen Lebensstil zu posten. Mit schicken Autos, einer hübschen Frau, immer die besten italienischen Anzüge trug er. Und so ging das immer weiter und weiter, bis dieser Mann dann irgendwann vor Gericht kam, weil er in ein Mord verwickelt ist und dann auch des Mordes schuldig gesprochen wurde. Was wir also hieran sehen können ist, dass wir zwar zum einen in einer Welt leben, in der wir so eine Virtualität haben, wir haben nur noch mit Sammelkarten und so weiter zu tun. Zugleich ist diese Materialität, die dann bis hin zu unseren Handys vorhanden ist, eine, die genau solche Ausbeutungsverhältnisse hervorbringt, bei denen man einfach so achsezuckend sagt, ja, das scheint wohl jetzt so zu sein, das gibt es da, es wird mal kurz gemeldet im Fernsehen. Wenn man Glück hat, hat man es mitbekommen. Und das war es dann wieder. Aber es zeigte eigentlich sich in dieser Struktur, wo immer noch ein Business und noch ein Business an etwas drankommt, etwas so grundsätzliches daran, dass also diese Verhältnisse, die da sind, die zunächst mal nur Wirtschaftsverhältnisse sind, das ist einfach nur kompetitiv oder so könnte man sagen, dass diese von Gewalt durchzogen sind. Und das haben eigentlich so Leute wie Haus und Hopf und diese ganzen Rechten in einer Klarheit begriffen, wie das viele aus dem liberalen Spektrum gar nicht sehen wollen, weil die natürlich immer sagen, ja, aber die soziale Marktwirtschaft und so weiter. Ja, es gibt natürlich Rahmensetzungen, die vieles verhindern, aber dass eigentlich dann doch, wenn es hart auf hart kommt, genau der Kampf wieder dahin zurückgeht, dass es da wirklich ein gegenseitiges Erschießen gibt, ein Fressen und Gefressen werden, dass das ist, was da eigentlich alles strukturiert, zeigt in größter Transparenz das, was jetzt von den anderen mit netteren Worten nur beschrieben wird, mit Wettbewerb und wir wollen auch keine Gesellschaft, in der es nur noch Teilnehmerurkunden gibt.
Hoss und Hopf lieben ja das Land, meinen die Bevölkerung und sie hassen den Staat. Und das ist ganz interessant, weil hier kann man dann auch nachhören, wie die, also es ist einfach nur noch paradox ist, dass man auf der einen Seite einen Podcast macht, der die ganze Zeit über den Staat abhated, insbesondere weil er dir Geld wegnimmt. Dann passiert aber etwas, deine Nachbarschaft brennt ab wie in Los Angeles und plötzlich heißt es, der Staat hat nur eine Aufgabe, uns zu schützen, wo waren denn die Feuerwehrleute und so weiter. Also die pendeln immer so hin und her, wie es ihnen gerade gefällt. Aber der Staat kommt immer schlecht weg, entweder weil er dir alles nimmt oder weil er dir keinen Schutz gibt. Und diese Reduktion auf, nee, der Staat soll nur noch regeln, damit wir ja und dann Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Migration, Grenze, Bevölkerung, Volk, also die anderen, wir. Und ja, März hat dieses Spiel mitgespielt. Bist du, weil da sind noch drei Clips, die du aber...
Ich bin im Prinzip durch damit, denn ich glaube die Sache ist verstanden. Ich empfehle noch mal sehr diesen Bericht im New Yorker oder diese Reportage im New Yorker zu lesen, weil sie uns über unsere globalen Ausbildungsverhältnisse wahnsinnig viel erzählt. Und wenn Leute mit kompetitiven Sachen kommen, dann muss man ihnen mal sagen, ja genau, wie da in der Mine in Südafrika, lest es euch einfach mal durch.
Und es ist ja wirklich genau wie dieses Computerspiel. Nur das sieht halt schön aus, ist ja so bunt und gezeichnet und da...
Aber man schickt da ja Minen, einer für sich rein, die für einen arbeiten und kann wiederum Manager einstellen, die für sich was tun. Also es wird ja immer noch so etwas angedockt. Also es gibt immer noch eine weitere Möglichkeit. Und diese Einführung von Intermediären, das ist ja eigentlich das Interessante, dass ja sehr viele dieser Libertären und Rechten kämpfen ja, und das macht sie ja dann manchmal so sympathisch für viele, die da gar nicht ideologisch mit einer Meinung sind, gegen vorhandene Intermediäre. Die sagen, das finde ich aber scheiße, warum muss denn eigentlich da immer noch ein Sender was beschließen? Warum muss denn da noch der dazwischen geschaltet werden?
Kann man das nicht einfach versteigern?
Können wir das nicht so, können wir das nicht einfach so machen, genau. Und dann bauen sie aber natürlich, sobald sie die Macht haben, wieder neue Intermediäre auf. Das ist ja das Interessante, also warum brauche ich jetzt noch eine Plattform von Logan Paul, um meine Kärtchen zu verkaufen? Warum muss er jetzt ein neuer Intermediär werden, den ich mit meinem Geld dann unterstütze, der sich auch mal noch was einhält?
Ja.
Paypal ist ja auch ein Intermediär, der mit jeder Zahlung nochmal extra verdient und dadurch ist Elon Musk reich geworden. Also diese ganzen Intermediäre und diejenigen, die dagegen kämpfen, das ist nur immer jeweils die andere Seite derselben Medaille.
Jede Bauernregel, insbesondere die, die uns besonders plausibel erscheinen, gibt es auch mit umgedrehten Vorzeichen.
Ja.
Und wenn wir die hören, ist es genauso plausibel.
Es war ja auch so amüsant, das ist ja das bei dem, die sagen jetzt zum einen, die sind gegen Free Speech und gegen Volker-Meinungs-Zensur.
Also erst mal die Beers abschaffen.
Und dann würde ich erstmal sagen, ja, ich bin auch gegen Zensur, ich bin für Free Speech, aha, dann bin ich also bei denen. Dann sind die aber zugleich für Zensur, wenn es dann darum geht, irgendwelche linken Meinungen zu beschneiden. Oder ja auch interessant bei Twitter war das ja zu erleben, dass als dieser TikTok-Bannen, Kurz-Bannen, wie man das nennen möchte, kam, Selbst-Bannen. Dann, Selbst-Bannen müsste man es eigentlich nennen, Ulf Poschert sagte, dass er sehr dafür ist, TikTok zu verbannen. Also da dann plötzlich nicht mehr Free Speech. Das ist dann nicht gut.
Ja, ihr Verhältnis zu China müssen sie eh noch strukturieren, alle. Ja gut, ich möchte eine Wahlempfehlung abgeben, weil es steht ja eine Wahl an und wir haben heute schon ausführlich darüber gesprochen, was zur Wahl steht.
Das hatten wir noch nie, dass hier eine Wahlempfehlung ausgesprochen.
No, aber es hat ja auch erst eine Bundestagswahl bisher statt.
Und eine Europawahl.
Hatten wir auch schon.
Ja, aber ich bin natürlich getriggert. Ich habe jetzt Horst und Hopf gehört und ich werde die Vorzeichen umdrehen. Bei Horst und Hopf klingt es ja so. Wie immer Leute, wir geben hier keine Wahlempfehlung raus. Ihr wählt nachher, was ihr für richtig haltet. Das ist der einzige Weg, das ist der demokratische Weg. Ihr wählt, was ihr für richtig haltet und das wird nachher Konsequenzen geben. Diese Konsequenzen müssen wir alle tragen. So ist das Leben nun mal. Deswegen ist Eigenverantwortung und Selbstverantwortung so wichtig. Ja, so ist das Leben nun. Mit den Konsequenzen müssen wir leben und deswegen ist es ja so wichtig, dass wir unseren Bizeps stärken. Er vertieft es. Weder Kian noch ich haben uns jemals, auch wenn es uns schon oft als Vorwurf gemacht wurde, uns für eine Partei in diesem Land ausgesprochen. Weder Kian noch ich haben jemals gesagt, ich wähle die Partei A oder ich wähle die Partei B. Es wird weiterhin auszusehen. Wir nehmen hier, wir können auch unsere Meinungen kundtun und das ist auch wichtig, aber ich sage nicht, Leute ihr sollt das und das wählen. Ich wähle meine Partei, ich spreche aber auch nicht darüber, welche das ist. Ich habe eine Partei, durch die ich mich sehr gut vertreten fühle. Das ist meine Entscheidung, ihr trefft eure Entscheidung. Wir gehen das hier einfach nur ganz neutral durch und besprechen, was eben gesagt wurde. So, das wollte ich nur ganz kurz erwähnen. Rätselraten. Er hat eine Partei, die überzeugt wählt, aber er sagt uns nicht welche. Finden wir heraus, welche das ist? Anhand von zwei Clips, der eine von Hopp, der andere von Hoss. Fangen wir mal an. Also die sind alle so, also ja, du siehst einfach nur die Nerven liegen blank. Und das ist halt. Schau mal, ich sage, die eine Partei wie die AfD, die braucht keinen Elon Musk, um Werbung für sie zu machen. Denn das gesamte Land macht jeden Tag Werbung für die jetzt alleine an Silvester. Was glaubst du denn, für wen, wem das Zulauf gibt? Mehrere Tote, dutzende Verletzte, Bürgerkriegsähnliche Zustände, die von der Polizei exakt so benannt werden. Es ist ja nicht so, dass die Bürger das sagen, die Polizei sagt, nee, nee, das war gar nicht so. Nein, die Polizei, die sind alle überfordert, dutzende Verletzte, alles am Arsch. Nur noch du hast, wenn du die Interviews, was heißt Interviews, also so von mutigen Reportern, die da auf der Straße standen und dann kamen die Talerons und haben gesagt, Polizei hat hier nichts zu sagen, wir haben die Kontrolle. Ja, absolut korrekte Einschätzung der Situation, so ist es. Polizei hat nichts zu sagen, Talerons haben die Kontrolle. Und wundert sich da einer, wie das aktuell in den Umfragen aussieht. Also ich finde, das ist doch scheißegal, ob da Elon Musk da was sagt oder nicht. Der bestätigt nur das, was viele Leute denken. Und das ist eine Wahlwerbung nachher. Und wer hat diese Wahlwerbung zu verantworten? Die Leute, die diese ganzen hunderttausende Leute ins Land gelassen haben. Das ist doch eine ganz simple Sache. Also hast du eine Idee, wen er will?
Wir kommen wirklich gar nicht drauf. Also welche Partei könnte das wohl sein?
Wir hören jetzt Hoss, der uns noch eine, wie man heute Neudeutsch in der praktischen Politikwissenschaft eine Erlaubnisstruktur gibt. Also im Sinne von ja, AfD und ich weiß, die sagen die Leute, das geht nicht und so. Aber doch, vielleicht geht es doch. Denk nochmal drüber nach.
Am Ende sollte es doch allen Menschen nur darum geben, allen, dass die Gesellschaft vernünftig funktioniert, dass die Wirtschaft vernünftig funktioniert, dass es landsicher ist, dass man sich wohlfühlt. Und egal, wer das am Ende durchsetzt oder auch dafür spricht und wem man das auch irgendwo auch so ein bisschen abkaufen kann, weil er das nicht in Vergangenheit massiv missbraucht hat, den kann man doch mal wählen und dann gucken, was passiert. Wir haben doch eine Verfassung. Es ist doch nicht so, dass jemand gewählt wird und plötzlich keine Ahnung, das Land explodiert. Es wurden doch damals, als Hitler an die Macht gekommen ist, danach Maßnahmen unternommen, damit sowas nicht noch mal passieren kann.
Ja, da müsste ich jetzt auch noch mal drüber nachdenken. Wer konnte denn da jetzt?
So, jetzt hören wir AOC. Sie war im Podcast mit Jon Stewart, auch dann großes Publikum, 3-4 Millionen Abruf oder so allein bei YouTube. Und was ist jetzt zu tun? Es wird ja auch so ein bisschen bemängelt. Wo sind denn die Demokraten? Was passiert denn da? Und ich denke mir so ein bisschen, das hat jetzt alles Zeit. Also was wir nicht brauchen, ist jetzt Personal. Also ich brauche jetzt nicht Nancy Pelosi, die noch mal erzählt, dass Trumpa wirklich evil ist oder Chuck Schumer oder so, ne? Wir brauchen irgendwie etwas anderes. Sie geht erstmal auf diese neurechten Botschaften ein.
Wenn du auf die Art schaust, wie Putin in Russland gearbeitet hat, und die Art, wie sie sich in diesen Oligarchen, in diesen Kleptokristen, übernehmen, sie beten auf diese exakt, auf diese exakten Logiken, auf diese exakten Bedeutungen, was ist, dass alle korrupt sind und alle korrupt sind. Und also wer schenkt einen Scheiß?
Wie schäfst du dich?
Auf der einen Seite hast du keine Gerechtigkeit.
Und du kannst auch nur deinen schenken.
Ja, also jedes Mal, wenn Hopf da irgendwie in seinem Podcast sagt, kümmere dich um dich, halte dein Zimmer in Ordnung, geh ins Gym, liess mein Buch, ist das ja im Grunde die Botschaft. Gib auf! Hör auf Ansprüche zu stellen. Frag nicht nach dem Staat, frag nicht was der Staat für dich tun kann. Es wird keinen Staat geben. Kümmer dich um dich. Also man muss die Botschaft dann sozusagen übersetzen.
Eigentlich müsste im CDU-Programm auch stehen, wir haben ihnen nichts anzubieten. Wir könnten, wenn sie möchten, ihre rassistischen Ressentiments bedienen. Da hätten wir fünf Vorschläge, die wir auch ohne Kompromiss gerne umsetzen.
Mit dem Steuergeld wollen wir nicht, wir entlasten sie um 100 Milliarden Abgaben. Behalten sie ihr Geld.
Wenn sie aber nicht viel Geld haben, dann könnte sein, dass sie noch mal ein bisschen mehr zahlen müssen, um den Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland zu stützen und den Sozialstaat noch aufrechtzuhalten.
Jetzt könnte man ja sagen, gut wären jetzt tolle Personen mit super Programm. Also irgendwer aufstrebend kommt und sagt, ich habe die echten fünf Punkte, wie auch immer. Jetzt sagt AOC, nee jetzt mal Schritt für Schritt, es fehlt was anderes.
Was ist dann der Prozess des Redefinen, was dieses Partei ist, was es sich vorwärts beherrscht und sind es dort Leiter? Es ist sklerotisch. Ich meine, es ist ein Partei in echter Verrückung. Und ich weiß nicht, ich kann mein Finger nicht aufheben. Es erinnert mich an die Republikaner im Jahr 2012, wo es nur, wenn Trump in den ersten 2016 Primer kam, ich meine, er hat einfach seinen Finger nicht aufheben. Jeb Bush? Ja, schön, boom, fertig. Und ich denke, die Demokraten sind von diesem Punkt wundervoll. Also wie, was ist der Prozess des Redefinen und der Recapturierung, was dieses Partei ist?
Ich denke, wir brauchen eine echte Agenda. Wenn du gemerkt hast, dass die demokratische Partei nicht wirklich eine Plattform hat, mit irgendwelchen neuen...
Ich hab gemerkt.
Ja, es gibt keine Plattform. Ich meine, es gibt technisch eine Plattform, die gewählt wird. Das ist das Schlechteste. Wenn du einen armen Amerikaner oder einfach ein normaler Amerikaner fragst, was ist ein Demokrat? Was stehen sie für?
Ja, wir brauchen eine Agenda, ein Ziel. Kein ausformales Programm, sondern so eine Idee, die ja lauten könnte, Und ich würde sagen, der Staat könnte mal wieder für mich da sein, ohne dass ich jetzt bitte die Aufgabe der Politiker erledigen soll, in welcher Form, in welcher Höhe, wie viel Geld, für was und so weiter. Das können ja dann die Profis klären. Jetzt erstmal eine Agenda. Und damit ist nur eine Idee gemeint. So eine Agenda, von der man alle mal, nur Agenda ist jetzt ganz wichtig, keine Agenda haben, free of Agenda, free Agenda, wie es die ganzen Kanäle heißen. Einfach erstmal eine Idee in den Raum stellen, wie zum Beispiel der Staat könnte mal wieder für dich da sein. Irgendwer wird schon irgendwelche Ideen kommen und dann gibt es einen demokratischen Prozess, da stellt man sie gegenüber. Aber der Staat könnte mal prinzipiell wieder für dich da sein. Du musst die nicht als Feind begreifen, die Politiker als deine Gegner, wie auch immer, sondern sie tun mal etwas für dich. Fragen wir uns natürlich, hat das irgendeine deutsche Partei im Angebot? Wir grasen den Journalismus dazu ab, beginnend beim Deutschlandfunk. Dort gibt es einen Podcast, Der Tag. Nicht zu verwechseln mit der sehr guten Sendung, Das war der Tag. Also Deutschlandfunk Der Tag gibt einen Überblick über die Programme und Agendas der politischen Parteien, die zur Wahl stehen.
Dann kommen wir mal von den Entlastungen zu den Belastungen. Oder beziehungsweise Belastung klingt immer so negativ.
Belastung klingt immer so negativ. Das ist doch nicht gut, wenn es jetzt hier um Belastung geht.
Jedenfalls zu den Vorschlägen, einige Gruppen doch ein bisschen stärker ran zu ziehen. Die sind nicht so zahlreich, wenn ich mir ihre Tabelle angucke, aber es gibt ein paar. Stichwort Erbschafts- und Vermögenssteuer.
So, Stichwort Erbschafts- und Vermögenssteuer. Sie hat einen Gesprächspartner, der hat eine ganze Tabelle. Also alles, was zur Wahl steht. Sie gehen das jetzt mal durch.
Wagt sich daran und wie ambitioniert?
So richtig ambitioniert. Weiß nicht, ob da eine Partei sich wirklich zeigt. Aber was man sagen kann...
Da müsste man vielleicht doch noch mal in das Wahlprogramm der Linken reingucken, nehme ich an.
Das mag dann in der Tat sein.
Hat man irgendwie nicht gemacht.
Ach so, das wird man einfach mal ausverklammert.
Also ich habe so eine Tabelle, ich mach mal eine Analyse. Ja, also bei Erbschaftssteuer sollte man vielleicht doch noch mal bei den Linken reinschauen. Also was ist denn das bitte? Scheiß, das versteht doch niemand.
Wir müssen über innere Sicherheit reden. Wir können jetzt nicht anfangen mit Erbschaftssteuer.
Das Politikteil der Zeit. Sie reden auch über die Angebote der Parteien, zum Beispiel hier über das von BSW.
Okay, bleibt noch das BSW.
So im Sinne von bleibt noch, so als Letzte gucken wir jetzt mal bei der BSW.
Da sieht man immer Wagenknecht und dann zwei Slogans unser Land verdient mehr oder unser Land wünscht sich mehr und dann kommt Frieden, Rente, Wohnungen, Lehrer und Ärzte, weniger Migration und dann immer aber die alten Parteien haben versagt. Das ist fast noch aggressiver in Richtung der so genannten etablierten Parteien, oder?
Ich finde es vor allem interessant, wenn man es mit den Plakaten der Linken vergleicht. Die sind ja wirklich quasi schamlos, hemmungslos, linkspopulistisch. Wenn du zu viel Miete zahlst, dann ist das der Vermieter schuld. Wenn dein Einkauf zu teuer ist, dann bereichert sich ein Konzern. Also die wenden praktisch, das ist eine klassische Neidkampagne, die eben gegen den praktisch den, wie sagt man, den Antagonisten wenden.
Und warum ist die Zeit so blöde, das gibt es doch gar nicht. Also wer profitiert denn sonst von höheren Mieten außer der Vermieter? Das ist einfach nur, das ist ja nur Betriebswirtschaft. Also man kann jetzt sagen, ich möchte gerne, dass die Vermieter reich sind. Dann soll man das sagen, dann sagt das bei der Zeit. Sagt einfach, wir wollen Politik für die Vermieter, wir wollen, dass es den Vermietern gut geht, weil die unsere Zeitung für zu viel Geld immer noch abonnieren. Dann sagt das doch einfach. Aber das ist betriebswirtschaftliche Logik. Jeder würde so handeln. Jeder würde in einer betriebswirtschaftlichen Logik handeln. Und deswegen ist es auch gut, das auf das Plakat zu schreiben. Und wir haben gesehen, wie die Lebensmittelkonzerne und die Konzernchefs ihre Einnahmen, ihre Gewinne verdoppeln konnten in den vergangenen Jahren im Zuge der Inflation.
Wir haben ja den Text von Isabella Weber. Wir haben die Überschrift kritisiert, aber nicht den Inhalt. Es gab Preisschocks in den grundlegenden Energie- und Rohstoffversorgungen. Dieser wurde weitergegeben. Es gab eine Inflation im Supermarkt. Dann ging dieser Preisschock in den Energie- und Rohstoffen zurück. Die Preise sind einfach hochgeblieben. Ab jetzt Gewinnmarge. Genau. Also wenn ein Plakat hängt mit an deinem Einkauf im Supermarkt bereichert sich jemand. Ja. Und bei der Miete, es ist das einfache Vertragsverhältnis der Welt. Es gibt einen Vermieter und dann gibt es ein Mieter. Und die Sache ist mit drei Seiten BGB geregelt. Da kommt keine Kommune dazwischen, da kommt kein Land dazwischen. Das ist einfach nur, du machst eine Bundestagswahl. Das ist das einzige Gremium, dass du darüber entscheiden kann, was in Mietverträgen steht. Und dann gibt es einen Vermieter und einen Mieter. So. Und der Wähler ist nun auf einer dieser beiden Seiten.
Ja.
Und der Gewinn des einen ist der Verlust des anderen.
Also es ist eigentlich eins plus eins ist zwei.
Ja, das ist so eine Sache.
Es ist wirklich verrückt, wie diese beiden hier, Deutschlandfunk und die Zeit einfach, da gucken wir gar nicht hin. Und wenn wir hingucken, sehen wir nur Linkspopulismus und klassische Neiddebatte. Ja, das ist der T-Nord, der hier ist. In diesen großen Fragen, die wir jetzt bis hierhin heute geklärt haben, ist das die Antwort des Journalismus da. Ja. So, im Deutschlandfunk schiebt sie aber noch so einen Nachtrag hinterher. Ihr ist doch im Gespräch dann doch so ein kleiner, eigener Fehler im Handwerk aufgefallen.
Herr Hänze, ich danke Ihnen ganz, ganz herzlich für Ihre Analyse und dass Sie das mit uns geteilt haben. Vielen Dank.
Sehr gerne.
Und zwei Ergänzungen noch zu diesem Gespräch. Erstens waren ja Die Linke und das BSW nicht Teil der Analyse von Tobias Hänze.
Aber die BSW immerhin Teil des Gesprächs noch.
Aber damit die nicht unter den Tisch fallen, hab ich nochmal nachgeguckt. Also auch Die Linke verspricht in diesem Wahlkampf eine Reform der Einkommenssteuer. Da sollen grob alle, die weniger als 7.000 Euro brutto im Monat verdienen, weniger Steuern zahlen. Dafür soll der Spitzensteuersatz auf 53 Prozent steigen und Superreiche, was auch immer in dem Zusammenhang Superreiche heißt, sollen 75 Prozent reichen Steuer zahlen.
Das ist übrigens genau beziffert, was unter Superreich gemeint ist. Das wäre bei den 75 Prozent der Fall ist. Ich hab die Zahl jetzt gar nicht im Kopf. Sie steht im Programm. Und ganz lustig ist, ja eigentlich müsste sie sagen, also ich würde davon entlastet werden.
Sie verdient wahrscheinlich unter 7.000.
Und sie, die hier alle zuhören, verdienen im großen Teil auch alle unter 7.000. Sie würden ja offenbar davon entlastet werden.
Das ist absurd. Also der Wahlkampf im Journalismus abgebildet ist unglaublich.
Also ich kann ja noch verstehen, wenn da irgendwelche Multimillionäre und Journalisten zusammensitzen, die sagen uiuiui, da wird mir die Linke aber unangenehm. Und deswegen verschweigen wir das. Aber dass jetzt auch diese Leute da, die da irgendwie in der Zeit bisschen schreiben dürfen oder hier immer vor das Mikro können, dass die sich so solidarisieren mit den Reichen. Das ist ja dann wirklich so wie Hoss und Hopf sehen sich ja als die Kumpels von Elon Musk. Und hier sagen sie, ach oh, die wollen die super Reichen, was immer das meint, besteuern. Ja du wirst nie davon gemeint sein.
Ja vor allem, wenn man als Journalist 2025, einen Monat vor der Bundestagswahl das Wort Superreicher ausspricht und zu erkennen gibt, dass man selber keinen Begriff hat, also kein Konzept hinter diesem Begriff hat, dann muss man sich einen Urlaub nehmen und nacharbeiten. Also jeder braucht einen Begriff von Superreichtum. Wir haben Bücher, die heißen Superreich oder Crazy Rich. Crazy Rich. Und da wird es genau thematisiert. Also es ist wirklich ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz schlimm. So, Precht und Lanz haben ja auch einen sehr guten Podcast, finde ich, insbesondere weil Lanz immer gut dagegen hält. Und sie sind so in plauder Stimmung, die Precht dann mal kurz unterbricht, bis Lanz feststellt, ach so, nee, nee, nee, stopp, stopp, stopp, hab ich das nicht gemeint.
So, jedes Jahr werden in Deutschland zwischen drei und vierhundert Milliarden vererbt. Weißt du, wie viel der Staat davon einnimmt? Zehn Milliarden. So, das heißt, man kann in diesem Land sehr, sehr gut leben und zahlt dann auch seine 25 Prozent Kapitalertragssteuer, wenn man ein so großes Aktienpaket hat, dass man ausschließlich von den Gewinnen dieser Aktien leben kann, beispielsweise oder auch Immobilienbesitz. Und auch da, du zahlst, wenn du ein kleiner Immobilien, du hast ein kleines Häuschen, das vererbst du. So, dann wird die Erbschaftssteuer fällig. Wenn du groß genug bist und hast so viele Immobilien, dass du daraus sozusagen ein eigenes Unternehmen gründen kannst, zahlst du nichts. Dann wird einfach das Unternehmen sozusagen weitergegeben, dann sieht die Welt ganz anders aus.
Das heißt, ich weiß jetzt, welche Wahlempfehlung du Menschen gibst, die dich fragen, die Linkspartei zu wählen. Weil die, die möchten wir auf jeden Fall die Erbschaftssteuern erhöhen und die Schlupflöcher machen und Vermögenssteuer vergrößern und so weiter.
Andrea, mir geht es um was anderes. Mir geht es darum, dass wir schon, finde ich ernsthaft, und das ist ja ein Zusammenspiel, auch aus Medien und Politik und öffentlicher Wahrnehmung.
Nee, wir bleiben lieber im Gerede.
Mir geht es ja um was anderes. Ich wollte ja ernsthaft darüber reden. Also wenn in Deutschland jemand Milliardäre härter rannehmen will, weil sie das Geld haben, das uns allen gehört, macht gar keinen Sinn, dass der Kühne da in seinem Pool, Helena Steinhaus hat ja dieses Bild gezeigt, mit seinem Getränk irgendwie 40.000 pro Minute verballert, während man das Geld genauso gut in Infrastruktur, Schulen, was auch immer stecken könnte. So. Jedes Mal, wenn jemand an die Milliardäre ran will, gilt das als populistisch und damit nicht mehr im Diskurs. Deshalb es für mich nur eine Möglichkeit gibt, um alles zu retten. Diejenigen, die an die Milliardäre ran wollen und den Arsch in der Hose haben, es zu wollen, obwohl ihnen von allen Seiten gesagt wird, das ist aber populistisch, das geht aber in eine Neiddebatte, wie auch immer, genau diesen jetzt zu unterstützen, weil der Diskursraum in diese Richtung verbreitert werden muss. So, dass wir jetzt die Chance haben, den Diskursraum zu verbreitern, indem wir einfach bei der Bundestagswahl eine richtige Wahl treffen, ist ja, also ist eine tolle Einladung. Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, damit ist dann alles gelöst, es geht grundsätzlich um diesen Diskursraum, wir können nicht Haus und Hauptwiese überlassen und den Bizeps und jeder Einzelne und hier und das ist ein Naturfakt und so weiter, geht einfach nicht. Nur jetzt im Februar haben wir doch die Chance, einfach die Linke zu wählen, die nur diese Idee in den Raum stellt. Und das ist die richtige Idee. Und ich finde auch, das ist die einzige Idee, um die es gerade gehen soll politisch. Ich finde ja schon, sehr viele Sachen kann man auch jenseits der Politik regeln.
Ja, wir sind ja jetzt nicht hier sitzend und sagen, wir wollen das alles staatlich geregelt bekommen.
Als Gym muss man tatsächlich selber gehen. Und das tut einem auch gut und das ist auch zu empfehlen.
Sehr richtig.
So, das macht nicht der Politiker. Also das ist einfach nicht der Pizza-Lieferservice, der dann sagt, du hast einen Sixpack bestellt, hier, hier ins Sparren. Nee, das muss man selber machen. Aber an die Milliardäre, also das kann man nicht selber machen. Da braucht man jetzt jemanden, der diese Idee dort, wo es heikel wird, vorträgt.
Man muss natürlich dann auch darauf hoffen, dass seine Bevölkerung überhaupt sich noch für, wie du es nennen würdest, Mathematik interessiert. Also sich dafür interessiert, dass zwei plus zwei vier zum Beispiel sind. Ich will dir ein letztes Beispiel geben und zwar der allerletzte Clip, den ich ausgewählt habe. Der wurde mir geschickt von einem Hörer, der sagte, er redet doch immer über die Fakten und dann wird er so getan, als sei das doch alles nur Meinungen, beziehungsweise sind die Leute ja überhaupt nicht mehr für Fakten anfällig, sondern sagen, da lasse ich mich aber jetzt gar nicht drauf ein. Das ist ja, also wir haben jetzt eben gehört, Milliardär bescheuert, das ist ja populistisch. Wie ist es eigentlich so mit Rechnungen? Wir hören jetzt hier, das ist irgendein Reality-Format. Ich weiß nicht genau, was das ist. Da ist ein Comedian, Christal heißt der, der rechnet was vor und der Fußballer Mario Basler antwortet jetzt darauf. Und ich würde sagen, es ist tatsächlich unser Diskurs Deutschland im Jahr 2025.
Okay.
Zwei plus zwei mal zwei.
Acht.
Zwei plus zwei sind vier mal zwei sind acht.
Schnaschnase.
Hast du auch einen Punkt vor Strich?
Das interessiert mir nicht, die Scheiße.
Kommt mit deinen intellektuellen, äh, Scheiß-
Ich euer Ernst. Ich denke immer, ihr spielt das.
Nein.
Man muss aber dazu sagen, dass Mario dann schon auch Argumente liefert, dass man sagt, ja gut, die verstehe ich dann auch.
Punkt vor Strich gibt es bei mir nicht, die Scheiße.
Das ist doch aber keine Entscheidung, die du triffst.
Oh, das ist doch ein Scheiß.
Mit euer Punkt vor Strich hat es es früher gegeben.
Ja.
Die Gerichten haben das glaube ich erfunden.
Und der semi Scheiß trägt ein Punkt vor Strich.
Punkt vor Strich. Ist mir Scheiße egal.
Hat es das einfach schon früher gegeben? Ja.
Ja. So, okay, das ist sehr gut. Man kann sich leicht verrechnen, selbst wenn die Frage 2 plus 2 mal 2 ist.
So.
Man kann sich auch politisch verrechnen, wenn man einfach das nicht beachtet, wie die reinste Logik funktioniert. Ich will das nochmal kontrastieren mit dem zweiten großen Angebot. Nicht nur von Friedrich Merz, aber stellvertretend, es sind alle Stimmen im Grunde in diesem Tenor ein. Hauptsache nicht die echten Rechten regieren so, ne? Ja. Wir wollen die rechte Politik machen. Ich hab ja eben schon betont, in der Problemlage stimmen wir alle überein. Schule funktioniert nicht, Bus fährt nicht, alles kaputt, alles scheiße, es könnte alles besser sein. So, wir stimmen hier mit Peter Thiele bei ein, mit Horst und Hopf, mit David Graeber, mit Miriam. Man kann jetzt auch andere Meinungen haben und sagen, ne, ich find's geil wie's läuft, aber für den Fall, dass man diese Meinung teilt. So, man kann jetzt sagen, 20 Billionen Privatvermögen, davon 16 Billionen bei den 1%, das macht irgendwie keinen Sinn. Wir könnten dieses Kapital nehmen, um hier wieder was zu erarbeiten. Oder, und das ist jetzt sozusagen der Gegenentwurf, man wählt einfach irgendeine von diesen Parteien, die jetzt die Rechten kopiert, zum Beispiel Friedrich Merz.
Wir können mal reinhören, wie sich Merz zum Beispiel in Sachen Migration äußert.
Über drei Millionen Drittstaatsangehörige, die nach Deutschland kommen. Wenn sie diese Zahl sehen, dann kann man vielleicht noch etwas einfacher verstehen, warum es uns im Augenblick nicht gelingt. Zum Beispiel im Bereich der Schulen für eine gute Bildung zu sorgen. Warum es uns nicht gelingt, im Bereich der Gesundheits- und Krankenversorgung ausreichende Kapazitäten vorzuhalten. Und warum es uns auch nicht gelingt, etwa im Wohnungsmarkt genügend Wohnraum zu schaffen. Das ist einfach eine objektive Überforderung der Möglichkeiten unseres Landes.
Ja dazu muss man sagen, das war jetzt nur eine Pressekonferenz, die naturgemäß etwas gesitteter abläuft und auch der Ton ist dann ein bisschen gedämpfter.
Ja, gedämpfter Ton und gesitterter Ablauf.
Also ist das jetzt die richtige Einordnung?
Ja, wenn Friedrich Merz es ernst meint mit, die nehmen uns die Zahnarzttermine weg, dann ist es mir völlig egal in welcher Form er das vorträgt.
Ob er gebrüllt hat oder geflüstert.
Dann ist das einfach eine zwei plus zwei mal zwei ist acht Rechnung, bei der wir später feststellen, nee geht nicht auf, macht keinen Sinn. Also diese Mathematik stimmt einfach nicht. So und wenn dann die Antwort ist, ja minus acht dann? Nee, also wenn wir jetzt die Ausländer noch rausnehmen, geht als Recht nichts mehr. Also dann haben wir erst recht keine Schulsysteme und Ärzte und was auch immer. Also Teufelsküche. Hier ist jetzt grundlegend, Entscheidung zu treffen. Bitte nicht den Walomard bedienen, bitte nicht pro Gramme lesen, wer was verspricht oder so, sondern einfach nur diese eine zentrale Idee pro Partei. Find ich die gut oder nicht? Und dann trifft man seine Entscheidung. Aber ich würde nicht sagen, wen er wählen soll. Ihr sollt selber entscheiden und dann ins Gym.
Und dann ins Gym. Ja, natürlich. Oder wir gehen jetzt zum Schnitzelessen.
Willst du schon los? Okay. Ja, wir hören Robin Alexander dann als Teaser nächste Woche.
Ja oder dann spielen auch Robin Alexander noch.
Wir haben ja noch was Zeit. Ich finde es sehr gut, dass wir heute ein bisschen früher dran sind, weil ich habe Eile.
Aber es wird in diesem auch kurzen Monat viel passieren. Davon können wir fest ausgehen.
Wir haben mit dem Journalismus schon genug gehasst. Ja, heute ist gut, nächste Woche.
Nächste Woche im Teaser geht es da nochmal rund. Und wir werden, wie schon angekündigt, dann von Marc Schiritz das Buch lesen. Zu dumm für die Demokratie? Fragezeichen.
Wir sagen ja.
Mal schauen, welcher demokratietheoretische Ansatz da vorgestellt wird, ob ich damit d'accord gehen kann. Denn man kann natürlich auch mit einer solchen zu dumm für die Demokratie sehr gut den Staat absichern vor der Bevölkerung, vor dem Volk. Also von daher kann man das natürlich auch neoliberal auslegen, was ich jetzt Marc Schiritz nicht gleich unterstellen will, aber wir werden sehen und diskutieren, was da drin steckt. Ich will mir mal noch offenhalten, was ich sonst im Salon vorstelle. Du wahrscheinlich auch noch oder hast du schon was im Blick?
Vor, das Gemeinsinnbuch der Asmanns jetzt mal mitzubringen. Ich hatte also ich habe jetzt Zeit zu lesen. Ich glaube, das wird vielleicht also vom Titel und Thema her das Buch der Stunde für mich und Asmanns mag ich sowieso beide. Von daher wird das wahrscheinlich meine zweite. Also der Rest dann mal gucken. Aber wir können ja mal gucken, was so kommentiert wird zu dem, was heute im Bundestag geschah.
Ja.
Erst mal die Texte abwarten.
Und hier nochmal der deutliche Hinweis. Wir freuen uns sehr, wenn dieser Podcast geteilt wird. Das muss gar nicht nur in den sozialen Medien geschehen, sondern kann natürlich auch intern bei WhatsApp oder sonst wo laufen. Wir freuen uns auch über gute Bewertungen auf den entsprechenden Plattformen. Und ja, freuen uns, wenn wir vielleicht mit ein oder anderen Argumenten, die wir hier geäußert haben, auch bei Leuten gehörfinden, die uns noch nicht kennen, beziehungsweise die vielleicht sonst da gar nicht so zugänglich für sind. Denn tatsächlich steht ja, wie wir jetzt in aller Deutlichkeit gesehen haben, relativ viel auf dem Spiel. Die Lage ist tatsächlich diskursiv, so wie der Clip von Mario Barsta das jetzt abgebildet hat. Oder noch ein Beispiel, ich habe mich unterhalten mit einer Dame, Ende 50, die sich sehr über den Rechtsruck aufregte, über Trump und AfD und besonders Alice Weidel. Und überhaupt, wie sich alles weiter nach rechts entwickelt. Um dann das ganze zu schließen mit den Worten, haben sie gestern Dieter Nuhr gesehen? Es war wieder so witzig. Und dann merkt man natürlich, wenn man dann noch mal so zwei, drei Nachfragen stellt, dass ökonomisch zum Beispiel so gut wie nichts verstanden wird. Insofern ist da sehr viel zu tun. Wir können einen kleinen Beitrag leisten. Der Rest muss man sehen, wie das so geht. Wir freuen uns jedenfalls, wenn der Podcast unterstützt wird. Und wir freuen uns auch, wenn ihr den Salon abonniert. Das ist wie gesagt möglich am einfachsten über Steady auf neu20er.de auf den goldenen Button. Dann kommt man direkt zu dem Steady-Abo. Wenn man uns über Spotify hört, kann man auch dort gleich sich rüberleiten lassen. Apple ist auch eine Möglichkeit, um die Paywall zu durchschreiten. Und dann gibt es noch Patrick.
Ich schreibe nochmal die Case-Termine unten rein. Ich habe jetzt gar nicht nochmal nachgefragt, ob es schon, also ob es noch Karten gibt. Letztes Mal war ja noch das letzte Drittel offen.
Ja, genau. Die Termine von unseren Live-Auftritte, die findet ihr dann auch in der Beschreibung. Die erste Case im März ist schon komplett ausverkauft. Ich vermute die im Juni auch. Wir wollen aber im nächsten Salon auch noch einen Opern-Termin bekannt geben. Und wir geben im nächsten Salon bekannt, wie unser Sommer, wann unser Sommer-Event sein wird. Und was wir schon mal sagen können, wir werden dann keine Gäste haben, aber Publikumsfragen. Und ich habe ja eine Idee.
Fragen vom oder an das Publikum?
Vom Publikum. Wir werden Fragen beantworten des Publikums? Wir beantworten Fragen des Publikums nicht nur, sondern in einem Teil. Und ich werde dir gleich, wenn die Mikros aus sind, erzählen, wie ich mir das vorstelle, damit wir möglichst viele Fragen beantworten können.
Wir auktionieren die Fragen.
Einen schönen Monat.
Yes, haut rein. Bis dann. Okay, ich bin gespannt.